This is the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I, of course, am Elliot Kalin. Today we're covering the beginning section of Part 5, The Love of Power, chapters 25 and 26. That's pages 499 to 606 in my book. And later in this episode, our special book club guest is Mike Schur. He is the creator behind beloved sitcoms like Parks and Recreation, The Good Place, Brooklyn Nine-Nine, he was a producer and writer on The Office, and he's also written a book on
这是《99%隐形》对《权力经纪人》的深度解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。而我，当然是埃利奥特·卡林。今天我们要讲的是第五部分《对权力的热爱》的开篇章节，即第25章和第26章。在我的书中，这对应的是第499到606页。在本集的后半段，我们特别邀请到了图书俱乐部嘉宾迈克·舒尔。他是备受喜爱的情景喜剧如《公园与游憩》、《良善之地》、《荒唐分局》的幕后创作者，他曾担任《办公室》的制片人和编剧，他还写过一本关于
moral philosophy called How to be Perfect. Mike is a huge fan of The Power Broker, maybe the biggest fan of The Power Broker I've ever met, and he has cited this book as inspiration behind Parks and Rec. So on this episode, we're covering pages 499 to 606 in my book. That's the beginning of part five, The Love of Power, chapters 25 and 26. When we last left the power broker, Robert Moses had run for governor. He had been such an unlikable, unpleasant candidate that he lost more than any major party candidate had ever lost before and his reputation is tarnished. He's completely on his ass. But President Roosevelt, a unlikely savior, in an attempt to remove him for good, has an order issued stating that New York City
道德哲学的书，名为《如何成为一个完美的人》。迈克是《权力经纪人》的超级粉丝，也许是我见过的对《权力经纪人》最大的粉丝，他曾提到这本书是《公园与游憩》背后的灵感来源。所以在这期节目中，我们将讨论我书中的第499到606页。也就是第五部分《对权力的热爱》的开篇，第25章和第26章。上一次我们讲到权力经纪人时，罗伯特·摩西竞选了州长。他是一个极不讨喜、令人反感的候选人，以至于他的得票差距创下了主要政党候选人之最，他的声誉也因此受损。他彻底栽了跟头。但罗斯福总统这位不可思议的救星，为了彻底赶走他，下达了一项命令，规定纽约市
will get no more WPA money until it fires anyone holding both a city and a state office. This was an order written just to expel Moses. Moses leaks this to the press. He's able to frame this as the federal government trying to push around the people of New York City. And it is just what Moses needed to get his halo affixed back over his head. And under Mayor LaGuardia, Moses perfects the system
如果再不解雇任何同时担任市级和州级职务的人，就将一分钱的WPA（公共事业振兴署）资金也拿不到。这项命令完全就是为了驱逐摩西而量身定制的。摩西把这泄露给了媒体。他成功地将此事包装成联邦政府试图欺压纽约市人民。而这正是摩西重新戴上他的光环所需要的东西。在拉瓜迪亚市长的手下，摩西完善了这一体系：
providing physical achievements for politicians to run on while threatening to resign if he doesn't get his way, although LaGuardia finds a way to take the piss out of him in this regard a little bit. Over the course of the last section, Moses is even more flagrant about ignoring orders and laws that get in his way, and he's even more ruthless about just destroying people who are trying to stop him from achieving his ends. But at the same time, he's beginning to get stretched pretty thin. He's doing all these jobs around the city. Most of them are not as accomplished or as thoughtful as like Jones Beach.
为政客们提供可供竞选的实际政绩，同时以不顺从就辞职相威胁，尽管拉瓜迪亚在这方面总能找到办法稍微扫他的兴。在上一部分的过程中，摩西对于无视阻碍他的命令和法律变得更加肆无忌惮，而对于那些试图阻止他达到目的的人，他也变得更加冷酷无情。但与此同时，他开始感到有些分身乏术。他在全市各地兼任着所有这些职务。其中大多数并不像琼斯海滩那样富有成效或深思熟虑。
And it is very clear that he's underserving New York City's poor and nonwhite population. And we'll see more of that ruthlessness and neglect in this episode. Because what's clear that Carrow is getting to at the end of the last section was that this is not a man in love with his mission, a man in love with Parks. He's become a man who's just in love with power, the love of power. The love of power.
而且很明显，他对纽约市的穷人和非白人人口服务不足。在本集中，我们将看到更多这样的冷酷无情和漠视。因为卡罗在上一部分结尾所要表达的显而易见的一点是，这个人并非热爱他的使命，不是一个热爱公园的人。他已经变成了一个仅仅热爱权力、热爱权力本身的人。对权力的热爱。
That starts chapter 25 called Changing. I think it's like the longest chapter in the book, is it right? I believe so. This is a 75, 76 page chapter. Uh, it's kind of an omnibus chapter that encompasses a bunch of different things all under that heading of changing. And this is one of those times where I'm like,
这开始了名为《改变》的第25章。我想这可以说是书中最长的一章了吧？没错吧？我想是的。这是一章长达75、76页的章节。呃，这有点像是一部综合性章节，涵盖了在“改变”这个主题之下的各种不同事情。而这也是那种让我忍不住想——
Mr. Carroll, maybe you could just put this chapter up into some smaller pieces. It's a big chapter. That, and maybe this one isn't served by being called changing or driving and changing. Like there's some specificity in these stories that I think might have been broken out a little bit better.
卡罗先生，也许你可以把这一章拆成一些更小的部分。这章太大了。那一章，也许它不应该叫作“改变”或者“开车与改变”。我觉得这些故事里有一些具体细节，如果能稍微拆分一下可能会更好。
But regardless, I actually really dig all this stuff. Like it does like it's accumulating to show what type of person Robert Moses has become kind of at the height of his power. Yes, and in a way chapter five is in some some way there's some great stuff in it, but in some ways it almost feels like Robert Caro is, is like, yeah, yeah, let's get through through this, I want to get to chapter 26, let's get to chapter 26. And so he's like, I don't want a whole bunch of chapters.
但无论如何，我其实真的很喜欢所有这些内容。就像它在不断累积，展示罗伯特·摩西在其权力巅峰之时究竟变成了什么样的人。是的，从某种程度上讲，第五部分里有一些非常精彩的内容，但在某些方面，它几乎让人觉得罗伯特·卡罗也是在想，好吧，好吧，让我们赶紧看完这个，我想看第26章，让我们进入第26章吧。所以他就像是在说，我不想搞一大堆章节。
We'll just have one big chapter and then we'll get to the, we'll get to the family stuff, so let's jump into it. If there's a lot of numbers in this chapter, I apologize listeners, we're going to be doing a lot of numbers. It's a long chapter. But then chapter 26 is such a, it's such a dramatic kind of personal story at the end of this large scale metropolitan municipal story. So you'll see this, this episode, I think you'll feel is going to be really well balanced, even though it's going to seem like we spend a lot of time talking about how much things cost
我们就留一个大章节，然后我们就可以进入家庭部分了，所以让我们直接切入正题吧。如果这一章里有很多数字，听众朋友们，我向你们道歉，我们要念很多数字。这是一个很长的章节。但随后的第26章是如此具有戏剧性、如此具有个人色彩的故事，它发生在这样大规模的都市市政故事的结尾。所以你会发现，这一章，你们会觉得平衡得非常好，尽管看起来我们花了很多时间在讨论东西花了多少钱
and how many thousand feet of riff-rap are being used, you know, in projects. So we start this chapter, it's ironic that it's called changing because Robert Carroll starts by saying that arrogance is just a basic part of Moses' nature. He's positing that just as it was for his mother, for his grandmother, arrogance comes naturally to him.
以及在项目中用了多少千英尺的护岸石，你知道的。所以我们开始这一章时，它叫《改变》具有极大的讽刺意味，因为罗伯特·卡罗在一开始就指出，傲慢只是摩西天性中的一个基本部分。他提出，就像对他母亲、对他的奶奶一样，傲慢对他来说是自然而然的。
That's something that is not changing in him. And that once he had a taste of power, he came to need power and dominance for its own sake. And this is why he thinks Moses seems to start going out of his way to antagonize people just with impunity. Before he would do it to get his way, or because sometimes he's just kind of a jerk, but now he seems to be getting pleasure
那是他身上没有改变的东西。而且一旦他尝到了权力的滋味，他便开始为了权力和统治本身而需要权力和统治。这就是为什么他认为摩西开始无缘无故地、甚至是有恃无恐地去激怒别人。以前他这样做是为了达到目的，或者有时他只是有点混蛋，但现在他似乎从中获得了乐趣
just out of stepping on people. And he goes through a couple of examples. There's a reproduction of a jerk, but now he seems to be getting pleasure just out of stepping on people. And he goes through a couple of examples. There's a reproduction of Mount Vernon in Prospect Park, my own home park when I lived in Brooklyn. And he wants to tear it down and the community councils of the city of New York, they don't want it to happen.
仅仅是通过踩踏别人。他列举了好几个例子。这里对一个混蛋的重现——但现在他似乎仅仅从踩踏别人中获得乐趣。他列举了好几个例子。布鲁克林展望公园里有一处弗农山的复制品，那是我住在布鲁克林时的自家公园。他想把它拆掉，而纽约市的社区委员会并不希望这样发生。
And the council is powerless. Robert Moses could just ignore them. He has total power of parks, but instead he publicizes their opposition so that he can then plant quotes in the papers that are kind of like witty rip-hosts to them. He's like, I haven't heard anything from any reasonable people about this. And the reporter's like, what about the community council of the city of New York? And he goes, exactly.
而委员会却无能为力。罗伯特·摩西可以直接无视他们。他对公园拥有绝对权力，但他偏不，他反而是大肆宣扬他们的反对意见，以便随后在报纸上安插一些言论，有点像是对他们的机智回击。他说：“我没有从任何讲理的人那里听到关于这件事的任何说法。”而记者问：“那纽约市的社区委员会呢？”他回答：“正是。”
And it's like, so you're going out of your way just to get that, that bon mot in the papers. And he goes all the way to the Rockaways to give a speech to a local association, just so we can tell them that their airport, Floyd Bennett Field, stinks, that it's not very good. Like, he didn't have to go out there. The Rockaways is not an easy jaunt from where he lives. There's a local newspaper that criticizes him,
这就好像是，你大老远跑这一趟，纯粹为了在报纸上抖个机灵。他甚至一路跑到洛克威去给一个当地协会做演讲，纯粹是为了告诉他们，他们的机场——弗洛伊德·贝尼特机场——烂透了，说它不怎么好。你看，他本不必大老远跑去那里的。从他住的地方去洛克威可不是一趟轻松的旅程。有一家当地报纸批评了他，
so he essentially runs it out of business. These are powerless people, really. They can't really stop him, but he just goes out of his way to step on them. Yeah, and one of the ones I found most poignant is this young woman who works for Mayor LaGuardia, Pearl Bernstein, she's a secretary at the Board of Estimate, and all she's doing is doing what LaGuardia tells her to,
于是他基本上就让这家报纸倒闭了。这些人其实毫无权力。他们根本阻止不了他，但他就是特意要去踩他们一脚。是的，我发现最辛酸的其中一个故事，是这个在拉瓜迪亚市长手下工作的年轻女性，珀尔·伯恩斯坦，她是估价委员会的一名秘书，而她所做的所有事情都只是听从拉瓜迪亚的指示，
like puts off Moses a little bit, does this, does that, whatever, and he just makes it a mission to destroy this woman's life. He makes life so horrible for her and is constantly abusive to her, and he knows she's just a proxy for LaGuardia, that she has no control over what she's doing. But he can't fight LaGuardia quite the same way. He can't belittle LaGuardia the same way. So he goes after her. And there's a story Carol tells of one of Moses' aides making a suggestion at a lunch meeting and Moses going, now you're just a swabby on this ship.
比如稍微应付一下摩西，做这个，做那个，诸如此类，而摩西却把毁掉这个女人的生活当成了一项使命。他把她的生活折磨得痛苦不堪，对她进行持续不断的辱骂，而且他知道她只是拉瓜迪亚的一个代罪羔羊，她根本无法控制自己在做什么。但他不能以同样的方式去跟拉瓜迪亚对抗。他不能以同样的方式贬低拉瓜迪亚。于是他就拿她开刀。卡罗还讲了一个故事：摩西的一个助手在一次午餐会上提出了一个建议，摩西却说：“现在你只是这艘船上的一个水手长。”
Do you understand? And then going, do you understand? Do you understand? Until the guy finally says, yes, sir. And two things about that. One, it's so unnecessary. And two, Robert Moses, he cannot avoid maritime water stuff. That's the analogy he goes to immediately. You're a swabby on this ship. He just loves the water,
你明白吗？然后接着说：“你明白吗？你明白吗？”直到那个人终于说：“是的，长官。”关于这件事有两点。第一，这完全没必要。第二，罗伯特·摩西，他就是避不开海事水上那一套。那是他立刻就能想到的类比。你是这艘船上的一个水手长。他就是热爱水，
even when he was attacking people. And he starts to, he's a big guy, he's got powerful arms from all that swimming, and he's physically threatening to people. And Kara tells the story of Manhattan Borough President Stanley M. Isaacs, who will come up a few times in this book as a opponent of Moses. They're at a board of estimate meeting and Isaac says,
即使是在攻击别人的时候也是如此。然后他开始——他是个大块头，常年游泳让他拥有强壮的胳膊，他会在体格上威胁别人。卡罗讲了曼哈顿区长斯坦利·M·艾萨克的的故事，他在本书中会多次出现，作为摩西的反对者。他们在一次估价委员会会议上，艾萨克说：
these are misleading cost figures. And Moses takes a swing in his direction and says, I'd like to punch you in the nose. And it's like, that's not, there's no, it's not acceptable. It's not acceptable for an adult human to say that to an adult, another adult. Yeah. And I think this is the one part where it is Robert Moses changing. Like he's a very pugnacious individual, but usually his opponents are people who have similar power to him. You know, they're a governor, they're a president
这些是误导性的成本数据。而摩西朝他的方向挥了挥拳头说：“我很想打你的鼻子。”这就好比，这不对，这是不可接受的。一个成年人对另一个成年人说这种话是不可接受的。是的。而且我认为这是罗伯特·摩西真正改变的一个部分。就像他是一个非常好斗的人，但通常他的对手都是那些拥有与他相似权力的人。你知道的，他们是州长，他们是总统，
who should be doing better things with his time, you know? But now these are really lowly people that he's just bullying, you know? And this is kind of a different, like just more extreme Moses. Yes, as opposed to, exactly, before he was a fighter who wouldn't let people get in his way, now he's a bully. He's bullying people.
本该把时间花在更有意义的事情上，对吧？但现在，这些全都是真正底层的普通人，而他只是在霸凌他们，你知道吗？这有点像是一个不同的、更加极端的摩西。是的，相比之下，确切地说，以前他是一个绝不让别人挡道的斗士，而现在他成了一个恶霸。他在霸凌别人。
And there's always been a little bit of that in him, but now he has the power to really run rampant with it because knowing he can't get in his way. And there's a story that Carol goes into detail on. We'll see how much detail we go into it. I think there's a lot of good details, but you may get bored of it. I don't know, about the Columbia Yacht Club,
他骨子里一直都有点这种倾向，但现在他拥有了真正的权力，可以借此肆无忌惮地胡作非为，因为他知道没人能阻挡他。卡罗详细讲述了一个故事。我们要看看我们会讲得多详细。我认为有很多精彩的细节，但你们可能会觉得无聊。我不知道，是关于哥伦比亚游艇俱乐部的，
which on the face of it doesn't seem like the most sympathetic group of people just from the name, Columbia Yacht Club, which on the face of it doesn't seem like the most sympathetic group of people just from the name Columbia Yacht Club. They've been on 86th Street since 1888. So that's almost 50 years by the point the story is happening. This is 1934. They paid a low rent to the city for the land because they had put the money in to develop and build and maintain this marina that was a place for guests of the city to dock their ships. They get involved with fleet week and things like that. When British royalty stopped by, you know, that's where they dock their yachts and things like that. So March, 1934, Moses says that the club is in the way
从字面上看，单凭“哥伦比亚游艇俱乐部”这个名字，它似乎并不是一个最能引起同情心的群体，单凭名字“哥伦比亚游艇俱乐部”来看，它似乎并不是一个最能引起同情心的群体。自1888年以来，他们就一直在86街。所以到这个故事发生的时候，这已经快50年了。那是1934年。他们向城市支付很低的租金来使用这片土地，因为他们曾出资开发、建造并维护了这个码头，这里是城市访客停靠船只的地方。他们参与舰队周之类的活动。当英国皇室成员造访时，你知道的，那是他们停泊游艇的地方诸如此类。因此，在1934年3月，摩西表示该俱乐部挡了
of the West Side Improvement, which is this huge West Side plan that we're gonna talk about a lot in this chapter. This has been his dream for years. And he says, we're gonna have to tear this yacht club down. And the members of the club are like, well, can we stay through September? Because we promised to help host during fleet week.
西区改善工程的路，这是一个巨大的西区规划，我们在这一章里会经常讨论它。这是他多年的梦想。他说：“我们不得不拆掉这个游艇俱乐部。”俱乐部的成员们则说：“嗯，我们能留到九月份吗？因为我们承诺要在舰队周期间帮忙接待。”
And if anyone, I don't know if other cities have fleet week the same way, but in New York fleet week is, it's a big thing. Like there's sailors all over the place. People love it. And, uh, Moses says that's fine because the West side improvement is such a big project. It's going to take me so long to get to the part where we need to tear you down. And then he's like, actually, I kind of want to change that building
如果有人——我不知道其他城市有没有类似形式的舰队周，但在纽约，舰队周是一件大事。到处都是水手。人们非常喜欢它。呃，摩西说这没问题，因为西区改善工程是一个如此宏大的项目。要推进到需要拆除你们的那一部分，还要花很长的时间。然后他又说：“其实，我有点想把那栋建筑
into a restaurant and I want to start working on that now. So you can stay through September if you donate the building to the parks department and the club Commodore, and it's unclear how this happens, in a call with Moses agrees to this plan. We'll stay through September and we'll give you the building, but agrees in such a way that it irritates Moses in a way that the Commodore can never really figure out. And the next day they get an angry letter
改成餐厅，我想现在就开始着手那项工作。所以只要你们把建筑捐给公园部门，你们就可以留到九月份。”俱乐部准将——目前还不清楚这一切是怎么发生的——在与摩西的一次通话中同意了这个计划。我们将留到九月份，并把建筑交给你们，但他同意的方式让摩西感到恼火，而准将却怎么也想不明白是为什么。第二天，他们收到了一封愤怒的信，
from Moses saying they have to vacate in 12 days and anything they leave behind will be considered abandoned property. And Moses goes to the press and he runs his strategy. This is the private interests versus the public good. These wealthy yacht owners, they're standing in the way of this big public improvement and the press just runs these statements without question. No criticism, they don't investigate it. Why would you investigate it? The champion of the parks is up against
来自摩西，信中说他们必须在12天内腾空房屋，他们留下的任何东西都将被视为无主财产。摩西随后找到媒体，开始推行他的策略。这就是私人利益对决公共利益。这些富有的游艇主们正在阻碍这项伟大的公共改善工程，而媒体则对这些声明照单全收，毫无异议。没有批评，他们不进行调查。你为什么要调查呢？公园的捍卫者正在与
the Columbia Yacht Club. It's a yacht club. Like they haven't seen 1980s movies yet in the 1930s, but they know, they can guess. Yacht club owners are kind of, for the average New Yorker, they can't have a yacht. And the club, they apply to the state Supreme Court for an injunction.
哥伦比亚游艇俱乐部对抗。那可是个游艇俱乐部。虽然他们在20世纪30年代还没看过80年代的电影，但他们懂，他们能猜到。对于普通纽约人来说，游艇俱乐部的老板们——他们自己是买不起游艇的。俱乐部向州最高法院申请了禁令。
And the court hearing shows that a lot of Moses attacks are based on just outright lies. And the court issues an injunction, but Robert Moses, does he, he doesn't do injunctions. He's like Andrew Jackson, tell the court, you enforce your own injunction, you know? And he has already sent two steam shovels and they literally cut off the dirt roads
而法庭听证会显示，摩西的许多攻击完全是基于赤裸裸的谎言。法院颁布了禁令，但是罗伯特·摩西会理睬吗？他才不管什么禁令呢。他就像安德鲁·杰克逊一样，告诉法院：你们自己去执行你们的禁令吧！他已经派了两台蒸汽铲车，直接切断了通往
leading to the clubhouse. So it's very hard to get to this clubhouse now. The next day, the power gets shut off and the people from the clubhouse, they get in touch with Con Ed and the Con Ed goes, oh yeah, someone from the yacht club called and told us to shut the power off. And it's clearly someone from the park department
俱乐部会所的土路。所以现在要想去这个会所变得非常困难。第二天，电力被切断了，会所的人联系了联合爱迪生电力公司（Con Ed），而联合爱迪生公司却说：“哦，是的，游艇俱乐部有人打电话来，让我们把电断了。”显然是公园部门的某个人
has called pretending they're from the club. While that's being sorted out, a group of park employees combined, they're like, oh yeah, we heard there was a problem with the water main. So we're just gonna dig it up and remove it. And they're just like, this is, it is one thing after another way of forcing them out. And the the board of aldermen of the city demands Moses rescinds the eviction order and he just ignores them. He doesn't have to. And in the end, the club members have
打电话假装自己是俱乐部的人。正当这件事还在处理时，一群公园员工联合起来，他们说：“哦，对了，我们听说水管出了问题。所以我们这就把它挖出来运走。”他们就是这样，一波接一波地强行把他们赶出去。市议会要求摩西撤销驱逐令，而他直接无视了他们。他根本没必要理会。最后，俱乐部成员不得不
to leave months early. Moses tears the building down. And later on, Caro reports that when someone else asked Moses, why did you do this to them? He said, because they were rude to me. That's amazing. And we don't even know what the rudeness was. As far as the guy from the club knows, he just said, yes, okay, we'll agree to your proposal. Yeah. I mean, a bully with this type of weaponry at his fingertips,
提前数月离开。摩西拆了这座建筑。后来，卡罗报道说，当其他人问摩西“你为什么要对他们做这种事”时，他说：“因为他们对我很粗鲁。”这太绝了。我们甚至都不知道所谓的粗鲁到底是什么。据俱乐部的那个人所知，他当时只是说：“好的，行，我们同意你的提议。”是的。我的意思是，一个拥有这种武器库的恶霸触手可及，
like to bring in, you know, steam shovels, to cut off the road, to bring in Con Ed, to bring in the people to shut off the water. I mean, all that sort of stuff is just, that is a stunning amount of power for a person who is not mature enough to wield it. Not mature enough to wield it, and also not an elected official. You can say, the last president before the current one,
比如调来蒸汽铲车，切断道路，搬出联合爱迪生，叫人来关水。我的意思是，所有这些事情，对于一个心智不够成熟、无法驾驭它的人来说，拥有如此惊人的权力。心智不够成熟，无法驾驭它，而且他还不是民选官员。你可以说，现任总统之前的上一任总统，
he was a bully, but he was, you know, considering our weird election system, he was elected to that office. You know, some people had decided he deserved it. Whereas with Moses, the people who decided he deserved this power are other elected officials, but it's not like the people of New York were like, yeah, yeah, we elected him to do this stuff. And these goals are not just bullying. They also help Moses achieve his goals by making people less likely to cross him. And Caro quotes Judge Jacob Lutzke talking like a New York judge where he says, if you know that every time you get in a guy's way,
他是个恶霸，但他——你知道的，考虑到我们奇怪的选举系统——他是通过选举担任那个职位的。有些人决定了他配得上这个职位。然而对于摩西来说，决定他配得上这种权力的人是其他民选官员，但并不是说纽约人民曾投票表示：对，对，我们选他来干这些事。这些目标不仅仅是霸凌。它们还通过让人们不太敢惹他，来帮助摩西实现他的目标。卡罗引用了雅各布·鲁茨克法官的话，他说话就像个纽约法官，他说：如果你知道每次你挡了某个家伙的路，
he's gonna kick you in the balls, you make pretty damn sure you don't get in his way, right? And yeah, if it's, I mean, this is a judge talking, you know, that's from the, not from the bench, I assume, but that's good advice. If you know a guy is gonna kick you in the balls, don't get close enough to his feet. And so the people in the city bureaucracy
他都会狠狠踢你的蛋蛋，那你就会非常确定自己绝对不会去挡他的路，对吧？是的，如果——我的意思是，这是一位法官在说话，你知道的，我想这不是在法庭上说的，但这倒是个好建议。如果你知道这家伙会踢你的蛋蛋，就别离他的脚太近。因此，城市官僚机构里的人
are now making a habit just to stay away from Moses, not to just to let him have his way because they know he's such a troublemaker. And it's almost like Robert Caro needs to remind us just the sheer power that he has at his hands. He's not just being a bully to the Columbia Yacht Club. He spends a page talking about the literal physical changes to the map of New York that Robert Moses is making. He's creating 5,000 acres of new land. He's joining islands together
现在都养成了一种习惯，那就是离摩西远远的，不要去挡他的路，由着他去，因为他们知道这家伙是个大麻烦。这几乎让人觉得罗伯特·卡罗需要提醒我们，他手中握有的权力简直大得惊人。他不仅仅是对哥伦比亚游艇俱乐部耍横。他用了一整页的篇幅来讲述罗伯特·摩西对纽约地图所进行的字面意义上的物理改造。他在创造5000英亩的新土地。他在把各个岛屿连在一起
to make larger met land masses. He's built hundreds of parks and bridges. The shape of the city, the physical reality of the city is in his hands. And so beyond just pushing out yacht clubs, you know, tearing down their houses, he's, he's literally changing the map of the city in a way that nobody probably should have the power to do, but certainly not someone who is accountable to nobody and it's only going to get less accountable as time goes on. I mean, he opens 255 playgrounds in the 1930s. He just makes a big deal out of each one of their openings and he numbers them in the press
来形成更大的陆地。他修建了数以百计的公园和桥梁。这座城市的轮廓，这座城市的物理现实，都掌握在他的手中。因此，除了把游艇俱乐部赶走、拆毁他们的房屋之外，他还在字面意义上改变着这座城市的地图，这种权力大概是任何本不该拥有的，尤其是绝对不应该掌握在一个不对任何人负责的人手中，而且随着时间的推移，这种问责只会越来越少。我的意思是，他在20世纪30年代开放了255个游乐场。他每次开放游乐场都要大张旗鼓，
so they can keep a count of his tally. Playground 145, it just opened. Playground 146, it opened. But what is clear is if you sort of pay attention to where these playgrounds are, he's really only putting playgrounds in the wealthier neighborhoods and he's really ignoring the playgrounds in the neighborhoods that need it the most.
并且在媒体上为它们编号，以便大家能统计他的政绩。第145号游乐场，刚刚开放。第146号游乐场，开放了。但显而易见的是，如果你稍微注意一下这些游乐场都在哪里，你就会发现他实际上只在较富裕的社区修建游乐场，而他却在极大程度上忽视了那些最需要游乐场的社区。
Specifically, he is building a lot of playgrounds in the comfortable areas of the city and the least amount of playgrounds in the area of the city inhabited by the city's 400,000 black residents, 200,000 of them are children. And Moses is not really interested in providing safe places for them to play. They need safe places to play. And the black community in New York is calling out to him specifically,
具体来说，他在城市里舒适的区域建造了大量的游乐场，而在城市里居住着全市40万黑人居民（其中20万是儿童）的区域，游乐场所建寥寥无几。摩西对为他们提供安全的游戏场所并没有真正的兴趣。他们确实需要安全的游戏场所。纽约的黑人社区一直在向他发出呼吁，
to the city government and to him, our children need playgrounds, they need safe places to go, but he doesn't wanna do it. And the press is not running the story. Moses refuses to build playgrounds in black neighborhoods. They're running the story. Look at all these playgrounds.
向市政府向他呼吁：我们的孩子们需要游乐场，他们需要安全的地方可去，但他就是不愿这么做。媒体也没有报道这个新闻。摩西拒绝在黑人社区修建游乐场。他们报道的新闻是：看看所有这些游乐场！
Look at all these playgrounds. 255 playgrounds. This is amazing. And if anyone asks Moses, what about playgrounds in slum areas? He says, I've done a lot for the children of the slums. And the papers are like, yeah, he said it folks. He's doing a lot.
看看所有这些游乐场！255个游乐场！这太棒了！如果有人问摩西：“贫民区里的游乐场怎么办？”他会说：“我已经为贫民区的孩子们做了很多了。”而报纸则会说：“没错，大家都听到了，他说他正在做很多事呢。”
And beyond playgrounds, this is where Caro talks about swimming pools. And there's a detail in here that was one of the things that always stuck with me in the 20 years after I first read this book, where Caro is talking about how swimming pools were particularly personally important to Robert Moses. He loves swimming.
除了游乐场，卡罗还在这里谈到了游泳池。这里有一个细节是我在第一次读这本书后的20年里一直铭记在心的，卡罗在书中谈到游泳池对罗伯特·摩西具有特别的个人重要性。他热爱游泳。
There were very few pools in the city, public pools. And now Moses in the 1930s, he's building all these public pools and he's putting a lot of his own personal attention because he likes, he's not a kid, he's not going to play on muggy bars or on a slide or something like that or you know, but he is going to, he is going to go swim, not in those pools, not with the regular people, but you know what I mean, he likes swimming. No.
当时城里的公共泳池非常少。而现在摩西在20世纪30年代建造了所有这些公共泳池，并且倾注了大量他个人的专注，因为他喜欢——他可不是个小孩子，他不会去玩攀爬架或滑梯之类的东西，或者你知道的，但他确实要去游泳，不是去那些泳池，不是和普通人一起，但你知道我的意思，他喜欢游泳。不。
No. And he's putting all the little touches he's known for. Kara talks about how the problem was always, how do you get people to wash their feet before they walk into a public pool and they invent these foot cleansing troughs that you have to step into. They're too wide for you to jump over or step over that have like antibacterial stuff. So you have to get this stuff on your feet. And it's just all these kind of ingenious solutions to making public pools possible. And he builds 10 of these huge public pools and one of them is built in Harlem at 146th street. And Robert Moses is determined,
不。他加入了所有他标志性的小设计。卡罗谈到，当时面临的问题一直是：如何让人在走进公共泳池之前先把脚洗干净？于是他们发明了这种你必须踏入其中的足部清洁槽。它设计得太宽了，你根本没法一步跨过去或跳过去，里面含有类似抗菌剂的东西。所以你必须让你的脚沾上这些东西。这只是一系列让公共泳池得以实现的巧妙解决方案。他修建了10个这种巨大的公共泳池，其中一个就建在哈莱姆区的146街。罗伯特·摩西下定决心，
this is the pool that New Yorkers of color are gonna use. I don't want New Yorkers of color. He wouldn't have said New Yorkers of color, but you know what I mean. And white people, I don't want them mixing at these pools. Some kind of trouble is gonna erupt. There's gonna be fights or something, you know, it just can't happen.
这将是纽约有色人种要使用的泳池。我可不希望纽约的有色人种——他当时不会说“有色人种”，但你们懂我的意思——和白人混杂在这些泳池里。那样肯定会出乱子。会有打架之类的事件发生，你知道的，绝对不能发生这种事。
And so I want this pool up there. That's the one that black people are going to use. And there's one pool in particular that is seen as the one with the biggest threat of race mixing, and that's in East Harlem, which was at the time a white neighborhood, but it's close enough to the black parts of Harlem and to the Puerto Rican parts of Spanish Harlem to worry Robert Moses. And Paul Wendels is like, how are you going to do it Robert Moses? How are you going to keep people of color from using that pool? And he tells them his solution is, well, first, we're only going to hire white lifeguards. That goes without saying. But secondly, the other pools in the city, they have heaters that are going to keep them at 70 degrees. This pool,
所以我要把这个泳池建在那儿。那是黑人将要使用的泳池。其中有一个泳池被视为种族混杂风险最大的一个，那就是东哈莱姆区的那个，当时那里是个白人社区，但它离哈莱姆区的黑人区和西班牙哈莱姆区的波多黎各人区足够近，这让罗伯特·摩西感到担忧。保罗·温德尔斯就问：“罗伯特·摩西，你打算怎么做？你将如何阻止有色人种使用那个泳池？”而摩西告诉他，他的解决办法是：首先，我们只招募白人救生员。这是不言而喻的。但其次，城里的其他泳池都配有加热器，能保持在70华氏度。这个泳池，
we're not going to heat it because according to Moses, black people do not like cold water. And Robert Carroll can't say that that's the reason why, but they find that New Yorkers of color who live close to that pool instead go to that 146 street pool. Even though it's much farther away. If they live three blocks from this pool, they'd rather travel three miles to the other pool. And it always stuck with me, the idea that like, well, you know, of course, black people hate cold water.
我们不加热，因为据摩西所说，黑人不喜欢冷水。罗伯特·卡罗无法证明这就是原因所在，但他们发现，住在那个泳池附近的纽约有色人种宁愿去那个146街的泳池。尽管它远得多。如果他们离这个泳池只有三个街区，他们也宁愿长途跋涉三英里去另一个泳池。这件事一直留在我的脑海里，那种认为“嗯，你知道的，当然啦，黑人讨厌冷水，
So we got to keep this pool cold. And it seems both a weird stereotype. It's not one that I had encountered before I read it in this book, but also such a petty thing to do and such a gross thing to do to say like, I gotta do anything I can to make this pool unpalatable to the people nearby that I don't want using it. There's such a casual kind of unquestioned racism about it
所以我们得让这个泳池保持冰凉”的想法。这既是一个奇怪的刻板印象——在我读这本书之前我从未遇到过这种说法——同时也是一件极其卑鄙、极其粗俗的事情，仿佛在说：我得想尽一切办法让这个泳池对我不想让它使用的附近居民毫无吸引力。这里面有一种如此随意的、不容置疑的种族主义，
that I find really shocking, really astounding. Yeah, it's really awful. Yeah, I just kind of like, I'm struck by it all the time, how many ways this poison in his mind sort of comes out and the things he builds, it know, it's just unpleasant. And of course we'd be, I'd be remiss if we gave the impression that Robert Moses was the one racist in an otherwise beautifully integrated and, and colorblind world, you know, that he, he was, that he was the, he was the snake
让我觉得非常震惊，非常不可思议。是的，这真的很糟糕。是的，我总是为此感到震惊，他脑海中的这种毒素究竟以多少种方式流露出来，体现在他建造的事物中，你知道的，这真令人不快。当然，如果我们给人的印象是罗伯特·摩西是一个在一个原本美丽融合且不分肤色的世界里唯一的种族主义者，那我们就大错特错了，你知道的，他——他就是那个
in the garden, you know, in this one, it's, I'm sure he can get away with this stuff partly because it's except, I mean, Robert Carrot doesn't call call Paul Wendles a racist in the book, but it's not like he then recounts Paul Wendles saying, Oh Bob, you can't do that. Oh, that's terrible. You know, it's, it's just kind of either tolerated or accepted or believed in by so many people, uh, which we talked a little bit about in, uh, the previous episode. So, and then Robert Carroll goes out of his way to talk about how Robert Moses
伊甸园里的蛇，你知道的，在这件事上，我确信他能逍遥法外，部分原因是因为这是可以被接受的——我的意思是，罗伯特·卡罗在书中并没有称保罗·温德尔斯为种族主义者，但这并不是说他随后会记录保罗·温德尔斯说：“哦，鲍勃，你不能这么做。哦，这太糟糕了。”你知道的，这只是被许多人容忍、接受或信仰着，
has built this immense stadium complex on Randall's Island. It has 22,000 seats and it is usually empty. The first five years, it never sells out. It's attended usually in the hundreds. And part of the problem is that you can't get there without a car. There's no public transit at the time going there because Moses does not want public transit, he doesn't want buses going to Randall's Island. And so it's kind of biting him in the end that
我们在上一集里稍微讨论过这一点。然后罗伯特·卡罗特意大书特书了罗伯特·摩西如何在兰德尔岛上建造了这个庞大的体育场综合体。它拥有22,000个座位，但通常都是空的。在前五年里，它的票从来没有售罄过。观看人数通常只有几百人。而问题的一部分在于，如果不开车根本到不了那里。当时那里没有公共交通，因为摩西不想要公共交通，他不希望有公交车开往兰德尔岛。所以到了最后，这就有点自食其果了，
this stadium he built is under attended because he made it hard for people to get there. Yeah, totally, totally. And this is when we get to the section that I like to call more bridges, more problems, where, or more parkways, more problems, where we start getting, we get into the section about how little good a lot of these parkways need to be doing
他建造的这座体育场由于他让人们难以抵达而导致上座率不足。是的，完全如此。这就是我们来到那个我喜欢称之为“更多桥梁，更多麻烦”的部分，或者叫“更多公园大道，更多麻烦”，在那里我们开始进入这样一部分：在本书一直在处理的大规模交通流量中，这些公园大道到底能起到多大的一点好作用。
in the massive scale of traffic that the book has been dealing with. So we start, it's the summer of 1936, the Grand Central Interboro and the Laurelton Parkways, famous names in the hallowed halls of parkways. They've opened up. This means Moses has now built a hundred miles of new parkways since he revealed his big parkway plan in 1924. And the newspapers are like, the traffic problem has been solved for generations. And then there's a little bit of blank space on the page. And then the next paragraph starts, the new parkways solved the problem for about three weeks. And this is, I love, it's such a, it's such a New Yorkie way to say it. Not, you know, and yet there seem to be problems
所以我们开始时，那是1936年的夏天，大中央干线、伊利博罗和劳尔顿公园大道——这些是在公园大道神圣殿堂里大名鼎鼎的名字——开通了。这意味着自1924年公布其宏大的公园大道规划以来，摩西现在已经修建了一百英里的新公园大道。报纸们纷纷宣称：“几代人的交通问题已经得到了解决。”然后页面上留白了一小段。接着下一段开始：“新的公园大道大约把问题解决了三个星期。”我太喜欢这个了，这真是太有纽约风格的表述了。不是，你知道的，然而似乎还是有
with the, just like, eh, it's not over for about three weeks. It's a, it's, and we see this, we start this pattern here where, which we can go into more detail or we cannot if we don't have to, where a bridge or a parkway opens up, the Triborough Bridge opens up, the Wantok Expressway opens up, and people say, well, this is it, this is gonna take care of the traffic.
各种问题，就像是，呃，大概持续了三个星期就没了吧。这是一个——我们在这里看到了这种模式，我们可以深入探讨，也可以略过——一座桥或一条公园大道开通了，三勒博桥开通了，万托克高速公路开通了，人们说：“好了，就是这个，这下能解决交通问题了。”
And then within a few weeks or a few months, the traffic is worse than it was before. The parkways and bridges are becoming jammed almost immediately. But at the same time, the old roads have just as much traffic as they did before. Somehow these bridges and these roads are bringing more cars in, which is they're creating even more of a need, which is then being filled. And Moses's only solution to any of this stuff is to just build more bridges and roads. And Roman, you understand urban infrastructure more than I do. What's going on here? What's going on in this situation?
然后不出几周或几个月，交通状况甚至比以前更糟糕了。公园大道和桥梁几乎立刻就变得拥堵不堪。但与此同时，老旧道路上的车流量和以前一样大。不知何故，这些桥梁和道路引来了更多的汽车，这反过来又创造了更大的需求，而这种需求随后又被填满。而摩西对此类事情的唯一解决办法就是建造更多的桥梁和道路。罗曼，你对城市基础设施的了解比我多。这到底是怎么回事？在这种情况下到底发生了什么？
Because the assumption they seem to be working from is there's a limited number of cars, provide bridges and those cars will disperse out. But instead it's almost as if the cars are spontaneously generating to fill this space. Yeah, it's true that you basically induce demand by providing more lanes. Like you add more lanes, it just fills up.
因为他们似乎依据的假设是，汽车的数量是有限的，只要提供桥梁，这些汽车就会分散开来。但相反，情况几乎就像是汽车在自发产生以填满这个空间。是的，事实确实如此，你通过提供更多的车道基本上诱发了需求。就像你增加更多车道，它们就会被填满。
It's always been this way. And what I wonder is, is this the first time we really learned that? Like that is a truism of urban design. And I wonder if Robert Moses' efforts is when we learned that empirically as such a default pattern that we consider it like a law in urban planning, that you just, if you add a lane, if you add a bridge,
一直都是这样。而我好奇的是，这真的是我们第一次真正学到这一点吗？就像那是城市设计的一个真理。我想知道，罗伯特·摩西的努力是否正是我们从经验中吸取这一教训的时刻，将其作为一个我们认为类似于城市规划定律的默认模式：你只要增加一条车道，增加一座桥，
it does not alleviate traffic. It just induces a new type of demand and it just fills up exactly the same way, unlike public transit. And that's taken as a given now, whereas, because at the- It's completely as a given. It's about as true as anything gets in urban planning, as far as I can say.
它并不能缓解交通。它只会诱发一种新型需求，并且会以完全相同的方式被填满，这与公共交通不同。而这现在被认为是理所当然的，然而，因为在——这完全是被当成理所当然的。就我所能说的而言，这几乎是城市规划中再真实不过的真理了。
Because all I know is what I read in books, and by books I mean the Power Broker, just this one book. And the people in the- Over and over again. Yeah, multiple times, this is my third time through. And the people in the book, they're like baffled by it. Like it's like a mystery. It's an enigma they cannot solve. Where are these cars coming from?
因为我所知道的全部就是我在书里读到的，而我所说的书指的就是《权力经纪人》，仅仅这一本书。而书中的人们——一遍又一遍地。是的，好多次了，这是我第三遍读。书中的人们对此感到大惑不解。就像这是一个谜。这是一个他们无法解开的谜团。这些车都是从哪儿来的？
As if a portal has opened up, and cars from another dimension are just pouring in. But you're saying at this point, it's now almost 100 years later, it's pretty well understood that if you create a need, it's people will will fill that need completely. And that's why most of the sort of urban planning thinking is about restricting cars. And there is no notion it's going to make things worse. That actually will make things better in these ways. And so, but this could be the moment that people really got this stuck in their heads
就好像开了一个传送门，另一个维度的汽车正源源不断地涌进来。但你的意思是，到了这个时候，几乎100年过去了，人们已经非常清楚，如果你创造了需求，人们就会彻底填满这个需求。这就是为什么大多数城市规划思维都在围绕限制汽车展开。而且没有任何迹象表明这会让情况变得更糟。事实上，这会在这些方面让情况变得更好。所以，但这可能是人们真正把这个概念刻进脑子里的时刻，
because every city fell for this in this period of time. But I think this is the clearest and most acute example because of the density of the city and the sort of the scope of the problem. And the fact that it fills up so quickly. So incredibly quickly, and it's that it's happening in the most important city in the world, greatest city in the world, New York City, best ever.
因为在这段时期里，每个城市都中过这个招。但我认为这是最清晰、最尖锐的例子，因为城市的密度以及问题规模之大。而且它被填满的速度是如此之快。快得不可思议，而且它发生在世界上最重要的城市、世界上最伟大的城市——纽约市，史上最棒的城市。
What other city has a giant gorilla climbing up buildings? We talked about it, just this one, well, and some others according to other movies. But King Kong goes to Tokyo at one point, he's in Rio, I think, in the, King Kong goes to Tokyo at one point. He's in Rio, I think, in the new movie. But anyway, mostly New York, but that it's happening there on such a scale. And Carol says, he says tens of millions of dollars have been spent. And the net result is that there used to be four bridges with traffic jams on them. Now there are six bridges with
还有什么城市有巨大的金刚爬上建筑物？我们讨论过，只有这个，嗯，根据其他电影来看，还有一些别的。但金刚在某个时候去了东京，他在里约，我想，在新电影里——金刚在某个时候去了东京。他在里约，我想，在新电影里。不管怎样，主要还是纽约，但它居然在那里以这种规模发生着。卡罗说，他说已经花费了数千万美元。而最终的结果是，过去有四个经常交通堵塞的桥梁。现在有六个经常
traffic jams on them. And people say, what if we add mass transit links to some of these bridges? And Moses refuses. He doesn't want trains on these bridges at all. And it seems like that his big parkway system is now just making it easier to dump cars from one place to another in big numbers. And I wonder if it's like, he's really coming from this world where cars were a thing that you had to have money to own. We've talked about before how like driving used to be about pleasure and now
交通堵塞的桥梁。人们说：如果我们给其中一些桥梁加上大众运输连接线会怎样？而摩西拒绝了。他根本不希望这些桥上通火车。看起来他庞大的公园大道系统现在只是在让成群结队的汽车从一个地方倾倒到另一个地方变得更加容易。我在想，这是否是因为他真的出身于这样一个世界：汽车是需要有钱才能拥有的东西。我们之前讨论过，过去开车是为了快乐，而现在
it's about commuting, but he's also living in a world where like more and more people can afford cars and the car companies are making more cars. So it seems foolish for them to be like, this will take care of the traffic problem as if there never will be more cars. Like they're making cars all the time. There's always new cars and some of them are going to end up in New York city. So it's, I don't know. What do you think is the, what do you think's the reason that they never factored in the fact that more cars can be made and purchased? I don't know. I think that there's, you know, Robert Moses has a number of blind spots and he really just,
它是为了通勤，但他也生活在一个越来越多的人买得起车、汽车公司制造更多汽车的世界里。所以他们认为“这能解决交通问题，就好像永远不会有更多汽车一样”的想法看起来很愚蠢。因为他们一直在造车。总会有新车，其中一部分最终会开进纽约市。所以，我不知道。你认为是什么原因——你认为他们从未把“会制造和购买更多汽车”这一事实考虑进去的原因是什么？我不知道。我认为，你知道的，罗伯特·摩西有许多盲区，他真的只是——
I mean, what Caro tells you of his upbringing, it really set in motion like everything he thinks about the world. And this one, he just cannot wrap his head around. Like he has been driven in a car, mostly for pleasure, but also for work, because he gets- He's got that sweet car office, yeah. It's ferried around, you know, to take care of, and tromp through wetlands and stuff.
我的意思是，卡罗对他的成长经历的描述，确实引发了他对世界看法的方方面面。而对于这一点，他就是无法理解。就像他一直坐汽车出行，大多是为了快乐，但也为了工作，因为他得到了——他有那个超棒的车载办公室，是的。他被四处接送，你知道的，去处理各种事务，在湿地里跋涉之类的。
But he has a very, for all of his genius as presented, he has a really hard time updating his firmware to the modern world as he goes along. He just cannot adjust to the world as it is. He's really like building a city for the world. Like you could say that building for cars is a little bit of, I don't know,
但他——尽管呈现出种种天才之处，他在随着时间推移将自己的底层逻辑更新到现代世界时却遇到了极大的困难。他就是无法适应现实中的世界。他真的就像是在为某个世界建造一座城市——你可以说为汽车建造城市有点——我不知道。
futurist or forward thinking, because the subway system was built out very, very quickly in the early 20th century. And he's reversing all that momentum but it's just so surprising how much he cannot take in certain types of details to adjust a city plan that would work for everybody. During this part of the book he was really reminding me a lot of Elon Musk where it was like Elon Musk had kind of one good idea which was we should have a electric car company that operates like a large car company.
有远见或者前瞻性，因为地铁系统在20世纪初建设得非常、非常快。他正在扭转所有这些势头，但令人惊异的是，在调整一个能为所有人服务的城市规划时，他是如此无法吸收某些类型的细节。在书的这部分里，他真的非常让我联想到埃隆·马斯克，就好像埃隆·马斯克有一种好主意，那就是我们应该拥有一家像大汽车公司那样运营的电动汽车公司。
And then thinks assumed that meant he had lots of good ideas. Really, he didn't after that. Whereas Moses has this one good idea, which is we need to have a way for people to get from one place to another. But then he doesn't have the best solution for it. And he kept supplying that solution or like maybe a better way to compare to is like Walt Disney, where Walt Disney is like, I want a theme park full of robots so that I can recreate Main Street 1900 like it was when I was a kid. Or like Jurassic Park, we've got all this amazing genetic technology. Let's use it
然后就自以为是地认为这意味着他有很多好主意。说真的，在那之后他并没有。而莫西斯则有这一个好主意，那就是我们需要有一种方法让人们从一个地方去到另一个地方。但随后他并没有为此提供最佳解决方案。他不断地提供那个解决方案，或者说也许更好的对比对象是沃尔特·迪斯尼，沃尔特·迪斯尼就像是，我想要一个到处都是机器人的主题公园，这样我就可以重现1900年的主街，就像我小时候那样。或者像《侏罗纪公园》那样，我们拥有所有这些了不起的基因技术。让我们利用它
to recreate the oldest things we can think of, dinosaurs. Like I want it, there's maybe that's it. Maybe that's a human drive is to to be fine trying to figure out new ways to do old things until someone else comes along is like well you can use this new thing for a new new way or you can use this old thing in a new way like anyway. So the point is Robert Caro is going to dig in deep on another kind of Moses special which is the destruction of a neighborhood and this is a kind of a micro version of something we're going to see in much greater detail later in the book in a different neighborhood. But it's November 1941, World War II is about to start.
来重现我们能想到的最古老的东西，恐龙。就像我想要的，也许这就是人类的驱动力——乐于去找出用旧方法做新事的新途径，直到另一个人出现，说你可以用这个新东西走一条新新途径，或者你可以用这个旧东西走一条新途径，反正就是这样。所以重点是，罗伯特·卡罗将深入挖掘莫西斯的另一个标志性特作，那就是摧毁一个街区，这是我们将在书的后面在另一个街区以更详细得多的方式看到的事物的微观版本。但那是1941年11月，第二次世界大战即将开始。
That doesn't really turn into what we're talking about. And that's when Moses opens up this thing called the Gowanus Parkway in Brooklyn. And it's an elevated road that he's been able to sell partly because it's on pillars that used to hold the elevated subway line through that area. It runs through Sunset Park, its neighborhood very close to where I used to live in Brooklyn, Park Slope. And in fact, real estate brokers in Brooklyn have been expanding the boundaries of Park Slope into Sunset Park for years now as a way of raising
这并没有真正变成我们正在谈论的事情。正是在那时，莫西斯在布鲁克林开放了被称为加瓦纳斯公园大道的东西。这是一条高架路，他之所以能部分推销出去，是因为它建在以前用来支撑该地区高架铁路线的支柱上。它穿过日落公园，这个街区离我以前在布鲁克林住过的地方公园坡非常近。事实上，布鲁克林的房地产经纪人多年来一直在将公园坡的边界扩大到日落公园，以此来提高
the rents in Sunset Park. Our producer, Isabelle is reminding us she used to live in Park Slope too. Park Slope is where people who work in, in, in podcastset Park. Our producer, Isabelle, is reminding us she used to live in Park Slope too. Park Slope is where people who work in podcasting work from their apartment. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, writers. It's a great neighborhood for people in the arts who want to live in the city,
日落公园的租金。我们的制作人伊莎贝尔提醒我们，她以前也住在公园坡。公园坡是那些在播客制作人伊莎贝尔提醒我们她以前也住在公园坡。公园坡是那些在播客行业工作的人从他们的公寓里工作的地方。是啊，是啊。是的，作家们。对于那些想住在城里、
but they want to live where it's really smelly in the city. So there was this elevated train line that ran down Third Avenue. It just became a regular part of the neighborhood. Elevated trains are not great. They, they darken things. Uh, the resonance of this neighborhood, they've kind of gotten used to the elevated train line,
但又想住在城里气味很难闻的地方的艺术界人士来说，这是一个绝佳的街区。因此，有一条沿着第三大道运行的高架铁路线。它只是成了这个街区的一个常规部分。高架列车并不算太好。它们会让光线变暗。嗯，这个街区的回响，他们已经有点习惯这条高架铁路线了，
but they know that an expressway is going to be, it's going to block out much more light because instead of the slats of a train track, it's going to be just a cement block. It's going to be bigger and they say. Much wider too. And much wider. Yeah.
但他们知道高速公路将会，它会挡住更多的光线，因为取代铁轨板条的将只是一块水泥砖。它会更大，而且他们说。宽得多。宽得多。是的。
And then so they say, instead of running this expressway over the heart of our neighborhood, can you move it one block over to where that's just industrial waterfront. And even the comptroller of the city who lives in Sunset Park is like, yeah, the expressway would be way worse for the neighborhood than the L tracks were. And the parkway route, it's going to have to swing back towards second avenue after a mile anyway.
然后他们就说，与其把这条高速公路开过我们街区的中心，你能不能把它往旁边挪一个街区，挪到那些只是工业滨水区的地方？甚至住在日落公园的城市主计长也觉得，是的，这条高速公路对街区的糟糕程度远超L线铁轨。而且公园大道路线无论如何在一英里后都得转回第二大道。
So it won't really be saving that much money to reuse these pillars, but it will blight this neighborhood And the Parkway route, it's going to have to swing back towards Second Avenue after a mile anyway. So it won't really be saving that much money to reuse these pillars, but it will blight this neighborhood. And Moses is like, eh, it's a slum. It's not worth preserving. Why would we bother? And so Caro investigates that and he goes into detail and he interviews people from the area.
所以重复使用这些支柱并不会真正省下多少钱，但它会毁了这个街区。而且公园大道路线无论如何在一英里后都得转回第二大道。所以重复使用这些支柱并不会真正省下多少钱，但它会毁了这个街区。而莫西斯却觉得，呃，那是个贫民窟。不值得保护。我们为什么要费那个劲？于是卡罗对此进行了调查，他深入细致地采访了当地的人们。
And he's going to do this again later in even much more detail with the Tremont neighborhood in the Bronx. But he's interviewing people there and the portrait he builds is that it's a poor neighborhood, but it is not a slum. It is a neighborhood of nice houses where people take care of their blocks. You know, it's quiet. There's this kind of strong community of mostly Norwegians, but they're
他后来在布朗克斯的特里蒙特街区还将再次这样做，甚至会更详细。但他在那里采访人们，他构建的画像是，这是一个贫穷的街区，但它不是贫民窟。这是一个拥有漂亮房子的街区，人们精心照料他们的街区。你知道，这里很安静。这里有着主要由挪威人组成的牢固社区，但他们
very active with each other. They're, it's poor, but it's not dangerous. It's not unpleasant. It's a solidly working class neighborhood of the kinds that I feel like used to be symbolic to me of the outer boroughs when I was growing up, but now feels, you know, old fashioned and Robert Carroll, he takes us down a little walk down third Avenue. If you can indulge me in, in quoting, he says,
彼此非常活跃。这里很穷，但并不危险。并不令人不快。这是一个坚实的工人阶级街区，当我还小的时候，我觉得这种街区曾是我心目中外围行政区的象征，但现在感觉，你知道，已经过时了。罗伯特·卡罗带我们沿着第三大道散了一小步。如果你能原谅我引用的话，他说，
the heart of the neighborhood, the focal point that gave it unity and a sense of community was third Avenue lining it along with new stands off which 9,000 Nordisk to Dennis were sold every day. That's like Norwegian newspaper were seven movie theaters, dozens of tiny restaurants run by couples and featuring recipes from the old countries, little restaurants, but good. And so many wouldn't know where to go for lunch or calls Harold Benson, whose hardware store was on third Avenue at 54th street and scores of small friendly mama and papa stores, the Northland gift shop, the Finnish bookstore, a hardware store that looked like a general store out of the old West, a butcher shop that raffled off 25 big turkeys every Christmas that occupied the ground floor of three and four story brick fronts in which mama and papa lived upstairs with the children.
街区的中心，赋予其统一感和社区感的焦点是第三大道，道路两旁林立着报摊，每天售出9000份《挪威日报》。那就像是挪威报纸，有七家电影院，几十家由夫妻经营的小餐馆，主打老家的食谱，餐馆虽小但很好。许多人甚至不知道午餐该去哪里，哈罗德·本森的五金店就开在第三大道和第54街交汇处，还有几十家小巧友好的夫妻店，诺兰礼品店、芬兰书店、一家看起来像老西部杂货店的五金店，一家每年圣诞节抽奖送出25只大火鸡的肉店，它们占据了三到四层砖砌正面建筑物的底层，妈妈和爸爸就和孩子们住在楼上。
The Avenue was always busy. People shopping or window shopping were just walking. Benson recalls, this is like old school Brooklyn. Like what I think of as like old school Brooklyn, what makes it nice? The image you get is that the neighborhood residents there are very proud of this neighborhood. And they don't want this,
这条大道总是很热闹。人们在购物、逛橱窗或者只是散步。本森回忆说，这就像老派的布鲁克林。就像我所认为的老派布鲁克林那样，是什么让它变得美好？你得到的印象是，那里的居民对这个街区非常自豪。他们不想要这个，
they understandably don't want to express way right over their heads. And the board of estimate, one of the reasons they approved Moses for using those pillars is because they assumed, oh, the pillars are already there. Moses isn't going to have to get any new right of way land for this expressway.
他们可以理解地不希望有一条高速公路直接从他们头顶穿过。估价委员会之所以批准莫西斯使用这些支柱，原因之一是他们以为，哦，支柱已经在那儿了。莫西斯不需要为这条高速公路获取任何新的通行权土地。
It'll save us time. We won't have to relocate anybody. This will be great. And Moses is like, uh, funny story. I need to relocate a hundred stores and 1300 families because the board of estimate didn't realize you need on and off ramps for an expressway, like for a parkway. A train doesn't need on and off ramps, it's just the stations. And Moses also,
这能为我们省下时间。我们不需要重新安置任何人。这太棒了。而莫西斯则像是，呃，有个有趣的故事。我需要重新安置100家店铺和1300户家庭，因为估价委员会没有意识到，高速公路需要上下匝道，就像公园大道那样。火车不需要上下匝道，只有车站就行。而且莫西斯还，
this is where he kind of, his twisting the rules comes in even more because he's like, if I build this road and it's not a parkway, the law says I don't have control over it. So even though it is an elevated treeless stretch of highway that goes through a city. I'm calling it a parkway. And you know what? I have another rule. I don't allow trucks on my parkway. So trucks are instead going to go on third avenue underneath. That's a four lane street. I'm going to have to expand that into a highway into a 10 lane highway so that it's more truck accessible.
正是在这里，他扭曲规则的做法变得更加淋漓尽致，因为他说：如果我建这条路，而它不是公园大道，法律规定我对它就没有管辖权。所以，尽管这是一条穿过城市的、没有树木的高架高速公路路段。我管它叫公园大道。你知道吗？我还有一条规定。我的公园大道上不允许有卡车。所以卡车将改走底下的第三大道。那是一条四车道街道。我得把它扩建为高速公路，变成一条十车道的高速公路，这样它对卡车来说就更具通达性。
And so now you've got, uh, so much more noise, so much more darkness after he builds this road and businesses start to close down. And Carol makes the point that the elevated train brought people to Sunset Park and the parkway just brings people through it. And this is the big crux of so much of what Moses is doing is he's not interested in bringing people to parts of the city. He just wants to get them through it as quickly as possible. Yeah, this is really key.
所以现在你有了，呃，更多的噪音，在他在修建了这条道路之后，黑暗增添了许多，企业也开始倒闭。卡罗指出，高架列车将人们带到了日落公园，而公园大道只是将人们带过了它。这就是莫西斯所做的大部分事情的核心所在，他对把人们带到城市的各个部分不感兴趣。他只想让他们尽可能快地穿过它。是的，这真的很关键。
Cause if you ever lived in a neighborhood with an elevated train, there are stops not too far apart that you just take the stairs down and you go by your Nordic paper, you know, and then you go back up or you get a snack or whatever. And it, even though this is a, you know, a major artery that brings people to and through, it just much more brings people to a place. Yes, when I lived in Astoria, Queens,
因为如果你曾在有高架火车的街区住过，那些车站相距不远，你只需走楼梯下去，去买你的挪威报纸，你知道，然后你再走上去，或者去吃个零食什么的。而且，尽管这是一条把人们带到这里和穿过这里的交通大动脉，它更像是把人们带到一个地方。是的，当我住在皇后区阿斯托里亚时，
I was very close to the elevated train there. And like, yeah, you take the elevated train home, you get off of your stop. And exactly like on the way home, I could stop at the hardware store, the grocery store, the Chinese takeout place, I ate everything I needed in my errands to and from the train.
我离那里的高架火车非常近。就像，是的，你坐高架火车回家，在你的车站下车。完全就像在回家的路上，我可以顺便去五金店、杂货店、中餐外卖店，我在往返火车的途中办完了我需要的所有事情。
And it felt like it wasn't super pleasant to walk underneath the tracks, but it didn't feel like you were in like a tunnel. But with a road like this, it's not like someone can be driving down the parkway and look out and see this Norwegian restaurant and be like, yeah, I think I'm gonna stop there. Like the next exit may be miles away.
感觉在轨道下面走虽然不是超级愉快，但并不觉得你好像身处隧道中。但对于这样一条道路，不可能有人一边开着车在公园大道上行驶，一边往外看看到这家挪威餐馆，然后说，是的，我想我要在那儿停下来。因为下一个出口可能在几英里之外。
Right, right. It's just a different idea of what this sort of type of conveyance is for. And he's really, he's just trying to get you through a place because he doesn't find that place desirable and thinks that if everyone else inside of it is gonna just have to have a car to do it. I mean, maybe, I mean, that's one notion,
对，对。这只是对这种交通工具用途的一种不同看法。他其实只是想让你穿过一个地方，因为他不觉得那个地方是令人向往的，并且认为如果里面的其他所有人都只能为此买辆车的话。我的意思是，也许，我的意思是，这是一个观念，
to the earlier discussion we were having is like, if you build a world like this, where there's a mile and a half between exits and entrances to the Gowanus Parkway rather than a stop every three or four blocks, if it's an elevated train line, all of a sudden, if you live in that neighborhood, you do need a car. And it sort of creates this need and therefore it becomes a thing that fills it up
结合我们之前讨论的话题，如果你建造这样一个世界，加瓦纳斯公园大道的出入口之间相距有一英里半，而不是像高架铁路线那样每隔三四个街区就有一个车站，突然之间，如果你住在那个街区，你确实需要一辆汽车。它以某种方式创造了这种需求，因此它就变成了一种被填满的事物，
and therefore makes it bumper to bumper and useless at a certain point. And it just creates a worse and worse world when you design it this way. To quote the actor John Glover playing the role of Daniel Clamp in the classic film, Gremremlins 2 The New Batch. If you build a place for things, things come.
并在某种程度上变得首尾相接、拥挤不堪且毫无用处。当你以这种方式设计它时，它只会创造出一个越来越糟糕的世界。借用经典电影《小魔怪2》中演员约翰·格洛弗扮演丹尼尔·克兰普时的台词：如果你为事物建造了一个地方，事物就会到来。
And that's kind of what happens. Yeah, he builds a place that is for cars and not people and the people leave. It makes it harder for the neighborhood to actually go about their business because this road is here. It makes it less pleasant. People are less likely to go patronize the business there.
这正是发生的事情。是的，他建造了一个为汽车而非为人服务的地方，人们便离开了。由于这条路的出现，使得这个街区的人们实际上去处理事务变得更加困难。它让环境变得不那么宜人。人们不太可能去光顾那里的生意。
So businesses start to close, which means even less people stop by. So more business close, people who own those businesses move away. Families are leaving. Now the side streets are also full of trucks. So people don't want to live there. And third Avenue, this place that was a kind of poor, but bustling kind of friendly street becomes exactly the kind of place that people are afraid to go to. That's, that's where you go to find drunks, to find street violence, to find drug addicts. More and more people move away and it becomes
于是企业开始倒闭，这意味着停下来的人更少了。因此更多的企业倒闭，拥有这些生意的业主搬走了。家庭正在离开。现在小街道上也挤满了卡车。所以人们不想住在那里。第三大道，这个曾经贫穷但熙熙攘攘、颇具人情味的街道，精确地变成了人们害怕涉足的地方。那就是，那是你去找醉汉、找街头暴力、找瘾君子的地方。越来越多的人搬走，它变成了
the slum that Moses said it was. If you call it a slum and you give it the opportunity to become a slum, a neighborhood will become a slum. Just as happens in Gremlins 2, The New Batch, when that shining skyscraper just turns into a hive of gremlins. And to add the most bitter of irony to the whole thing, the Gowanus Parkway is almost instantly backed up with traffic, just like all the other parkways. And Moses' solution to this is we gotta widen the road. So he does to the point that if your apartment
莫西斯口中的那个贫民窟。如果你叫它贫民窟，并且给它创造了变成贫民窟的机会，一个街区就会变成贫民窟。正如在《小魔怪2》中发生的那样，当那座闪闪发光的摩天大楼最终变成了一个小魔怪的巢穴时。为了给整件事增添最苦涩的讽刺，加瓦纳斯公园大道几乎瞬间就交通大塞车，就像所有其他公园大道一样。而莫西斯对此的解决方案是我们得拓宽道路。所以他照做了，以至于如果你的公寓
is on either side of the road, then on wet days, the cars are splattering your windows. Their wheels are just throwing water at your windows. And Moses has essentially wrecked this neighborhood. But as Karo says, quote, no newspaper mentioned that fact. The newspaper is only there to talk about what's gonna happen beforehand
位于道路两侧，那么在潮湿的日子里，汽车会把泥水溅到你的窗户上。它们的车轮只会把水泼向你的窗户。莫西斯基本上毁了这个街区。但正如卡罗所说，引述：“没有一家报纸提到过这个事实。”报纸只负责报道在此之前将要发生的事情，
and how great it is that this guy's getting things done. Look at this amazing road. They're not interested in what happens after the fact. Yeah. And speaking of getting big things done, this brings us to the West Side Improvement Project, which is a great section of the book that I actually really love. But we'll talk about that after the break.
以及这家伙把事情办成了有多么棒。看看这条了不起的路。他们对事后发生的事情不感兴趣。是的。说到把大事办成，这就把我们带到了西区改善项目，这是书中我其实非常喜欢的一个章节。但我们会在休息之后再谈这个。
We have to divide up Chapter 25 into several sections because... Into more digestible chunks, yeah. It is very, very long as we've said before, but this is the West Side Improvement Project, which is this massive thing that I love how Caro does this, like demonstrates the problem solving and the process that Moses goes through. So could you describe what is this project?
我们必须把第25章分成几个部分，因为……分成更容易消化的块状部分， yeah。正如我们之前所说，它非常、非常长，但这就是西区改善项目，这是一个宏大的项目，我非常喜欢卡罗的处理方式，它展示了莫西斯所经历的问题解决过程和程序。所以你能描述一下这个项目是什么吗？
Yes, and I agree with you. This section, it's amazing to be reminded in this section also, just how brilliant Moses is. He's not just, if you call him an evil genius, you got to emphasize the genius part because he's just, he's so, he's amazing at this. But the West Side Improvement Project, this is the dream that Robert Moses had since the 1920s. If you harken back to the first or second chapter, he and future labor secretary Francis Perkins were walking around the west side of the Manhattan Island at night as young people and he's just talking about, couldn't you see a park here? Couldn't you see a road here?
是的，我同意你的看法。这一部分，在这部分中再次让人惊叹并被提醒，莫西斯是多么的才华横溢。他不仅，如果你称他为邪恶天才，你必须强调天才部分，因为他简直，他在这方面太棒了。但西区改善项目，这是罗伯特·莫西斯自20世纪20年代以来就有的梦想。如果你回想第一章或第二章，他和未来的劳工部长弗朗西丝·珀金斯作为年轻人，在夜晚漫步于曼哈顿岛的西侧，他当时就在谈论，你难道在这里看不到一个公园吗？你难道在这里看不到一条路吗？
The west side of Manhattan for years has been train tracks, often ground level train tracks. So people would get killed there frequently by trains. It is garbage dumps. It's municipal waste. Manhattan Island is such a different island than it was in the 1920s and 30s because it used to be an island full of manufacturing, full of industry, and now it's been taken over
多年来，曼哈顿的西侧都是铁路线，通常是地面铁路线。因此，人们经常在那里被火车撞死。这里是垃圾场。这里是城市废弃物。曼哈顿岛与20世纪20年代和30年代相比已经是一个截然不同的岛屿了，因为它过去是一个充满了制造业、充满了工业的岛屿，而现在它已经被
by other businesses. If you walk along the west side of Manhattan now, you're gonna see very fancy buildings, you're gonna see financial structures and things like that. But there was a time when it smelled bad, it was full of animals,'re going to see financial structures and things like that. But there was a time when it was smell bad. It was full of animals. It was full of trash, you know, and things like that. And so the idea is you're going to have an extended elevated parkway all along Manhattan's
其他企业所接管。如果你现在沿着曼哈顿西侧步行，你会看到非常高档的建筑，你会看到金融结构之类的东西。但曾几何时，这里气味难闻，充满了动物。时会看到金融结构之类的东西。但曾几何时，这里气味难闻。这里充满了动物。这里充满了垃圾，你知道，诸如此类。所以这个想法是，你将在曼哈顿的整个西侧拥有一条延伸的高架公园大道，
west side, the west side highway, I think, if I'm getting that right. You'll have a six mile long park. You're going to build the Henry Hudson Bridge finally across the Harlem River. This bridge that up till now in, in the book's terms is represented just by a pillar with no statue of Henry Hudson at the top of it, because they could not afford to finish it. Uh, that's going to connect Manhattan and the
西区高速公路，我想，如果我没记错的话。你将拥有一座长达六英里的公园。你终于要建造横跨哈莱姆河的亨利·哈德逊大桥了。这座桥直到目前为止，在本书的语境中，仅由一根顶端没有亨利·哈德逊雕像的柱子所代表，因为他们买不起完成它的资金。嗯，那将连接曼哈顿和
Bronx, you're going to have a connection from the Bronx that leads you out of the city to the Sawmill river parkway. This is his dream to connect Manhattan to the to the parkways outside that he's building, but also to make the West side something that Manhattan can be proud of. He really, he does want to make beautiful things. He wants to make things that are that at the very least he can hold pride in
布朗克斯，你将拥有一条从布朗克斯出发的连接线，引领你离开城市前往锯木河公园大道。这就是他的梦想，将曼哈顿与他正在建设的外部公园大道连接起来，同时也让西侧成为曼哈顿能够引以为豪的事物。他真的，他确实想创造美好的事物。他想创造那些至少能让他为自己创造了它们而感到自豪的事物。
having created. And he's been talking about it for years now, but it is going to cost an incredible amount of money. He Moses estimates it's going to cost $109 million. And this is during the depression, the city does not have $109 million. And what makes it slightly harder is that there's this 1927 agreement that he knows about between the city and the New York Central Railroad.
他已经谈论这个好几年了，但这将花费一笔惊人的巨额资金。莫西斯估计这将花费1.09亿美元。正值大萧条时期，市政府并没有1.09亿美元。让事情变得稍微困难一点的是，他知道在市政府和纽约中央铁路公司之间存在一份1927年的协议。
And it's their tracks that are going up and down the West side. And the New York Central Railroad said, in exchange for some other land in a different part of the city, we'll cover those tracks, we'll pay for covering them up. Oops, we didn't finish it, sorry, it just didn't get done. So Moses like, I'm gonna have to cover up those tracks
正是他们的铁路线在西侧上下穿梭。而纽约中央铁路公司表示，作为交换城市其他地方的一些土地，我们将掩盖这些铁路线，我们将支付掩盖它们的费用。哎呀，我们没弄完，抱歉，这事就是没办成。所以莫西斯就像是，我得把那些铁路线给盖起来，
and if the city pays for it, that's gonna be seen as the city giving away money to the railroad company, which no politician is gonna go for. And the railroad's never gonna have that kind of money. So what am I gonna do? And then beyond that, even if I do that, there's still tens of millions of dollars that I'm gonna have to figure out to fund this thing.
如果由市政府出资，那将被视为市政府在向铁路公司送钱，任何政客都不会买账。而且铁路公司也绝不会有那种资金。那我该怎么办？而且除此之外，即便我这么做了，我仍然得想方设法筹集几千万美元来资助这个项目。
And I feel like even to get an estimate of how much money it's gonna cost, and I'm sure he has his staff working with him on it, even that takes a certain amount of genius to be able to put a dollar figure on a project this enormous with so many different pieces to it. Totally. And as Caro said, to see all these parts working together,
我觉得甚至要估算它会花多少钱，而且我确信他有他的团队协助他一起研究，仅仅做到这一点本身就需要一定程度的天才，才能为一个规模如此庞大、拥有如此多不同组成部分的工程给出一个具体的金额。完全赞同。正如卡罗所说，看到所有这些部分协同工作，
that this is not just a park, this is a park and a bridge and a highway. And he's looking at them all as pieces of the same thing. And the only thing I can relate it to in my mind is that like, I can look at as a writer, I can look at a story and I can see how different scenes interact with each other to build a plot while also building character, while also building theme. But that feels like such a small thing compared to like, well, we're gonna reconfigure the west side of this island that's the most densely populated island in the country.
这不仅仅是一个公园，这是一个公园、一座桥梁和一条高速公路。他把它们都看作是同一事物的组成部分。我唯一能联系到我脑海中的是，作为一个作家，我可以看一个故事，然后看出不同的场景是如何相互作用来构建情节，同时又塑造人物、构建主题的。但与我们要重新配置这个岛屿西侧相比，这感觉是一件如此微不足道的事情，而这个岛是全国人口最稠密的岛屿。
It's astonishing. Anyway, so the amount of money that he needs, it seems insurmountable. And this is when Cairo, he takes you very methodically, step by step, through the ways that Moses surmounts it. It is no longer insurmountable. It becomes surmountable, which sounds like a pun name
这太令人惊叹了。不管怎样，他需要的资金数额看起来似乎是无法克服的。正是在这个时候，卡罗带你非常系统地、一步一步地领略莫西斯克服这一难关的方法。它不再是无法克服的。它变得可以克服了，这听起来像是一个滑稽的名字，
that a knight would have in like a- Monty Python. Monty Python, yeah, exactly. Like an old puck cartoon, you know, and then surmountable comes in. He sees that in this 1927 agreement, the railroad owes the city $8.2 million for work on the West side.
就像骑士在某个—中会有的名字。巨蟒剧团。巨蟒剧团，对，没错。就像一个老派的波克漫画，你知道的，然后“克服”登场了。他看到在那份1927年的协议中，铁路公司欠市政府820万美元，用于西侧的工程。
The railroad doesn't have that kind of money. It has no line of credit. It is in debt. It's paying back its loans at very higher interest rates. So Moses, first he's gonna have to get money for the railroad and then convince the railroad to spend that money on the park, rather than say, pay its workers or get out of debt.
铁路公司根本没有那种资金。它没有信贷额度。它负债累累。它正以非常高的利率偿还贷款。所以莫西斯首先得为铁路公司筹集资金，然后说服铁路公司把这笔钱花在公园上，而不是用来支付工人工资或摆脱债务。
And Moses has a lot of work on legal pads. He only works on yellow legal pads, which let me be honest, that's how I work too. I like to work on yellow legal pads. So I really get Robert Moses' love of just scribbling on yellow legal pads. It is the single best way to work out ideas is on a yellow legal pad.
莫西斯在法律垫纸上有大量的工作要做。他只在黄色法律垫纸上工作，说实话，我也是这样工作的。我喜欢在黄色法律垫纸上工作。所以我真的能理解罗伯特·莫西斯那种热爱在黄色法律垫纸上乱涂乱画的心情。在黄色法律垫纸上梳理想法绝对是最好的工作方式。
I'm sorry, there's no other better way to do it. I agree. Sorry tech industry, you're never gonna improve on this. You're never gonna be able to read a legal pad. It's the perfect size of paper. It's the perfect color of paper. Like just for that kind of work. I wouldn't want to read a book that's all on yellow paper. Your eyes will hurt eventually. But after doing a lot of math on those legal pads, he realizes he can arrange for New York state to give the railroad alone, not a payout, but alone from this grade crossing elimination
抱歉，没有比这更好的办法了。我同意。抱歉，科技行业，你们永远无法对其进行改进。你们永远无法阅读法律垫纸。它是完美尺寸的纸张。它是完美颜色的纸张。就像为了那种工作一样。我可不想读一本全是用黄纸写的书。你的眼睛最终会受不了的。但在那些法律垫纸上做了大量数学计算后，他意识到他可以安排纽约州给铁路公司一笔贷款，不是一笔直接拨款，而是从这个平交道口消除
fund that is somehow incredibly well funded. It has so much money in it. The city can give them a loan for $13.5 million that has such a low interest rate on it that the railroad can pay back its old loans while saving money on its future interest payments. And he writes up a law, it's this complicated agreement with tax liens and escrow stuff and that makes the loan appealing, I guess. And he pushes it through the legislature just at the end of the session. And he manages to convince Lehman to sign it on the last day, the bill is vile, but before it expires. And he says, you can take credit for it if you sign it.
基金中提供一笔贷款，该基金不知为何资金异常充足。它里面有太多的钱了。市政府可以向他们提供一笔1350万美元的贷款，其利率之低，足以让铁路公司在偿还旧贷款的同时，还能节省未来利息支付的开支。他起草了一项法律，这是一项复杂的协议，包含了税收留置权和托管之类的内容，这使得这笔贷款很有吸引力，我猜。他在会议结束时将其强行通过了立法机关。并且他在最后一天说服了雷曼在法案到期前将其签署——该法案内容糟糕，但在到期前签了。他说，如果你签字，你可以居功至伟。
And now Moses only has $95.5 million left to find. There's still a lot of money left to go. So what's he gonna do? Well, hey, here's something you can do. I feel like this is depressionary thinking. He's like, oh, when the railroad covers up all that land and expands the park space, it's going to create a lot of waste rocks. And I need landfill. I need $4 million worth of landfill.
现在莫西斯只剩下9550万美元需要去寻找了。仍然有大量的资金缺口。那他该怎么办？好吧，嘿，这里有个你可以做的事情。我觉得这是一种大萧条时期的思维方式。他觉得，哦，当铁路公司覆盖了所有那些土地并扩建了公园空间时，它会产生大量的废石。而我需要垃圾填埋料。我需要价值400万美元的垃圾填埋料。
Why should I let these rocks go to waste? I'll just use that as the landfill. That's $4 million. He saved right there. Yeah. Now he only needs $91.5 million more. This next one, it's not a lot of money, but it's my favorite.
我为什么要让这些石头白白浪费？我只管把它们用作垃圾填埋料就行了。那就是400万美元。他就在这里省下了。是的。现在他只需要再筹集9150万美元。接下来的这个，虽然钱不多，但它是我的最爱。
Yeah, it's so great. He goes, he goes, if we build a boat basin and we put gargoyles on the boat basin, there's not a lot of money, but it's my favorite. Yeah, it's so great. He goes, if we build a boat basin and we put gargoyles on the boat basin, there's this fund for artwork on public works that we can tap into that no one remembers. And you know what? This philanthropist years ago set up a fund
是的，太棒了。他接着说，如果我们在一个船坞上建个船坞，并在船坞上放上滴水兽，虽然钱不多，但它是我的最爱。是的，太棒了。他接着说，如果我们在一个船坞上建个船坞，并在船坞上放上滴水兽，这里有一个用于公共工程艺术品的基金，我们可以利用它，而没有人记得它。你知道吗？多年前，这位慈善家设立了一个基金
to put freezes on public buildings. So if we put a freeze on it, we'll do that. And it says in the book that the engineers are like, well, we've never seen gargoyles on a boat basin, but okay, and it gets them $100,000 more. So that's 91.4 million dollars to go. And the next one, this is another one, it's also boat basin related. So this boat basin is going to have a marina, it's going to have a restaurant, it's going to have a promenade. Remember Robert Moses, he loves the idea of recreational facilities. He likes multi-use recreational facilities,
用于在公共建筑上安装浮雕。所以如果我们把浮雕放上去，我们就能做到这一点。书中提到工程师们说，好吧，我们从来没在船坞上见过滴水兽，但好吧，这为他们又争取到了10万美元。所以还剩9140万美元要筹集。接下来的这一个，又是另一个，它也与船坞有关。所以这个船坞将有一个码头，将有一家餐厅，将有一条步行道。记住罗伯特·莫西斯，他喜欢休闲设施的想法。他喜欢多功能的休闲设施，
these grand buildings that a lot of people can use all at once. And coincidentally, Harold Ickes over at the WPA or the PWA, I get my letters mixed up, Harold Ickes, he wants to employ more people. This is Moses enemy from last episode. But Harold Ickes is like, I'm going to give quick approval to any plan ready project for things like railroad grade eliminations that can employ a bunch of people. And one week later, Moses has the plans drawn up for the 79th Street grade elimination structure, which is just the boat basin building with the marina and the restaurant and the bureaucrats in the federal government, they're like, it doesn't really look
这些宏伟的建筑可以同时供许多人使用。而且巧合的是，WPA（或者PWA，我老是把字母搞混）的哈罗德·伊克斯，他想雇佣更多的人。这是莫西斯上一集的敌人。但哈罗德·伊克斯却表现得像是，我要对任何准备就绪的铁路平交道口消除等项目给予快速批准，因为这些项目可以雇佣一大批人。仅仅一周后，莫西斯就绘制好了第79街平交道口消除结构的规划图，这其实就是那个带有码头和餐厅的船坞建筑，而联邦政府的官僚们则觉得，这看起来不太
like a grade elimination structure, but okay. But maybe these brass turtle ornaments are a little much for a structure for eliminating railroad grades. And they slash $154,000 from the budget. Now, this is where I would have said, I guess we don't need those brass turtle ornaments. But no, instead, Moses goes to LaGuardia and says, hey, if the city chips in $154,000 for brass turtles, then we can get another $1.7 million from the federal government for this beautiful boat basin. And the CWA is going to contribute another $3 million for the labor.
像平交道口消除结构，但也行吧。不过，这些黄铜海龟装饰品用于一个消除铁路平交道的结构来说，可能有点过于浮夸了。于是他们从预算中削减了154,000美元。现在，如果是我，我可能会说，我猜我们不需要那些黄铜海龟装饰品了。但没有，相反，莫西斯去找拉瓜迪亚说，嘿，如果市政府凑出154,000美元买黄铜海龟，那么我们就能从联邦政府那里为这个漂亮的船坞再拿到170万美元。而且CWA还将为劳动力再出资300万美元。
Look, now we've got $5 million for this boat basin. All the city has to do is spend $154,000 on brass turtles. And so he gets it. And that leaves only $86,400,000 to go for the project. There's still a lot of money, but you see the way he's like chopping it down and he's able to find all these ways for it to qualify for state and federal funds for housing, for interstate highways, for river and harbor funds, for railroads, and gets another $12 million out of that.
你看，现在我们为这个船坞筹集到了500万美元。市政府所需要做的就是在黄铜海龟上花费154,000美元。于是他成功了。这样一来，距离项目完成只剩下86,400,000美元的缺口了。虽然仍然是一大笔钱，但你看他是如何一点点把它砍下来的，而且他能够找到所有这些途径，使其符合州和联邦关于住房、州际高速公路、河流与港口资金以及铁路的资金申请资格，并从中又挤出了1200万美元。
He's so good at finding these programs. He's like Matthew Lesko, you know, the guy who had the book about all these government programs that are giving out free money and all these different ways of like tax strategies and like getting to this government fund and making it work for this and your brass turtles and kind of whipsawing LaGuardia into thinking that he has to do this $150,000 to get the rest
他太擅长寻找这些项目了。他就像马修·莱斯科，你知道那个出过一本书的人，书中写满了各种无偿撒钱的政府项目，以及诸如税务策略等各种各样的方法，比如如何触及这个政府基金并让它为这个服务，还有你的黄铜海龟，以及那种像拉瓜迪亚认为他必须花这15万美元才能拿到剩余资金，而不是直接取消黄铜海龟的做法，这难道就是他特有的天才之处吗？但是，在这个1.09亿美元的法案中，为他省下最多钱的方法是，他开始发现，他为这个公园制定的一些规划大约每英里耗资800万美元。
of the money versus just eliminating the brass turtles is that his particular brand of genius. But what gets him the most amount of money off of this $109 million bill is he begins to see that he has a certain amount of plans for this park costs about $8 million per mile. And he realizes that this actually goes up into Harlem and he does not care that the people of Harlem have a nice of park as the people in below 125th street.
他意识到这实际上一直延伸到了哈莱姆区，并且他根本不在乎哈莱姆区的人们是否能像125街以下的人们那样拥有一个漂亮的公园。
And so, you know, by building the park to different standards, he saves $29 million. This isn't like a hundred thousand dollars here and a hundred thousand dollars there. Like this is where he really eliminates it by just providing worse services for people who need it more. Yes, by short-shifting the people in the neighborhoods that he considers not really worth spending the money on. And so he's got this park that below 110th street
所以，你知道，通过以不同的标准建设公园，他节省了2900万美元。这可不是这里十万美元、那里十万美元的小打小闹。这才是他真正通过为更需要它的人提供更差的服务来削减成本的地方。是的，通过在那些他认为不值得花钱的街区里对人们进行敷衍和剥夺。所以他拥有了这个公园，在110街以下的部分
is gonna be beautiful. Between 110th and 125th, it's gonna be okay. It's not gonna be so bad. And then from 125th up, it's gonna be done as cheaply as he can do it. And that's over three miles of the park. And so he's saving a lot of money. There's only $45 million to go. He's more than halfway there.
将会非常漂亮。在110街和125街之间，将会还可以。不会太糟糕。然后从125街往上，将会尽可能便宜地完成。那可是公园的三英里多。因此他省下了大量的资金。只剩下4500万美元的缺口了。他已经完成了一半以上。
And at this point, uh, he goes, okay, this section, it's going to cost $30 million, what I don't have paid for this section of the park. I'll tell the city. I can get $20 million in funding from the CWA for labor. If the city pays $10 million for materials. And he does this for this section of the park. I'll tell the city I can get $20 million in funding from the CWA for labor if the city pays $10 million for materials." And he does the same song and dance, are you going to let $20 million in pay for this city?
而此时，呃，他说，好吧，这部分，将花费3000万美元，我没有为公园的这部分支付资金。我会告诉市政府。如果市政府支付1000万美元的材料费，我可以从CWA争取到2000万美元的劳动力资助。他为公园的这一段也是这么做的。我会告诉市政府，如果市政府支付1000万美元的材料费，我可以从CWA争取到2000万美元的劳动力资助。而他也如法炮制，难道你要让2000万美元的工资在这个城市
Going to be lost because you won't spend $10 million? And then when they agree, he goes to CWA and goes, hey, I can get $10 million from the city. Give me $20 million in labor funding. And they agree. He's whipsawing back and forth. And he manages to make it fit the legal bounds of what they can contribute to by calling the Henry Hudson Parkway,
因为你不愿意花1000万美元而打水漂吗？然后当他们同意时，他去找CWA说，嘿，我可以从市政府拿到1000万美元。给我2000万美元的劳动力资助。他们同意了。他左右逢源，通过将亨利·哈德逊公园大道称为公园接入路，
a park access road. It has to have access to a park. It's this huge highway. And now he has all the money he needs to build this stream project up to 192nd street. And this is when it always reminds me how much bigger New York is than any New Yorker spends time in. Because this is a huge city. And how many people spend time below 14th Street and above 192nd Street in the same lifetime? Very few. But he only
设法使其符合他们可以出资的法律界限。它必须能够通往一个公园。这是一条巨大的高速公路。现在他拥有了将这个宏大项目一直修建到192nd街所需的所有资金。正是在这个时候，这总是提醒我，纽约比任何纽约人花时间去了解的都要宏大得多。因为这是一座巨大的城市。在一生中，有多少人会在14街以下和192街以上都花时间呢？寥寥无几。但他只需要
needs $15 million to pay for those last three miles. And this is when we get into the part where he starts to do some things that are irreversible changes to the city in order to find and save this money. There were previous plans for Northern Highway that took a different route that kind of avoided cutting through any of the parks up in the north end of the city, the north end of Manhattan, and building this lower bridge, this lower Henry Hudson Bridge that would go through an industrial area called Marble Hill. And the idea behind this was let's avoid taking up land that people might want to use for other things with this road and this bridge. But Moses has to run the road through the parks, at least in some way, because the funds are from a park access road. And if he doesn't at least get into the parks, then he can't use these funds because it's illegal to charge tolls on roads
1500万美元来支付最后三英里。正是在这个时候，我们进入了他开始采取一些不可逆转的改变来改造城市以寻找和节省这些资金的部分。先前针对北部高速公路有其他的规划，走了一条不同的路线，某种程度上避开了穿过城市北端、曼哈顿北端的任何公园，并建造这座较低的桥梁，这座较低的亨利·哈德逊大桥将穿过一个名为大理石山的工业区。背后的想法是，让我们避免用这条路和这座桥占用人们可能想要用于其他用途的土地。但莫西斯必须让道路穿过公园，至少在某种程度上要穿过，因为资金来自公园接入路。如果他不能至少进入公园，那么他就不能使用这些资金，因为在某些类型的联邦资助的道路上收费是违法的。并且他需要收费来偿还为资助建造亨利·哈德逊大桥而发行的债券。这一切都很复杂。无论如何，最终结果是，他觉得我想我必须把这条路直接穿过这两个公园——特赖恩堡公园和因伍德公园。
that have certain types of federal funding. And he needs to charge tolls to pay off the bonds for funding the building of the Henry Hudson Parkway. It's all complicated. And anyway, the end result is he's like, I guess what I have to do is run this road right through these two parks, Fort Tryon Park and Inwood Park.
那是公园用地。我拥有管辖权。我想做什么就做什么。而且谁说公园接入路就不能一路穿过公园？如果你能一路穿过公园，那就没有什么比这更能体现对公园的接入了。这将为他节省他仍然需要的1500万美元中的500万美元。所以他只需要1000万美元。而这正是亨利·哈德逊管理局被允许筹集的准确金额。不幸的是，正值大萧条时期。纽约市几乎无力偿还债务。
And it's park land. I have control over it. I can do whatever I want. And who's to say a park access road can't run all the way through a park. There's no greater access to a park than if you go all the way through it. And this is going to save him $5 million of the $15 million he still needs. So it only needs $10 million. And this is the exact amount of money that the Henry Hudson authority is allowed to raise. Unfortunately, this is the depression. And New York City has almost defaulted on its loans.
银行家们对投资公共债券非常谨慎。正是在这个时候，罗伯特·卡罗引入了一个新角色，他会时不时地出现——迈克尔·杰克·麦迪根。他的名字叫迈克尔，但他的绰号是杰克。他是在没有受过教育的情况下长大的。他最初是来自宾夕法尼亚煤矿区的承包商。
Bankers are really wary of investing in public bonds. And this is when Robert Carroll brings in a new character who's gonna show up every now and then, Michael Jack Madigan. His name is Michael, but his nickname is Jack. And he grew up uneducated. He's a contractor originally from the Pennsylvania coal country.
他最终成为了莫西斯精明干练的财务零售商，向华尔街银行家出售莫西斯项目的债券。这里有很多关于利率和摊销覆盖率的讨论。我并没有完全理解。我可不是杰克·麦迪根。关键是他在说服贷款人相信会有足够多的司机愿意为了亨利·哈德逊大桥的便利而支付10美分方面遇到了困难。
And he ends up as Moses's shrewd kind of financial retailer who sells bonds for Moses projects to Wall Street bankers. And here there's a lot of talk about interest rates and amortization coverage rates. I do not fully understand it. I am no Jack Madigan. The point is he's having trouble convincing lenders that enough drivers will pay 10 cents for the convenience of this Henry Hudson bridge.
因此，这里有大量的强力推销，银行家们说，我们只购买310万美元的管理局债券，绝不多买。所以如果莫西斯要建这座桥，它的造价就不能超过310万美元。而唯一的办法就是尽可能多地将公园大道延伸至桥梁里弗代尔侧唯一属于城市拥有的土地——范科特兰公园。他施展了他惯常的左右逢源的魔力，但他无法将管理局承担的桥梁建设成本份额压低到500万美元以下。他再也无法削减了。
And so there's a lot of hard selling and the bankers say, we'll buy $3.1 million in authority bonds and no more than that. So if Moses is going to build this bridge, it cannot cost more than $3.1 million. And the only way to do that is to run as much of the parkway as possible through the only city owned land on the Riverdale side of the bridge, Van Cortland Park. And he does his usual whipsawing magic, but he can't get the authorities share of the bridge costs lower than $5 million. He can't cut it anymore.
他感到沮丧，准确地说是500万零9万美元。他不知道该怎么办。麦迪根有个主意。如果他们不完全建完这座桥呢？它本应是一座六车道的大桥。如果他们建造一座四车道的大桥，但把支撑它的拱门做得足够坚固，以至于他们可以在上面加装一个上层甲板呢？
He gets depressed, technically $5 million, $90,000. And he doesn't know what to do. Madigan has an idea. What if they don't totally finish the bridge? It's supposed to be a six lane bridge. What if they build a four lane bridge, but they make the arches supporting it strong enough that they could put an upper deck on there
他感到沮丧，技术上说是500万美元、9万美元。他不知道该怎么办。摩西有个主意。如果他们不完全建完这座桥呢？这本该是一座六车道的大桥。如果他们建一座四车道的大桥，但把支撑它的拱门做得足够结实，这样他们就能在上面加建一个上层甲板呢？
when they have the money for two more lanes. And the bankers say, okay. And they sign an agreement that says if traffic reaches a certain level on the bridge, they'll buy another $2 million worth of bonds to complete the bridge. And with that, the financing of the West Side Improvement Project is finally complete.
当他们有钱再修两条车道时。银行家们说，行。于是他们签署了一份协议，规定如果桥上的交通量达到一定水平，他们就会再买价值200万美元的债券来完成这座桥的建设。至此，西区改善工程的融资终于大功告成了。
He did it. He and his staff have succeeded in doing something the city has been trying to do for 50 years, funding improvement that will make the West Side of the city livable and make it easier for people to drive north and south on the west side. And Robert Carrow says this is perhaps the supreme example of the practical side, the getting things done side of Moses thinking he has got this thing done only Roman. When you are going to build this huge thing through parks, that's totally fine, right?
他做到了。他和他的团队成功做了一件这座城市50年来一直在尝试做的事，资助了一项能让城市的西区宜居，并让人们在西区南北开车更加便利的改善工程。罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Carrow）说，这或许是摩西思维中注重务实、注重实干一面的最高典范，他把事情办成了，只是，罗曼。当你打算在公园里修建这个巨大的庞然大物时，这完全没问题，对吧？
Like that doesn't affect anything. You know, that's, you're not sacrificing anything that you can never get back again, right? Probably. Yeah, I mean, this is something that's really key to understanding New York at this time. I mean, up here in this park, it's kind of the last natural area of the island of Manhattan. I mean, it is not developed much at all. And these are the types of parks that Robert Moses doesn't really care for. He's a recreation park kind of guy. Like Woodlands doesn't really excite him because he didn't build it.
就像这不会影响任何事情一样。你知道，那就是，你没有牺牲任何你永远无法再找回的东西，对吧？大概吧。是的，我的意思是，这是理解当时纽约的关键所在。我的意思是，在城区的这个公园里，它是曼哈顿岛上最后的自然区域。我的意思是，它几乎没有怎么被开发过。而这些正是罗伯特·摩西并不太在乎的公园类型。他是一个喜欢游乐公园的人。林地并不能真正让他兴奋，因为不是他建的。
You know? And so some people, you know, when this plan goes into effect, you know, they love this park, including a couple of reformers, Bill Exton and Bob Weinberg. And, you know, they say, you know, like there's ways to build around this. And what they probably don't know,
你知道吗？所以有些人，你知道的，当这个计划生效时，你知道，他们很喜欢这个公园，包括几位改革派人士比尔·埃克斯顿（Bill Exton）和鲍勃·温伯格（Bob Weinberg）。而且，你知道，他们说，你知道的，比如有办法绕过这个进行建设。而他们可能不知道的是，
the amount of work he has done to get to this point, and he doesn't want to undo like a single, like legal pad worth. Yes, he is such a, such a tightly constructed, like an intricate house of financial cards that can't tumble. And these two guys, Exton and Weinberg and Exton is particularly focused on Inwood Hill Park, which is that kind of untouched wilderness. It's on the Northwest tip of Manhattan Island. This is like you're saying, this is a New York city that still has untouched wilderness. It's on the northwest tip of Manhattan Island. This is, like you're saying, this is a New York city that still has untouched parkland. It still has marshland that hasn't been touched. And all of that is going to be wrecked. A huge six-lane highway is going to go through that woodland. The plan involves them taking this last natural marshland, which Carol paints as this kind of biological refuge that biology classes go to to see life that they can't see anywhere else in the city.
他为了走到这一步所付出的工作量，他可不想撤销哪怕一张法律记事本那么多的内容。是的，他就是这样一个构建得如此紧密、像一座摇摇欲坠的复杂金融纸牌屋的人。而这两个家伙，埃克斯顿和温伯格——埃克斯顿尤其专注于因伍德山公园（Inwood Hill Park），那是那种未被触及的荒野。它位于曼哈顿岛的西北端。这就好比你说的，这是一个仍然拥有未被触及的荒野的纽约市。它位于曼哈顿岛的西北端。这就好比你说的，这是一个仍然拥有未被触及的公园绿地的纽约市。它仍然有未被触及的沼泽地。而所有这些都将被毁掉。一条巨大的六车道高速公路将穿过那片林地。该计划涉及他们占用这片最后的天然沼泽地，卡罗将这里描绘成一种生物避难所，生物课的学生们会去那里观察在城市其他地方看不到的生命。
That's going to get turned into an enormous clover leaf with like landscaped, uh, shrubbery because Moses doesn't like that stuff. And Weinberg is protective of this neighborhood called Sputenduyvel. That is it's almost rural at this point in the Bronx, this small thing. And right now it has a two-lane road and that would be turned into again into a six-lane highway, which would kind of split this community in half. And they find this original alternate route that avoids cutting through these places. And they find, oh, this route would be cheaper. It'd be a little longer, be cheaper. And also, and they don't have the terms to describe this
那片地方将被改造成一个巨大的三叶草形立交桥，配有景观灌木丛，因为摩西不喜欢那种自然的东西。而温伯格则在保护一个叫斯普腾戴维尔（Sputenduyvel）的社区。在布朗克斯区，这个小地方在当时几乎还保留着乡村风貌。目前它只有一条双车道公路，而这将被再次变成一条六车道高速公路，这会把这个社区拦腰截断。他们找到了一个最初的替代路线，可以避免穿过这些地方。他们发现，哦，这条路线会更便宜。会稍微长一点，但更便宜。而且还有，虽然他们当时在30年代还没有合适的词汇来描述这个，
at the time in the thirties, but it would be better environmentally and ecologically. They do start to worry about things like, what's gonna happen to drainage in this area if we remove all these trees? They don't have the words for that, because at the time, who was thinking about the environment in the 1930s? Very few people.
但它在环境和生态上会更好。他们确实开始担心诸如，如果我们移走所有这些树，这个地区的排水系统会发生什么之类的事情。他们没有这方面的词汇，因为在当时，20世纪30年代谁会考虑环境问题呢？极少数人。
I mean, John Muir was until he died. I don't know when he died, but I assumed he was dead by then. But there was no environmental movement like that. There was only a little bit of a preservation movement. And they're worried that not just environmentally, but if you run this road through Sputnik and Doval, then like Riverdale, that area is going to be overrun with people. And I should have asked my mom, my mom lived in Riverdale until she was 13. I should have asked her if it felt overrun with people, but she certainly, she lived in an apartment building
我的意思是，约翰·缪尔（John Muir）在他去世前是会考虑的。我不知道他什么时候去世的，但我假设他到那时候已经去世了。但当时并没有那样的环保运动。只有一点点的保护运动。他们担心不仅是对环境的破坏，如果你把这条路修过斯普腾戴维尔，那么像里弗代尔（Riverdale）那样的地区就会涌入大量的人口。我本该问问我妈妈的，我妈妈13岁之前一直住在里弗代尔。我本该问问她，那里当时是不是感觉挤满了人，但她确实，她当时住在一栋公寓楼里。
then. And that was an area that had houses. It didn't have apartments at the time, that when the, in the thirties, when this is happening. My mom didn't live there in the thirties. Don't worry about it. Don't have to worry about my mom's timeline. And the thing is, as Carol makes the point of saying, this kind of thing cannot be undone.
然后。那是一个原本只有独栋房屋的地区。在30年代事情发生的时候，那里并没有公寓。我妈妈不是在30年代住在那里。别担心。不用担心我妈妈的时间线。关键是，正如卡罗所指出的那样，这种事情是无法逆转的。
If you destroy that marshland, if you run a road through that forest, you cannot ever get that back. That's impossible to return. And not only that, if you have this, he's been talking about this park that runs along the river, but really it's the highway that runs along the river for most of that length, right along the water. And that cuts off the waterfront from New Yorkers forever. You won't be able to walk along the river.
如果你摧毁了那片沼泽地，如果你在那个森林里修了一条路，你将永远无法把它买回来。那是无法恢复的。不仅如此，如果你拥有了这个——他一直在谈论这个沿着河岸延伸的公园，但实际上是沿着河岸延伸的高速公路占据了大部分长度，紧挨着水边。这把纽约人与滨水区永远隔绝开来了。你将无法沿着河边散步。
You can't fish from it. You can't picnic by it. And I grew up going to New York and then living in New York where this is already the case, the waterfront is maybe a little parts of it that you can fish off of a highway overpass or something like that, or, you know, off the, over a railing. But there were, for most of New York's history before this time, you could go down to the water and just kind of be there at the water. This is why New York was one of the great oyster fishing centers of the world.
你不能在河边钓鱼。你不能在河边野餐。我是去过纽约并在纽约生活过的人，当时这种情况已经存在了，滨水区可能只有一小部分地方，你可以从高速公路立交桥上或者诸如此类的地方钓鱼，或者，你知道的，从栏杆上方钓鱼。但在纽约这段历史的大部分时间里，在这个时期之前，你可以走到水边，就在水边待着。这就是为什么纽约曾是世界伟大的牡蛎捕捞中心之一。
You know, the big oyster, you could, you could just go down to the water and get stuff. And of course that also meant people would just like throw trash into the water for centuries, but still Moses will be creating a wall of Russian cars that will separate New Yorkers from their waterfront. And we'll talk about this more later, probably, but I lived in New York for years and I would forget I lived in a maritime city because you, you are cut off from the water and you just don't think about it. You don't involve yourself with it very much.
你知道，那个大牡蛎，你可以，你就可以直接走到水边去捞东西。当然，这也意味着人们几个世纪以来一直会把垃圾扔进水里，但尽管如此，摩西还是会建造一堵由飞驰的汽车组成的墙，将纽约人与他们的滨水区隔开。我们以后可能会更多地谈论这个，我曾在纽约住了多年，以至于我会忘记自己住在海滨城市，因为你与水隔绝了，你根本不会去想它。你不会过多地参与其中。
It's a pretty big deal and I'm going to invoke another city of the United States, Chicago, as a counterexample. I think one of the most important reasons why Chicago is as good as it is, is that there was an ordinance that you could not build large commercial buildings on the east side of Lakeshore Drive, which is the drive that goes along Lake Michigan. And it allows just everyone to both, you know, to see, to go down, experience the lake and make it a part of their lives and doesn't cut it off the way a bunch of high rises would.
这是一件相当大的事，我要以美国的另一个城市芝加哥为例来作为反例。我认为芝加哥之所以这么好的最重要的原因之一，是有一项法令规定，在湖滨大道（Lakeshore Drive，即沿着密歇根湖行驶的道路）的东侧不得建造大型商业建筑。它让每个人都能既看到、下去体验湖泊，并使其成为他们生活的一部分，而不会像一堆高层建筑那样把它隔绝开来。
And it really is like one of the most important architectural features of Chicago, making it as great as it is. That preservation, as opposed to building great things, sometimes in order to make the great things great, you have to have some restraint and think about the system as a whole. And it really does, it's so important to Chicago.
这确实是芝加哥最重要的建筑特色之一，使其如此伟大。这种保护，而不是建造伟大的东西，有时为了使伟大的东西真正伟大，你必须保持一些克制，并从整体系统来考虑。这真的很重要，对芝加哥来说太重要了。
I think it's one of the most important things about Chicago that makes it great. It feels so central to that city, that it's right there, as opposed to, if you wanna see the water in New York, you have to go out. You gotta go out to the, if you wanna go to the beach, you gotta go to the far reaches, where Coney Island or Rock you know, Rockaway is.
我认为这是让芝加哥变得伟大的最重要的事物之一。它让人感觉是这座城市的内核，它就在那里，相比之下，如果你想在纽约看水，你得出去。你必须去到，如果你想去海滩，你必须去到很远的远方，科尼岛（Coney Island）或洛克威（Rockaway）所在的地方。
It's such a weird thing. It's a place surrounded by water, you know? Yeah. And you don't get to experience it. And it's a real choice and a real bad choice that people made when they designed these cities and they did these things. Yeah.
这真是件很奇怪的事。一个被水环绕的地方，你知道吗？是的。而你却无法体验到它。这是一个真实的抉择，也是人们在设计这些城市和做这些事情时做出的一个非常糟糕的抉择。是的。
Although I will ask this question just to play devil's advocate. How many King Kongs does Chicago have? I rest my case, your honor, I rest my case. Although I will ask this question just to play devil's advocate. How many King Kongs does Chicago have? I rest my case, your honor, I rest my case. I think we can end this trial here. And so Robert Carroll, going back to the book, he presents this as a conflict of values. Like we talked about, Moses' generation, parks are for upper class people.
尽管我会问这个问题，只是为了唱反调。芝加哥有多少个金刚？我无话可说了，法官大人，我无话可说了。尽管我会问这个问题，只是为了唱反调。芝加哥有多少个金刚？我无话可说了，法官大人，我无话可说了。我想我们可以到此结束这场审判了。因此，罗伯特·卡罗回到书中，将此表现为一种价值观的冲突。正如我们所讨论的，在摩西的那一代人眼里，公园是属于上流社会的人的。
You take leisurely drives in them. And as he was coming of age, the question was, we've got all this land, how are we going to develop it so people can use it? Now the land has been developed. And the new question is, how do we preserve what's left that's undeveloped for the people who need an escape from that development? And how do you balance the needs of people traveling
你在里面悠闲地开车兜风。而当他成年时，问题变成了：我们拥有了这片土地，该如何开发它以便人们使用？现在这片土地已经被开发了。而新的问题是：我们如何为那些需要逃离这种开发的人，去保护剩下尚未被开发的土地？以及你如何平衡那些在城市中穿行的出行者的需求，
through the city with the needs of people in the city? And Kara talks about weighing the need for this bridge against the risk of not having the money for it in the future, against the destruction of not having the money for it in the future, against the destruction of the things the city can never bring back. It's a very complicated equation. Yeah. And Moses refuses to think about it.
与城市居民的需求？卡罗谈到了权衡这座桥的需求与未来资金短缺的风险，权衡未来资金短缺所带来的破坏，与城市再也无法恢复的事物的破坏。这是一个非常复杂的方程式。是的。而摩西拒绝去考虑它。
Yeah. He doesn't want to talk to anybody about it. He does grant a meeting to Exton and apparently spends it laughing at him the entire time, which again is bullying behavior. Why are you going to do that? Yeah. And other city officials listen. They notice that again, Moses is planning these parkway bridges too low for buses to pass under them. We don't need
是的。他不想跟任何人谈论这件事。他确实答应与埃克斯顿会面，显然整场会面都在嘲笑对方，这又是一种霸凌行为。你为什么要这么做？是的。其他城市官员也听进去了。他们注意到，摩西再次将这些公园大道桥梁设计得太矮，以至于公共汽车无法从下面通过。我们不需要
to open up that kettle of worms again. But Moses ignores that anyway. And there are some civic groups that start listening to the reformers who are against it. But the group with the most clout is the Park Association. The Park Association is led by Iph Salzberger and she just loves Moses. She's in the tank for him. She has the Park Association approve these plans. And once again, as we will see time and again, the reformers are shocked to realize that this law they lobbied for that gives Moses ultimate power over parks was not a great idea. That he's not the benevolent king of parks that they were hoping for. Much like the king of cartoons on PB's Playhouse is a benevolent king. He doesn't tell you what should be in a cartoon or not.
再次揭开那个潘多拉魔盒了。但摩西还是不理那一套。有一些公民团体开始听取反对它的改革派的意见。但最有影响力的团体是公园协会（Park Association）。公园协会由伊芙·萨尔茨伯格（Iph Salzberger）领导，她简直爱死摩西了。她完全被他收编了。她让公园协会批准了这些计划。正如我们将一次又一次看到的那样，改革派们再次惊愕地发现，他们为之游说、赋予摩西对公园拥有绝对权力的这项法律并不是个好主意。他并不是他们所期望的公园仁慈之王。就像公共电视网（PBS）儿童节目《皮威乐园》（Pee-wee's Playhouse）里的卡通之王是个仁慈的国王一样。他不会告诉你卡通里应该有什么不应该有什么。
He just shows you a little bit of a public domain cartoon and then leaves. But Moses is much more destructive than that guy. And he does his favorite stuff. He goes, oh, I'll hold public hearings. And then he starts cutting down hundreds of trees weeks before the hearings. And he drives stakes, he whipsaws, he misinforms, and his opponents
他只是给你看一点公共领域的卡通片然后就离开了。但摩西比那个家伙更具破坏性。而且他做着他最喜欢的事。他说，哦，我要举行听证会。然后他在听证会前几周就开始砍伐数百棵树。他钉上木桩，出尔反尔，散布错误信息，而他的反对者们
don't really have technical experts who can examine Moses plans fully and without the support of the press, without support of the mayor, because the mayor wants this West Side improvement to run on for reelection, there's little that anyone can do to obstruct him and Moses begins work cartoonishly fast. So the board of estimate meets to vote on the route through Sputnik and Duival. By the time they meet to vote, the bridgeheads have already been installed. So there's nowhere else for it to go. It has to go there. And the legislation authorizing the building of the Henry Hudson Bridge, it's signed at 1 PM on May 1st, 1935. At 5 PM, Moses has already signed the contracts with the contractors.
并没有真正能够全面审视摩西计划的技术专家，而且在没有媒体支持、没有市长支持的情况下——因为市长希望这个西区改善工程能持续到他竞选连任——没有人能做多少事情来阻挠他，而且摩西以一种漫画般的速度开始动工。因此，估价委员会（board of estimate）开会投票表决通过斯普腾戴维尔的路线。当他们开会投票时，桥头堡已经安装好了。所以它已经无处可去。它只能去那里。而授权建造亨利·哈德逊大桥（Henry Hudson Bridge）的立法于1935年5月1日下午1点签署。下午5点，摩西就已经与承包商签好了合同。
And by 7 AM., the next day, the workers are working on it. And a few weeks later at midnight, they're putting the steel spans in place, and they're installed by 5.55 a.m. that day. And Cairo says, when River Dalians went to work in the morning, there before them was a bridge where none had existed the night before.
第二天早上7点，工人们就在上面开工了。几周后的午夜，他们正在把钢跨度结构安放到位，并在当天早上5点55分安装完毕。卡罗说，当里弗代尔的居民早上上班去时，一座前一天晚上还不存在的桥就那样立在他们面前。
Like, he's building bridges overnight. It's bonkers. And Moses has to work fast because he can't allow people to discuss things. He cannot have it get out that he is referring to a highway as a park access road or that all these decisions about location and how the bridge is designed are not based on what's best for the bridge or what's best for the city,
就像这样，他一夜之间建起桥梁。这太疯狂了。摩西必须抓紧干活，因为他不能允许人们讨论事情。他绝不能泄露出去：他把一条高速公路称为公园连接道路，或者关于选址和桥梁设计的所有这些决定，都不是基于什么对桥梁最好或对城市最好，
but based on what are bankers going to invest in? What are they going to buy bonds in? Discussion might create controversy. Controversy scares investors. He is only interested in what's going to keep the investment coming in. And discussion also means delay. And who knows? New York city may never have access to this kind of money again for this project. And Jack Madigan tells Caro, there was no alternative. And Caro is like in the book, I don't know if he said this to Madigan,
而是基于银行家们会投资什么？他们会买什么债券？讨论可能会引起争议。争议会吓退投资者。他只对能让投资源源不断流入的东西感兴趣。讨论也意味着拖延。谁知道呢？纽约市可能再也不会有资金来进行这个项目了。杰克·麦迪根（Jack Madigan）告诉卡罗，别无选择。而卡罗在书里就好像——我不知道他是不是对麦迪根这么说的，
but in the book he's like, uh, there is an alternative. You can just wait and not build the bridge right now. Like wait till later. Like, why is that to be right now? What's, what's like, it'd be great to have this bridge, but the rest of the project is almost finished. You don't really need this bridge
但在书里他的意思是，呃，其实是有选择的。你可以等一等，现在先不建这座桥。比如等到以后再说。就像，为什么非得是现在？有什么——就像，有这座桥固然很好，但项目的其余部分快完成了。你其实并不需要这座桥
for the whole West side improvement. LaGuardia is fixing the city budget. He's getting a little better. If you need a bridge, do this. Can't you balance that against the fact that the economy may or may not get better or worse and the fact that there are things that we're gonna lose forever by building it in this place and to Moses and his men, those things don't matter at all. So why would they bother about it? They don't have to care if those things matter to someone else. They
来完成整个西区改善工程。拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）正在修复城市预算。情况正在变好。如果你需要一座桥，就这么办。难道你不能权衡一下这一点：经济可能会变好也可能会变坏，以及这样一个事实——通过在这个地方修建它，我们将永远失去一些东西？而对摩西和他的手下来说，这些东西根本不重要。所以他们为什么要为此烦恼呢？如果这些东西对别人重要，他们也不必在乎。他们
don't matter to them. They have the power to ignore them. It's the cutting down the trees that just gets me so mad and sad at the same time. Oh, for me it's the marsh, but the trees too, the trees too, all that stuff. I mean, just like, you know, while people are discussing things, you know, he just does what he always does, and just like the, of the places he controls,
不在乎。他们有权力无视这些。砍伐树木这件事最让我感到既愤怒又悲伤。哦，对我的来说是沼泽，但树木也是，树木也是，所有这些东西。我的意思是，就像，当人们还在讨论事情的时候，你知道，他只是做他一贯做的事，就像对待他控制的那些地方一样，
he just destroys them so that there's nothing to save at a certain point. And that just is like heartbreaking. I find that extremely upsetting. It really, it reminds me of, it's a more effective version of something that was said in, when George W. Bush was president, where someone, I forget who it was, if it was Rumsfeld or Rove or somebody, was like, well, the press can talk about this stuff, but while the press is talking
他只是摧毁它们，以至于在某个时刻什么也救不了。这简直令人心碎。我觉得这极其令人不安。这真的让我想起，这是一种更有效的说法，在乔治·W·布什担任总统时有人说过，有人，我忘了是谁，是拉姆斯费尔德还是罗夫还是别的什么人，曾说，好吧，媒体可以谈论这些事情，但当媒体在谈论
about reality, we're gonna be out there creating new realities and then the press can talk about that. And it's Moses is like, yeah, we can discuss whether we should cut those trees down, but they're down. So you can talk about it, but I'm gonna do it. And once I've done it, you're not gonna be able to stop me. And it's so, it's just, it's horrifying. Yeah, and that fact that I remember reading this book
现实时，我们将走出去创造新的现实，然后媒体就可以谈论这个。摩西的意思是，是的，我们可以讨论我们是否应该砍掉那些树，但它们已经被砍了。所以你可以谈论它，但我打算这么做。一旦我做了，你就无法阻止我。这太，这简直是太可怕了。是的，事实上我记得读过这本书
for the first time when I was a young man and being like so mad about him destroying that forest, destroying that marsh land and having to remind myself, like getting physically angry while I was reading it and having to remind myself, this happened before your parents were born. Like this is, it's no use getting mad about it now. You know, and Moses would, I'm sure say the day
第一次读时我还很年轻，对他摧毁那片森林、摧毁那片沼泽地感到无比愤怒，不得不提醒自己，一边读一边气得浑身发抖，不得不提醒自己，这发生在你父母出生之前。就像这样，现在生气也没有用了。你知道的，摩西肯定也会在树被砍倒的第二天说
after the trees are cut down, why get mad about it? It's done. You know, you can't, you know, what's done is done. But the carol does such a good job of just making you so sad that it happened, even when you're reading it decades later, when it's not just a fete accompli, it's history. It happens. You know, there's no changing it. He talks about December 12th, 1936, the Henry Hudson Bridge opens. The ceremony doesn't go great, it's raining. And this detail that I love that LaGuardia forces them to stop the ceremony so he can go to the radio and listen to King Edward VIII abdicate from his throne.
为什么还要为此生气？事情已经结束了。你知道，你不能，你知道的，覆水难收。但罗伯特·卡罗把这件事写得太好了，让你对发生的事情感到无比悲伤，即使你在几十年后阅读它，当它不仅仅是一个既成事实，而是历史的时候。它确实发生了。你知道的，这是无法改变的。他谈到1936年12月12日，亨利·哈德森大桥开通。仪式进行得不太顺利，下着雨。我特别喜欢的一个细节是，拉瓜迪亚强迫他们暂停仪式，以便他能去收音机旁听爱德华八世国王宣布退位。
And I love the idea of that, that like, just that moment to remind the reader and to remind maybe Moses too, that like, there's other stuff going on in the world besides the Henry Hudson Bridge opening. Like this is not the most important thing going on in the world right now. Not that the King of England abdicating is the most important thing in the world either, but there's other stuff going on. Moses is so proud of this and the whole thing is finished by October of 1937.
我喜欢这个想法，仅仅是那个时刻，提醒读者，或许也提醒摩西，除了亨利·哈德森大桥开通之外，世界上还有别的事在发生。这并不是当时世界上最重要的事情。倒不是说英国国王退位就是世界上最重要的事情，但还有别的事在发生。摩西对此感到非常自豪，整个工程在1937年10月前就全部完成了。
It's just six miles of parks and roads replacing six miles of garbage dumps and industrial waste and shanty towns. And this is the dream he has had since he was a young man and he's made it happen. And Robert Caro goes onto this long, very beautiful section describing the experience of driving through the woods right outside the city, in the woods that run alongside the Sawmill River Parkway and then going onto the Henry Hudson
这只是六英里的公园和道路，取代了六英里的垃圾堆、工业废料和棚户区。这是他自年轻时的梦想，而他让它成为了现实。罗伯特·卡罗接着写了一段很长的、非常优美的文字，描述了开车穿过城市边缘的树林、穿过锯木河公园旁的树林然后走上亨利·哈德森大桥的体验
and finally emerging into New York. And he pretend, he makes you imagine you're one of the reporters on opening day and the kind of magical effect of descending from the forest to the city and how beautifully this has all been put together. There's really no way for me to, I'd love to read some selections from it, but there's no way to abridge it and keep the power in it. So you're going to have to just read the book. I'm sorry. Just read the section of the book about it.
最后驶入纽约。他假装，他让你想象自己是开幕当天的记者之一，想象那种从森林驶入城市的奇妙效果，以及这一切是如何被完美地组合在一起的。我真的没有办法，我很想朗读其中的一些选段，但没有办法在删节的同时保持其中的力量。所以你们只能自己去读这本书。我很抱歉。去读书中关于这部分的内容吧。
And it's for a moment, I don't know if you had this, had this impression, but for the moment, it's almost like Robert Caro makes me agree that, yeah, maybe this was worthwhile because it's such a, the way he describes it is so beautiful and so powerful. And like, I've driven into New York before. Like it's not, I've never had that experience of like, of awe other than the moment you see the skyline
而且有一会儿，我不知道你是否有这种感觉，但有一会儿，罗伯特·卡罗几乎让我觉得，是的，也许这很值得，因为它是如此，他描述的方式是如此美丽和有力。而且，我以前也开车进过纽约。这并不是，我从来没有过那种敬畏的体验，除了你看到天际线的那一刻
for the first time is always a magical moment. But he does such a good job of indicting Moses, but then also being like, yeah, but look at this thing that he built. Like giving him his fair rope, you know? Yeah, I think that's right. And I do find a lot of the parkways in the sort of East coast nice to be on.
第一次总是神奇的时刻。但他把摩西批判得很好，但同时又像是在说，是的，但看看他建造的这个东西。就像给他留出足够的活动空间一样，你知道吗？是的，我认为这很对。而且我确实觉得东海岸的很多公园路开起来很舒服。
And a lot of these bridges are nice to be on I love going over the Golden Gate Bridge. For example, you didn't have to destroy a forest to create it but but I mean, I probably probably part of the person you know, who knows anyway, but the I Also just like this this part of this doesn't work on me I mean I own a couple of cars, you know, like a big family, but I do not enjoy driving. It is just a functional thing for me. When everyone says to me like, oh, it's just such a nice drive, it's a beautiful drive,
而且这些桥很多都很好开，我喜欢过金门大桥。例如，你不需要为了建造它而摧毁一片森林，但但我的意思是，我可能也算是那种人吧，谁知道呢，不过我，我也只是喜欢这部分，这对我不管用。我的意思是，我名下有几辆车，你知道的，一个大家庭的车，但我并不喜欢开车。对这我来说只是一件功能性的事情。当每个人都对我说，哦，这真是一次很好的车程，这是一次美丽的自驾游，
I'm just like, that for some reason just doesn't work on me, even though I'm a car dependent person where I live. And so I just, I get it, but I also like, this is for, you know, he's designing a world for himself to be sitting in the back of a chauffeured car. And I mean, that makes, um, a drive way more beautiful.
我就会觉得，不知为何这对我不管用，尽管我住的地方是一个依赖汽车生活的人。所以我就懂了，但我也觉得，这是为，你知道的，他正在为一个坐在专车后座的自己设计一个世界。我的意思是，这确实让，嗯，车程变得美妙得多。
Now imagine you were sitting in the back of that chauffeured car. Oh boy, how great it would be. No, but I, it would be amazing. It's funny reading that I read this, the first time I read this, I was 20 years old. And at that point, I hated driving. I didn't like it as a teenager.
现在想象你坐在那辆专车的后座上。天哪，那该有多棒。不，但是我觉得，那会是惊人的。有趣的是，我读这个，我第一次读这个的时候我20岁。在那时，我讨厌开车。作为一个青少年，我并不喜欢它。
I was living in New York. I would live in New York for years without owning a car or touching the wheel of a car. And both the inside wheel and the outside, the steering wheel and any of the outside wheels that it's touched the ground. I don't know why I would touch those, but I didn't touch those either.
我当时住在纽约。我在纽约住了多年，没有车，也没有碰过汽车的方向盘。不管是内侧的方向盘还是外侧的，方向盘和任何触地外侧轮胎。我不知道我为什么要碰那些，但我也没有碰那些。
And maybe I'm trying to remember, I think it's still affecting me somewhat, but now as a Los Angeles resident and someone who drives most days and has really come to enjoy driving, maybe that's it. I'm like, imagine yourself. I'm like, yeah, that would be a really nice drive. Like, but I'm imagining that drive on opening the preview, the reporters get, when there are no other cars. And so a daily news reporter, he calls it the most beautiful drive in the world.
也许我在努力回想，我觉得它现在还在某种程度上影响着我，但现在作为洛杉矶居民和大多数日子都在开车并且真的很享受开车的人，也许就是这样。我当时就想，想象一下你自己。我就想，是的，那会是一次非常棒的自驾。就像，但我在想象在通车预览时的那种自驾，记者们在没有其他车的时候体验到的那种。因此，一个《每日新闻》的记者称之为世界上最美丽的公路之旅。
The press loves it. Most is like, this is gonna eliminate West side traffic jams. It's gonna take 26 minutes to get from Canal Street to the edge of the city, which is amazing. That's amazing. And I'd like, I've made a note here. I've gone on trips where I have to drive down Canal Street
媒体很喜欢它。摩西说，这将消除西区交通拥堵。从卡al街到城市边缘只需26分钟，这太棒了。这太棒了。我想，我在这里做了一个笔记。我去过一些不得不开车沿着卡纳尔街行驶的旅行
and it takes more than 26 minutes because it's so incredibly traffic jammed. And there's all these statistics on how much hydraulic fill they use, and how much feed of steel and cubic yards of granite. And Moses says, and the whole thing only cost $24 million, which is of course a huge lie. And Caro says, ultimately, there's no way of knowing exactly how much it costs because there's so many different sources that are tied up in these things. Caro estimates that the entire project all put together with all the money from everywhere and the tax assessments and things cost at least $180 million,
这花费的时间超过26分钟，因为交通实在是堵得不可思议。这里还有各种统计数据，关于他们用了多少水力填方，多少英尺的钢材和立方的花岗岩。摩西说，整个工程只花了2400万美元这当然是一个弥天大谎。卡罗说，最终，根本无法确切知道它花了多少钱，因为有太多不同的资金来源牵涉其中。卡罗估计，整个项目汇集所有地方的资金、税收评估以及其他费用，至少花费了1.8亿美元，
maybe as high as $218 million. And that's in 1930s dollars. This is what a hamburger costs like a nickel, you know? And he says the Boulder Dam, which at the time was the monument to how expensive you could build something, cost $76 million. And this West Side improvement potentially cost two or maybe even three possibly times more. But it's at the same time, everyone's talking about how great it is, you know, and it's so beautiful.
甚至高达2.18亿美元。那可是20世纪30年代的美元。那时候汉堡只卖几美分，你知道吗？他说，当时作为造价高昂纪念碑的博尔德大坝花费了7600万美元。而这个西区改善工程潜在的花费可能是其两倍甚至三倍。但与此同时，每个人都在谈论它是多么棒，你知道的，它是如此美丽。
And finally the West Side railroad tracks are covered up. The press is excited about that. And Carol goes, not exactly. The railroad tracks were covered until they reached 125th Street. And then once you're in Harlem, the tracks were covered up. The press is excited about that. And Carol says, not exactly. The railroad tracks were covered until they reached 125th Street. And then once you're in Harlem, the tracks run covered and there's from 125th up to 155th Street. And so you get stench and soot and grime and noise. And Carol says, the white people who lived along Riverside Drive were freed from those
最后，西区的铁路线被遮盖起来了。媒体对此感到兴奋。卡罗说，并非如此。铁路线一直被遮盖到125街。然后一旦你进入哈莱姆区，铁路线就被遮盖了，媒体对此感到兴奋。卡罗说，并非如此。铁路线一直被遮盖到125街。然后一旦你进入哈莱姆区，铁路线就露在外面，从125街一直延伸到155街。所以你会闻到恶臭、煤烟、污垢和噪音。卡罗说，住在河滨大道沿线的白人摆脱了这些
annoyances, but the black people were not. And it talks about how Moses added 132 acres of land to the parts of the park below 125th street with all the fill and stuff like that. He added no new land to the park areas above 125th street that are likely to be used by black New Yorkers. And Carroll essentially describes two different parks. One of them is very lush, it's very ornamented, it's beautiful and is free of commercial buildings.
烦恼，但黑人却没有。书中谈到摩西如何在125街以下的公园部分通过填方等方式增加了132英亩的土地。他没有为125街以上可能经常被黑人纽约人使用的公园区域增加任何新的土地。卡罗本质上描述了两个不同的公园。其中一个非常郁郁葱葱，有很多装饰，非常美丽，而且没有商业建筑。
And the other one above 125th has had as little work put into it as possible. There's a minimum of any sort of facilities and they're not easily accessible. And this is where Caro talks about how in the Harlem section of Riverside Park, there are decorations of wrought iron monkeys that appear to have shackles on their arms.
而125街以上的另一个公园则几乎没有投入什么工作。那里的各种设施降到了最低，而且不易到达。这就是卡罗提到在河滨公园的哈莱姆区路段，有一些锻铁猴子的装饰，它们的胳膊上似乎带着镣铐。
This has become a very controversial claim. We don't need to get into it right now. We'll probably get into it in the future. But this is something that there are two, I feel like there are two aspects of this book that get picked at. This has become a very controversial claim. We don't need to get into it right now. We'll probably get into it in the future. We will talk about it. Yeah. But this is something that there are two, I feel like there are two aspects of this book that get picked at. And one of them is this claim and the other is the height of the bridges.
这已经成了一个极具争议的说法。我们现在不需要深入讨论它。我们以后可能会讨论它。但这是其中的一部分，我觉得这本书有两个方面经常遭到挑剔。这已经成了一个极具争议的说法。我们现在不需要深入讨论它。我们以后可能会讨论它。我们会谈论它的。是的。但这是其中的一部分，我觉得这本书有两个方面经常遭到挑剔。其中之一就是这种说法，另一个是桥梁的高度。
And we'll return to them again and again. But we're talking about this other thing right now. So we'll get back to that another time. The press, they're talking about how Moses has reclaimed the waterfront for the people, but Carol makes the point that for much of the improvement, the parks are not on the waterfront. The parkway is. Like you can't even really see the water past the road. So a driver gets a few moments of a beautiful view,
我们会一遍又一遍地回到这些话题。但我们现在在谈论别的事情。所以我们以后会再讨论这个。媒体在谈论摩西如何为人民收复了滨水区，但卡罗指出，在大部分的改善工程中，公园并不在滨水区。公园路才是。就像你甚至无法透过道路看到水面一样。所以司机可以享受片刻的美丽风景，
but the person on foot can't with the time to absorb that view. They can see almost none of it. And he says, with a chance, a wonderful chance to give the city's people a way of escaping the city, he had instead sealed them within it, which is such an ominous way to talk about it. It's so scary. And I have to admit, when you're in New York City, you don't feel sealed in necessarily, but I do wish that you could get to the water more easily. And the driver totals are enormous.
但步行的人却没有时间去欣赏这种风景。他们几乎什么也看不到。他说，这是一个绝佳的机会，本可以给这座城市的人们提供一种逃离城市的方式，但他却把他们封锁在了城市里面，用这种不祥的方式来谈论它。这太可怕了。我必须承认，当你身处纽约市时，你并不一定觉得自己被封锁在里面，但我确实希望你能更容易地亲近水。而且司机的总数极其巨大。
The bankers had promised they would only buy more bonds when traffic reaches 6,000 cars per day. On the first day of toll collection, over 9,000 cars use it. They're like, okay, it's a new bridge. People are excited about driving over it. It's not gonna always be that way. But the drive totals continue to go up and up. And they have a chart in the shape of a thermometer
银行家们曾承诺，只有当车流量达到每天6000辆时，他们才会购买更多的债券。在收费的第一天，有超过9000辆车通过。他们想，好吧，这是一座新桥。人们对开车过桥感到兴奋。情况不会一直这样的。但车流量还在不断攀升。他们在办公室里有一个
in the office measuring the daily traffic totals. And it's pretty soon the numbers are rising above the top of the thermometer chart. They've broken the daily traffic totals. And it's pretty soon the numbers are rising above the top of the thermometer chart. They've broken the thermometer and bankers are rushing to buy bonds. The second deck gets added to the bridge. Moses finally puts up that statue of Henry Hudson that's been meant to go on that pillar since 1909.
呈温度计形状的图表，用来测量每日车流量。很快，数字就超过了温度计图表的顶端。他们打破了每日车流量的记录。很快，数字就超过了温度计图表的顶端。他们打破了温度计的记录，银行家们争先恐后地购买债券。桥梁的第二层被加建了。摩西终于竖起了那座自1909年以来就准备放在那个柱子上的亨利·哈德森雕像。
He builds a park there for small children. Of course, he puts steps in the park so he can't bring baby carriages in. It takes 20 years of lobbying to get the steps removed. And this is the point where if you're reading the physical copy of the book, there's this section here of black and white photos of Moses Bridges that interrupts this chapter.
他在那里为小孩子建了一个公园。当然，他在公园里建了台阶，这样婴儿车就推不进去了。花了20年时间的游说才把台阶拆除。这时候，如果你在读纸质书，这里会有一段关于摩西桥梁的黑白照片，打断了这一章。
And the one, I feel like one of the weaknesses of the book or the few weaknesses is the photo sections, which are kind of disorganized and the photos are not amazing. But there's this one picture on here that maybe we'll come back to in the future about the proposed Midtown Expressway Which is an expressway that's going through the buildings in Midtown, Manhattan. Yeah, it looks so futuristic
我觉得这本书的缺点之一或少数缺点之一就是照片部分，它们有点杂乱无章，照片也不是很惊艳。但这里有一张照片，也许我们以后会回过头来讨论，关于拟建的中城高速公路，这是一条穿过中城曼哈顿建筑群的高速公路。是的，它看起来太具未来感了
It's one of those things we look at it You're like that looks cool, and then you think about it for two minutes, and you're like that would be terrible but uh by 1938 Moses has hooked up all his parkways the second deck is on that bridge We heard about how beautiful that Parkway drive is when you're driving in. It's just you speeding along, just getting, getting right into the city from the forest. Traffic is a thing of the past, right?
这是那种我们看着会觉得，看起来很酷，然后你想了两分钟，就会觉得那太糟糕了的东西。但是，到1938年，摩西已经将他所有的公园路连接起来了，桥上加了第二层。我们听说开车进来时那条公园路的风景有多美。那就像是你一路飞驰，从森林直接驶入城市。交通已经是过去式了，对吧？
Roman is traffic a thing of the past? No, sir. Because the central axiom to urban planning is however many lanes you build, how many bridges you build, cars will fill it. I don't know, let's find out. Let's just take a look at the book and see what happens. Oh no, oh no, oh, it's all backed up. And the old bridges and roads, they're also backed up.
罗曼，交通真的是过去式了吗？不，先生。因为城市规划的核心公理是，无论你修建多少条车道，无论你修建多少座桥梁，汽车都会把它填满。我不知道，让我们拭目以待。让我们来看看书里是怎么写的，看看会发生什么。哦不，哦不，哦，全部堵车了。旧的桥梁和道路也都堵车了。
All backed up the same. It talks about a reporter decides, he's like, I'm gonna drive that trip from the city line to Canal Street back and see if it takes 26 minutes. This is a nine mile trip. One way it took him 58 minutes, another way 73 minutes. And it's bumper to bumper traffic along the water.
全都堵得水泄不通。书中提到有个记者决定亲自验证一下，他想开车从市界开到运河街，看看是不是真的只要26分钟。这段路程有九英里。单程花了他58分钟，另一个单程则花了73分钟。沿河一带全都是紧紧相贴的拥堵车辆。
So you're not looking at the water, you're looking at the bumper of the car in front of you because you've got to keep moving. And it seems, Carro says, Moses had two objectives, reclaim the waterfront for New Yorkers and ease traffic. One of those things did poorly. And the other thing it just did not do. On opening day for the West side improvement, Bill Exton, he goes to Inwood Hill, the park that now is a road running through it,
所以你根本看不到水景，你只能盯着前面那辆车的车尾，因为你得不停地往前开。卡罗说，摩西当时有两个目标：为纽约市民夺回水岸以及缓解交通。其中一项目标完成得很糟，而另一项目标根本就没做到。在西区改善工程开通当天，比尔·埃克斯顿去了因伍德山，那个现在有一条公路穿过其中的公园，
and he finds the peacefulness is all gone and Weinberg's predictions about Sputeneuvel and Riverdale, they came true. They're becoming haphazardly developed suburbs. The city didn't really plan for them to absorb all this traffic coming through it. That last freshwater marsh in New York, it's gone. And Carroll says these things are also part of the cost, the West side improvement, beyond that maybe $200 million that were spent on it. This was the cost and it was barely considered before it was built. But no one's thinking about it at the time. Moses, he's still being celebrated for his work. People love him. Look, children get new playgrounds. Of course,
他发现那里的宁静已经荡然无存，温伯格关于斯普滕迪弗和里弗代尔的预测也应验了。它们正在变成杂乱无章开发的郊区。这座城市并没有真正规划好如何去承受涌入的大量交通。纽约最后一块淡水沼泽地也消失了。卡罗说，这些代价同样也是西区改善工程的一部分，还不止是花在上面的那大约2亿美元。这就是代价，而且在动工之前几乎根本没有被考虑过。但在当时，没有人去想这些。摩西仍然因为他的工作而备受赞誉。人们爱戴他。你看，孩子们有了新的游乐场，当然，
they're going to love him. The old guard of the good government goo goo groups, they still love him. Mrs. Salzberger is like, the park association wants to give you our award for the year. And he's like, uh, I'm really busy. So you can come to my office and give it to me. And all these big business groups want to celebrate him. There's a movement to name the West Side Highway, the Robert Moses Highway, but it fails because New York politicians are worried
他们会爱戴他的。那些优秀的政府改革派老派人士依然爱戴他。索尔兹伯格夫人代表公园协会对他说，我们想把年度大奖颁给你。而他的反应是，呃，我很忙，所以你可以来我的办公室把奖颁给我。所有这些大型商业集团都想为他庆祝。当时甚至有一个运动想把西区高速公路命名为罗伯特·摩西高速公路，但最终失败了，因为纽约的政客们担心
that people are going to call it the Moses Highway, which would sound too Jewish, which if you can't even have a Jewish highway in New York, it's not going to happen anywhere. I'm sorry, you know? And so many groups want to honor him. At one point, there's a black tie dinner in his honor that's sponsored by 16 different groups, and the media is doing the thing of taking his faults and spinning them as strengths. And Caro says, his vituperation and personal attacks on anyone who dared to oppose him were outspokenness, his refusal to obey the rules and regulations of the WPA or laws he had sworn to uphold was independence and refusal to let the public interest be hampered by red tape and bureaucrats.
人们会把它叫作摩西高速公路，这听起来太犹太化了——如果在纽约连一条犹太人的高速公路都不能有，那在其他地方就更不可能实现了。我很抱歉，你知道的吧？有这么多的团体想要向他致敬。有一回，举办了一场为他举行的黑领结晚宴，由16个不同的团体共同赞助，而媒体则把他的缺点粉饰并包装成优点。卡罗说，他对于任何敢于反对他的人的谩骂和人身攻击，被说成是直言不讳；他拒绝遵守WPA的规章制度或他发誓要维护的法律，被说成是独立自主、拒绝让公共利益受到繁文缛节和官僚主义的阻碍。
And the columnist Westbrook Pegler, he makes a joke that Moses, when he starts projects, it's the oops, sorry technique, that he just starts a project without authorization and goes, oops, sorry. And everyone's kind of like laughing it off. That's Moses, that's what he does. And national magazines have started picking up the story of this amazing guy in New York
专栏作家韦斯特布鲁克·佩格勒还开玩笑说，摩西在启动项目时用的是“哎呀，对不起”的战术，也就是他未经授权就直接开工，然后来一句“哎呀，对不起”。大家基本上都把这当成笑话一笑了之。这就是摩西，他就是这样的人。全国性的杂志也开始报道纽约这位了不起的人物的故事
who's getting things done. And Harper's does this story talking about how great it is that Moses doesn't let the law or personal property rights get in the way of building his stuff. And Fortune magazine, this is my favorite of the quotes that Kara has, Fortune magazine says, thus, not only like a boy scout is Bob Moses always prepared, like Galahad, his strength is as the strength of 10 because his heart is pure. Which even if Robert Moses was like a truly noble parks builder, that's a bonkers way to describe him.
谁能真正把事情办成。而《哈泼斯杂志》则发表了一篇报道，大加赞赏摩西不让法律或私有财产权阻碍他搞建设。还有《财富》杂志——这是卡罗引用的我最喜欢的一段话，《财富》杂志说，因此，鲍勃·摩西不仅像个童子军一样时刻准备着，而且就像加拉哈德一样，他的力量有十个人的力量那么强大，因为他的心地纯洁。这话说得，就算罗伯特·摩西真的是个品格高尚的公园建设者，这也是一种极其荒谬的形容方式。
And his national reputation sort of grows and grows and more and more people go to New York to study with Moses to try to figure out how to build things, how to, you know, like ignore people, you know, like It's really something. And if you're a dissenting voice, then you are ignored or in one case, literally drowned out by singing at a Moses event. Someone is like, hey, maybe you shouldn't have done this thing and people just sing really loudly
他的全国声望可以说是与日俱增，越来越多的人前往纽约向摩西学习，试图弄清楚如何搞建设，如何，你知道的，比如无视他人，你知道的，这真的很有一套。而如果你是一个持不同政见者的声音，那么你就会被无视，或者在某一个案例中，在摩西的一次活动上，直接被歌声给盖过去了。有人觉得，嘿，也许你不该搞这出，然后人们就开始大声唱歌
to drown them out. And this is when he starts being called the master builder or the master planner. He is no longer just the man with the parks. He's no longer just the guy, man who can get things done. He is the master builder or the master planner. You know, he is no longer just the man with the parks, you know, he's no longer just the guy who man who can get things done. He is the master of it all. The mass, the someone who is unquestioned, like the authority and Robert Moses, he still visits Al Smith.
来把他们的声音盖过去。也就是在这个时候，他开始被称为建筑大师或规划大师。他不再只是那个拥有公园的人。他不再只是那个能把事情办成的家伙。他是建筑大师或规划大师。你知道的，他不再只是那个拥有公园的人，你知道的，他不再只是那个能把事情办成的家伙。他是这一切的主宰。主宰，一个不容置疑的人，就像权威一样，而罗伯特·摩西，他依然去拜访艾尔·史密斯。
This Rokaro takes us a moment to, to look in at Al Smith, Al Smith, who is now 56 years old, not yet an old man, but he has been sidelined from politics. He blames Roosevelt. He's become bitter. He's become obsessed with his hatred of Roosevelt. He's starting to fall in with right-wingers because they also hate the New Deal and hate Roosevelt. Mrs. Moskowitz, who might've been a tempering influence on him, has died. His other cronies, they don't see him much anymore because he's not powerful. He's still beloved and popular. And Robert Carrow talks about him getting on the bus and people on the bus will applaud him as soon as he walks on. I'm sure people are still singing East Side, West Side to him.
罗伯特·卡罗带我们花点时间来看看艾尔·史密斯，如今56岁的艾尔·史密斯，虽说不上是个老头，但他已经被边缘化出了政坛。他把这一切归咎于罗斯福。他变得愤世嫉俗。他开始对罗斯福满怀怨恨，到了痴迷的地步。他开始同右翼分子混在一起，因为他们同样痛恨新政，痛恨罗斯福。曾经或许能对他起到缓和作用的莫斯科维茨夫人已经去世了。他过去的那些亲信，也不怎么来看他了，因为他已经大权旁落。他依然备受爱戴，人气很高。罗伯特·卡罗提到他上公交车时，车上的人只要他一上车就会为他鼓掌。我敢肯定，大家依然在冲他唱着《东区，西区》。
I'm sorry, people are still singing the sidewalks of New York to him. It's not called East Side, West Side. And people are still singing a song to him all the time, but he's not a political force. He is not even an elder statesman. He is just kind of like a relic. And he tells Bob Moses, public support is a slender read to lean on, but Moses seems sure that he's never going to lose it. He's always going to have that public support. Yeah.
抱歉，人们依然在冲他唱着《纽约的人行道》。不叫《东区，西区》。人们依然一直在为他唱着一首歌，但他已经不再是一股政治力量。他甚至算不上什么资深政治家。他简直就像是个历史遗迹。他告诉鲍勃·摩西，公众的支持是一根靠不住的芦苇，但摩西似乎确信自己永远不会失去这种支持。他将永远拥有这种公众支持。是的。
Roman, you've made that sound as if, as if at some point the public may turn on Robert Moses, but I don't think so. I mean, this is the end of the book, right? What I am struck by in this section is what a good heart Al Smith has through most of his life. I'm sure he had, um, horrible blind spots and did bad things, but mostly is a champion of, uh, the, you know, the people he cares about the champion of the city. And this obsession, you know, this bitterness and this pettiness towards Roosevelt, being ignored by Roosevelt, really just undoes him. And in this way that is just, you know, it's kind of heartbreaking. It's just so, but it's also just sort of like, you know, he has complete control over this. Like he could just, you know,
罗曼，你刚才那番话听起来，就像是在暗示公众在某个时刻可能会背弃罗伯特·摩西，但我可不这么认为。我的意思是，这是书的结尾了，对吧？这一部分最让我触动的是，艾尔·史密斯在人生的绝大部分时间里有着多么善良的心地。我确信他，嗯，有着可怕的盲区，也做过坏事，但总体而言，他一直是，呃，他所关心的人民的拥护者，这座城市的拥护者。而这种执念，你知道的，这种对罗斯福的怨恨和小家子气，因为被罗斯福无视，真正毁了他。而且这种方式，你知道的，简直让人心碎。它就是如此，但这也让人觉得，你知道的，他对这一切有着完全的掌控。比如他完全可以，你知道的，
let that go and move on and do different things, but he cannot. And it really, it just diminishes him. It's just like a poison that he just drinks on his own accord. He like mixes it up and drinks it, just this hatred. And it just makes him less and less of a person and less and less of a person worth being revered.
放下这一切，继续前行，去做别的事，但他就是做不到。这真的，这只会贬低他自己。这就像是一种他自愿饮下的毒药。他自己把它调配好然后喝下去，满腔的只有这种仇恨。这只会让他在人格上变得越来越渺小，越来越不配受到人们的崇敬。
But Bob Moses still likes the old, sees the old Al Smith, but there's just something about him that's broken here that I find just truly heartbreaking and mostly heartbreaking because it's a completely self-inflicted wound. It feels very sad and there are two thoughts that I have about it and one is that this is a premonition and I think Caro is setting it up this way of Bob Moses in the future. Robert Moses also will someday be a bitter old man who has not lauded the way that he
但鲍勃·摩西仍然喜欢那个老去的、还能看到昔日影子的艾尔·史密斯，只是他身上有些东西在这里已经破碎了，这让我觉得简直令人心碎，而且最让人心碎的是，这完全是一个自作自受的伤口。这感觉非常悲伤，对此我有两个想法。第一个想法是，这是一个预兆，我认为卡罗在为未来的鲍勃·摩西做铺垫。罗伯特·摩西有朝一日也会成为一个满腹怨恨的老头，他不会像他
thinks, has not listened to the way that he thinks, does not listen to the way that he thinks. And maybe that's just the lot of anyone who goes for power. You can't that eventually you lose that power either by having it taken from you or having it just, just aging out of it, retiring or something. And you hear so many stories of elder statesmen who yearn for the days when they were important, you know, it's not enough to be respected. It's not enough to be loved. They have to be important and they have to have that power. And Moses saw Al Smith at his height
想象的那样受到赞誉，不会像他想象的那样被人倾听，不会像他想象的那样倾听别人的声音。也许这就是所有追求权力的人的宿命吧。你无法，最终你会失去那种权力，要么是被剥夺，要么就是随着年龄的增长而自然退化，退休或者怎样。你听过太多资深政治家渴望他们当年风光无限的日子的故事，你知道的，仅仅被人尊重是远远不够的。仅仅被人爱戴是远远不够的。他们必须手握大权，必须拥有那种权力。摩西见证了艾尔·史密斯处于权力巅峰时的风采，
and Al Smith has fallen from that height. And Moses is like, yeah, but that's not gonna happen to me. Like I'm gonna be, it's, you know, it's, fame. I'm gonna live forever. You know, I'm gonna learn how to fly. This is, I don't have to worry about this ever happening to me, but it happens.
而艾尔·史密斯已经从那个巅峰跌落。摩西的态度是：是的，但那种事不会发生在我身上。我将会是，你知道的，名垂青史。我会永远活下去。你知道的，我要学会飞翔。这就是，我根本不用担心这种事会发生在我身上，但它确实发生了。
And it's as inevitable a part of life as dying, you know? And it feels to me like Al Smith very much there is like, this this is an early death for me and it's an, it's a, an admission that my life will end. And my other thought is, so why doesn't he like run for office? Like, I don't know what it's a, it's a weird thing. And I wonder if it's the machine politics of the day, maybe, or he feels like he can't get the support, but like, I feel like if Al Smith ran for, I mean, he's not going to run for governor again. That would be a slap in the face of the mayor.
这就如同死亡一样，是生活中不可避免的一部分，对吧？在我看来，艾尔·史密斯的这种状态非常像是在说：对我而言，这是一次提前的死亡，也是一种承认，承认我的生命终将结束。而我的另一个想法是，他为什么不去竞选公职呢？比如，我不知道，这真是一件奇怪的事情。我在想，这也许是因为当时的机器政治，或者他觉得自己无法获得支持？但我觉得，如果艾尔·史密斯去竞选——我是说，他不会再去竞选州长了。那等于是在打市长的脸。
For mayor, which is something LaGuardia is deeply afraid of in the beginning of his- He's always worried about. Yeah. Or he could run for Congress. Like I think about John Quincy Adams, who was president, lost reelection and then went into Congress for years and years.
去竞选市长。这也是拉瓜迪亚在早期深感恐惧的事——他一直都在担心这个。是的。或者他可以去竞选国会议员。就像我想起约翰·昆西·亚当斯，他曾担任总统，竞选连任失败后，依然去国会当了多年议员。
Was a Congressman for a long time after that. There's this idea that maybe that also that once you've had kind of ultimate executive power, that's the only thing that will satisfy you too. That we don't know. And I have a biography of Al Smith that's been sitting on my to be red shelf for a long time. And I should have read it before we did this podcast, but I didn't get around to it. But I wonder if there was this feeling in him of like, well, I had it. Why would I settle for anything less? I want it all. Because this is a man who thought he would be president,
在这之后做了很长时间的国会议员。有一种观点认为，也许同样是因为，一旦你品尝过那种终极的行政权力，那就成了唯一能让你感到满足的东西。对此我们并不知道。我书架上有一本关于艾尔·史密斯的传记，已经搁置了很久很久。我本来应该在做这个播客之前读完它的，但我一直没抽出时间。不过我在想，他心里是不是有这样一种感觉：既然我都已经拥有过最高权力了，为什么还要退而求其次呢？我要把一切都抓在手里。因为这是一个曾以为自己会当上总统的人，
ran for president and probably should have won if not for anti-Catholic bigotry. But it's a good question. It feels like he has, more than anyone else he has closed the door, but he's blamed that on Roosevelt. And maybe it's like, he knows he doesn't have it in him anymore,
他曾竞选过总统，如果不是因为反天主教的偏见，他本该赢得大选。但这确实是个好问题。感觉他比任何人都更彻底地为自己关上了大门，但他却把这归咎于罗斯福。也许是因为，他心里清楚自己已经没有当年的那个精力和手腕了，
but it's easier to blame Roosevelt than to blame himself. But it is very sad. It's a sad way for Al Smith to go. He suffers from the same thing that a lot of people who accomplish things suffer from, which is they're right for this section of time, that right and effective, and they have their finger on the pulse,
但把责任推给罗斯福，总比承认自己的失败要容易得多。但这确实非常悲伤。艾尔·史密斯以这种方式落幕，实在令人唏嘘。他犯了许多有所成就的人都会犯的同一种错误，那就是：他们在特定的时代是正确的、有效的，他们能够敏锐地把握时代的脉搏，
and they notice all problems for this little bit of time and all their worldview. It just coincides with having a great effect on the world. And that passes with time, no matter what. You cannot be that great and on top of things forever. And he just cannot turn it around. And he just is this kind of victim
他们在那个短暂的时期内注意到了所有的时代问题，他们所有的世界观，恰好与对世界产生巨大影响的契机不谋而合。然而，无论如何，这一切都会随着时间的推移而消逝。你不可能永远那么伟大，永远立于时代之巅。而他偏偏无法扭转这种局面。他最终成了
of the same political machine that brought him to that prominence and power. And he just becomes diminished in that. And I, anyway, I would be curious to know if you ever do read that book, Elliot. What- I'll get to it. Maybe I'll try to do it before the end of the,
当初将他推上显赫地位和权力巅峰的那个政治机器的某种受害者。他在其中变得越来越黯淡无光。不管怎样，艾利奥特，如果你真的去读了那本书，我会很想听听你的看法。什么——我会去读的。也许我会试着在结束，
actually, maybe I'll read it next. When I finish this book of short science fiction, short stories that's unrelated to what we're working on right now. But I would love to know from another perspective what his biographers say about the end of his life in that regard. Stay tuned listeners, will I get to reading that biography before we finish the podcast? We'll find out. So that's how that chapter ends and it's a pretty sad bitter end to the chapter.
事实上，也许我接下来就读它。等我读完这本与我们现在的工作毫无关系的科幻短篇小说集之后。但我很想从另一个角度了解，他的传记作家们在这方面是如何看待他生命终点的。听众朋友们请拭目以待，我究竟能不能在做完这个播客之前读完那本传记呢？到时候咱们就知道了。这一章就是这样结束的，对于这一章来说，这是一个相当悲伤且充满苦涩的结局。
Luckily, the next chapter is pretty happy, right? The next chapter is a pretty happy, joyful, sunshiny chapter. It's an amazing chapter of great gaiety and frivolity. And it is called Two Brothers. It's almost exact opposite of the chapter that we're talking about now. It's super fascinating. We'll talk about Two Brothers after this. So this next chapter, Chapter 26, Two Brothers,
幸运的是，下一章相当开心，对吧？下一章是一个相当快乐、喜庆、充满阳光的章节。这是一个充满了欢声笑语和轻浮乐趣的神奇章节。它叫做《两兄弟》。它几乎和我们现在讨论的这一章形成了鲜明的反差。它超级引人入胜。我们随后就来聊聊《两兄弟》。所以接下来的这一章，第二十六章《两兄弟》，
is just something else. And this chapter is one of the things I most want to talk to Robert Caro about because it's inclusion of the way, you know, kind of the different way Robert Moses uses power and to kind of hurt the people closest to him is such an authorial choice to include as opposed to all this other like, you know, like fighting with the board of estimates and, you to all this like, you know, like fighting with the board of estimates and, you know, grounding down, you know, different newspaper people and reformers
真的是别有一番看头。这一章是我最想和罗伯特·卡罗探讨的内容之一，因为其中包含的内容，你知道的，罗伯特·摩西运用权力的不同方式，以及他如何去伤害离他最近的人，作为一个作家，他偏偏选择把这些写进书里，而不是去写其他所有的那些，你知道的，比如跟估价委员会的扯皮，以及，你知道的，去写所有这些，你知道的，比如跟估价委员会的扯皮，以及，你知道的，把各种报人还有改革派
that he doesn't like is one thing. But the dastardly relationship with his brother is really something else. And I'm so intrigued by it. And so I don't know, let's start talking about this, this chapter. What's, what's, how does this open? So this chapter opens thusly, it begins like this, often at the rear of a cheering audience, there would be standing one figure who wasn't cheering who amid a room full of men and women gathered to honor Robert Moses stood watching Robert Moses with a face twisted with bitterness and hatred and contempt. He was Robert Moses's brother. And this is a, I'd like to continue to read more of that passage. The way this chapter opens, Paul Moses had a strange story to read more of that passage, the way this chap wrote one is, Paul Moses had a strange story to tell about this hero
那些他看不顺眼的人榨干压垮，那是一回事。但他和自己亲兄弟之间那种险恶的关系可就完全是另一码事了。这让我感到非常着迷。所以，不知怎么的，让我们开始讨论这一章吧。这一章是怎么开头的？这一章是这样开头的，它是这样开头的：经常在欢呼的人群后面，会站着一个没有欢呼的身影。在那个为了向罗伯特·摩西致敬而聚集了满屋子男男女女的房间里，他站在那里，注视着罗伯特·摩西，脸上带着因痛苦、仇恨和轻蔑而扭曲的表情。他是罗伯特·摩西的兄弟。这是一个，我想继续阅读那段话的更多内容。这一章的开头方式是，保罗·摩西有一个奇怪的故事——想再读一点那段话的更多内容，这一章的开篇是，保罗·摩西有一个奇怪的故事要讲，关于这位英雄，
who appeared particularly heroic because, so the legend went, he had absolutely no interest in money. Robert Moses, Paul Moses said, had cut him out of part of his inheritance. And Paul said his brother had done more to minimize the possibility of mutual acquaintances, finding out what he had done. He had used his influence to keep Paul away
这位英雄之所以显得格外英雄，是因为按照传说，他对金钱毫无兴趣。保罗·摩西说，罗伯特·摩西剥夺了他本该享有的一部分遗产。保罗还说，他的兄弟为了尽量减少他们共同的熟人发现他所作所为的可能性，可谓煞费苦心。他利用自己的影响力，尽可能不让保罗
from those acquaintances as much as possible by keeping him out of city posts for which he was eminently well qualified and to which he would have otherwise been appointed. And so this is a, like you said, this kind of book, this is a biography. It's not like a Kitty Kelly, you know, tell all biography where it's like, hmm, here, let's get into the closets
接触到那些熟人，手段就是阻挠保罗获得那些他完全胜任、且本该由他担任的城市公职。所以这是一个，就像你说的，这是一本传记。这不像基蒂·凯利那种八卦式的爆料传记，里面写着什么，哼，来吧，让我们走进壁橱，
and look at the skeletons and all the dirty laundry. This is a book that is working on these huge scale themes of how a city works, how democracy works, how power works. And it's almost like Robert Caro has taken you through this long chapter about how you fund a public work and the costs that are embedded in that both social and technological. And he's like, we've done a lot of that. It's time to get small and let's look at Robert Moses, the person in his family.
看看那些藏着的骷髅和所有的脏衣服。这是一本探讨宏大主题的书——城市如何运转，民主如何运转，权力如何运转。这就好比罗伯特·卡罗带你经历了漫长的一章，讲述了如何为一个公共工程筹措资金，以及其中隐含的社会与技术成本。然后他说：我们已经讲了足够多这方面的内容。现在是时候把视角缩小了，让我们来看看罗伯特·摩西作为个人的家庭生活。
I think that hasn't really been touched on too much previously in the book. But I think that he would tell you, is my guess, and I'd love to ask him about this too, he is looking at Robert Moses as a person as a whole. And this is another way that his use of power reveals something about him. Because this isn't just Robert Moses
我想这在本书的前面部分并没有真正被过多触及。但我想他会告诉你——这是我的猜测，我也很想就此向他提问——他是把罗伯特·摩西作为一个完整的人来看待的。这也是他运用权力的方式如何揭示其性格的另一个例证。因为这不仅仅是罗伯特·摩西
getting at his brother and we're gonna, you know, revel in the dirty laundry, like I said. This is Robert Moses using power, not just against the faceless thousands or millions that he doesn't know personally. This is him using power against someone who in theory is closer to him than anyone else, to his brother, who he's known obviously his whole life. It's his slightly older brother. power against someone who in theory is closer to him than anyone else, to his brother, who
在算计他的兄弟，我们也不是要（正如我所说）去沉湎于那些豪门丑闻。这是罗伯特·摩西在运用权力，对象不仅仅是那些他并不面熟的、成千上万的无名百姓。这是他在对一个理论上比任何人都更亲近的人——他的兄弟，一个他显然认识了一辈子的亲兄弟——滥用权力。这是他稍长几岁的哥哥。权力，而对象在理论上是比任何人都更亲近的人，也就是他的兄弟，
he's known obviously his whole life. It's his slightly older brother. And this is an amazing magic trick to me how that last chapter was so huge and now it's like we're going to zoom way in and we're going to look at his personal history, something that we haven't done before. We're going to talk about a new character, someone we have never have not mentioned in the book up to this point, his brother, Paul Moses. So there's something like, if a TV show did this,
他显然认识了一辈子的亲兄弟。这是他大一岁左右的哥哥。对我来说，这真是一个惊人的魔术：上一章的视野还如此宏大，而现在就像是将镜头骤然拉近，去审视他的个人历史，这是我们以前从未做过的事情。我们要谈论一个新角色，一个在本书前半部分从未被提及的人——他的兄弟保罗·摩西。所以这种感觉就像是，如果电视剧这么拍，
it would be startling to suddenly have this new character and be like, oh yeah, I'm his brother. And you'd be like, I didn't know he had a brother. What's his story? What's going on? Like he's just masterful at this kind of storytelling. And there's a little bit at the end we'll get to about Moses' wife too.
突然冒出这么一个新角色，然后说，“哦，对了，这是他兄弟，”你会觉得非常突兀，心想：“我以前都不知道他还有个兄弟。他的故事是什么？这到底是怎么回事？”他在这类叙事技巧上的确运用得出神入化。而在本章结尾处，还有一点关于摩西妻子的内容，我们稍后也会讲到。
And I feel like Caro touches on that briefly and that feels kind of like old world gentility to me that that is not what the chapter is about. But it's also who he had access to, because as we'll see, Robert Karo had access to a little bit at least to Paul Moses, to Moses' brother, and he really makes use of it. Yeah, and that's a point I wanna get to of this chapter
我觉得卡罗对这一点也只是简短地触及了一下，这让我觉得带有一种旧世界的贵族风范，因为那一章的核心并不是在讲这个。但这同时也取决于他能够接触到什么人，因为正如我们所见，罗伯特·卡罗至少在一定程度上接触到了保罗·摩西，接触到了摩西的兄弟，并且他真的充分利用了这一点。是的，这也是我想谈谈这一章的一个地方，
that I found really intriguing. So these two chapters, these two chapters side by side that we've grouped together artificially in our episode making, planning and stuff like this. But I like to juxtapose them because I'm really fascinated by them is that, there's this whole section that $109 million section that I
我觉得非常引人入胜。所以这两章，我们为了制作节目、策划以及诸如此类的事情而人工将它们归纳在一起的这两章，可以说是紧密相连的。但我喜欢把它们并置在一起，因为我对它们深感着迷。那就是，这里有整整一段——上一章中那笔高达1.09亿美元的资金部分，
love in the previous chapter that represents so much work. I mean, just understanding that weird tax strategy loan thing to get the money to the railroad legally and then pull that money back out to fund his project. That must have represented so much work of just spade work of just documents and talking to people and just understanding it. And Carol gives no mention of how much work that really was,
我太喜欢了，它代表了那么大量的工作。我的意思是，仅仅是去理解那种奇怪的税收策略贷款手段，以便合法地将资金调拨给铁路，然后又把资金抽回来资助他的项目。那背后一定代表着海量的工作，全都是那些枯燥的案头工作、查阅文件、与人交谈以及单纯地去理解这一切。而卡罗根本没有提及这背后到底付出了多少汗水，
even though I know that represents a ton of work. But he spends a lot of time in the beginning of this chapter talking about how hard it was to get Paul Moses to talk to him. Yes. And I was trying to think about why. And I think it's because he's not trying to show off how hard it was and how he got him eventually.
尽管我心知肚明那代表着排山倒海的工作量。然而，他在这一章的开头却花了大量时间来讲述让保罗·摩西开口说话是多么的艰难。是的。我当时一直在琢磨原因何在。我想这是因为他并不是在显摆自己有多不容易、最终又是怎么搞定对方的。
He's trying to show, you know, in support of this story that Paul Moses just did not wanna talk to him. Paul Moses was not someone who wanted to speak ill of Robert Moses, to anyone who would listen, and especially Robert Caro. He's setting the struggle up to talk to Paul Moses, not as like, look at this amazing thing I finally got to do as a reporter. He's setting up as like, you should maybe trust what Paul Moses is saying here, because he's just not out there like on every street corner
他试图向读者证明——为了支撑保罗·摩西根本不想接受他采访的这个事实。保罗·摩西并不是那种愿意向任何愿意倾听的人、尤其是向罗伯特·卡罗说罗伯特·摩西坏话的人。他把争取采访保罗·摩西的过程设定为：这可不是作为一个记者我终于做成了一件多么了不起的事情。他把它塑造成：你或许应该相信保罗·摩西在这里所说的话，因为他可不是那种在每个街头巷尾
talking about how bad Robert Moses is. I think it's a little bit of that. And it's also, I think the other things that Caro's been talking about in that last chapter, there's that if he says it, it means there's documentation that backs it up. There's, you can look at the paperwork. And here it's like, I think he wants to make it clear.
到处宣扬罗伯特·摩西有多坏的人。我觉得有那么一点这方面的意思。同时我也认为，卡罗在上一章中讨论过的其他事情也是原因之一：如果他把话说出口，那就意味着有案牍记载在支撑着这个说法。你可以去查阅纸面文件。而在这里，我觉得他是想向大家澄清：
I got this from Paul Moses. Here's how I tracked him down. Like, and here's how I got to him. So if this, anything in this isn't true, it's because Paul Moses is confused. And so there's a little bit of him, I think, trying to both back it up and also distance himself from the claims.
我是从保罗·摩西那里得到这些的。我是这样追踪到他的。以及我是如何找到他的。所以如果这里面的任何内容不是真的，那也只能是因为保罗·摩西自己记混了。因此，我认为他在某种程度上既是在试图为这些材料提供背书，同时也是在刻意拉开自己与这些指控之间的距离。
And explains. Well, just explain it that the provenance of the material is not the same as his normal level of rigor. It really is single sourced in a lot of ways. Well, and he says in it, he says the truth of Paul Moses' charge about the inheritance will never be determined. And I remember I've heard Carol talk about how
并加以解释。嗯，也就是解释说，这些材料的来源并不具备他平时那种严谨的程度。在很多方面，它确实只有一个消息源。嗯，他在书中也说过了，他明确表示保罗·摩西关于遗产的那项指控的真相将永远无法确定。我记得我曾听卡罗谈起过，
when he was writing about Lyndon Johnson, they would say, no one will ever know whether Lyndon Johnson stole this election. And he was like, I'm never gonna write. No one will ever know. I'm gonna find out election. And he was like, I'm never going to write. No one will ever know. I'm going to find out the answer to that. But here he has to write. I'll never know this, the truth, this, because by the time he's writing this,
当他在撰写关于林登·约翰逊的书时，别人会说：“永远不会有人知道林登·约翰逊到底有没有偷走这场选举。”而他的反应则是：“我绝不会写‘永远不会有人知道’。我一定要查个水落石出。”选举。而他的态度是：我绝不写“没有人会知道”。我一定要找到这个问题的答案。但在这里，他不得不写下：我将永远无法知晓事情的真相，因为当他写到这里时，
Paul Moses is dead. Robert Moses refuses to talk about it. Everyone else who was involved in it is also dead. And so I think he's, this is the first chapter and maybe the only chapter where I can remember where Caro is entering kind of like almost true crime ish territory where it's like I'm gonna tell you some things This is what I've come to believe but we'll never know this stuff for sure and everywhere else He's he's certain about what he's saying He's he is not playing that game and he says at the end there's something he says
保罗·摩西已经去世了。罗伯特·摩西拒绝谈论此事。所有其他牵涉其中、参与过此事的人也都已经过世了。所以我想，这是我能想起来的卡罗首度——也许也是唯一一次——涉足某种类似真实罪案（True Crime）领域的章节，那种感觉就像是：我要告诉你一些事情，这是我所倾向相信的，但我们永远无法百分之百地确定这些事。而在其他所有章节中，他对自己的言论都是笃定的，他绝不玩这种模棱两可的游戏。而且他在结尾处提到过一件事，他说：
Paul could have dispelled those shadows for months the author asked him to do so he refused saying it was no one's business But his own finally And it's like, like also the pain of that for Caro too, of like, oh, I had it. Like I almost had it. His, because as we'll see with Paul's story, there are parts of Paul's life that are a mystery to me, but I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me. And I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me, too. But I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me, too. And I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me, too. And I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me, too.
保罗本可以驱散那些阴霾，几个月来作者一直恳请他这样做，但他都拒绝了，声称那是他自己的私事，最终。这感觉就像是，卡罗对此也感到了阵痛，心想：“哦，我本来就差一点拿到了。”就像他几乎就拿到了，因为正如我们从保罗的故事中所看到的，保罗一生的某些部分对我来说是一个谜，但我认为这对我来说多少是个谜。而且我认为这也带有一点神秘感。但我也觉得这对我来说也是个谜。但我认为这也是对我来说的一点神秘感。但我认为这也带有一点神秘感。但我认为这也是对我来说的一点神秘感。
And I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me, too. And I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me, too. And I think it's a little bit of a mystery to me, too. And I think it's a little bit of the pain of that for Caro too, of like, oh, I had it. Like I almost had it his way, because as we'll see with Paul's story, there are parts of Paul's life that are a mystery. No one knows what was going on with him during that time. And, and we'll never know now. And that Caro was so close to having it, but there's also something of a, like, there's something kind of Victorian novel about it too, where it's that want, you
但我认为这也带有一点神秘感。但我认为这也带有一点神秘感。但我认为这也带有一点神秘感。而且我觉得这也是卡罗为此感到痛苦的一部分，心想：哦，我本来就要拿到了。就像我几乎用他的方式得到了它，因为正如我们将从保罗的故事中看到的，保罗生活中的某些部分是个谜。没有人知道他在那段时间里到底经历了什么，而且，我们现在永远也不会知道了。卡罗距离真相只有一步之遥，但这也带有一种，怎么说呢，这其中甚至有些维多利亚时代小说的色彩，也就是那种渴望，
want to learn more now that you know, that we'll never know that the truth of it, you know, now it's a mystery. So I want to hear about it. And you really couldn't create a fictional rivalry as rich as this one. I mean, these two men, Paul and Robert, are kind of, you know, refracted mirror images of each other. They're both considered very handsome, very charming, kind of know-it-alls. You know, they're very close in age. I kind of know-it-alls. You know, they're very close in age.
既然你已经知道了，就会想要了解更多，但我们又永远无法知晓真相，现在它成了一个谜。所以我真的很想听听关于它的故事。你确实无法虚构出一段比这更丰富的对立关系了。我的意思是，保罗和罗伯特这两个人，有点像是，你知道的，彼此折射的镜像。他们两个都被认为长相极其英俊、魅力非凡、有点像是百事通。你知道的，他们年龄相仿。有点像是百事通。你知道的，他们年龄很接近。
I think Paul is only about a year older. Yeah, he's only a year older and they have so much of the same personality about them. Like you said, they're both really smart. They're both really charming. They both feel their superiority to other people. They feel that not necessarily the need, both feel the need to show it,
我想保罗只比他大了一岁左右。是的，他只大了一岁，而且他们的性格中有太多相似之处。正如你所说，他们两个都极其聪明。都极具魅力。他们都觉得自己比其他人更优越。他们觉得，倒不一定是非要——两个人都有强烈的表现欲，
but they both feel the assumption that they are superior to other people. And Caro, he points out that they had two differences, one small and one big. The small difference is Robert Moses did not care about lower class people or people of color, whereas Paul Moses seemed to be genuinely sympathetic towards them and even seemed to express warmth
但他们内心深处都理所当然地认为自己高人一等。而卡罗也指出，他们之间有两处不同，一大一小。小的那处区别在于：罗伯特·摩西根本不在乎底层民众或有色人种，而保罗·摩西似乎对他们抱有真正的同情，甚至似乎对穷人表现出一种他在对待较为富裕的人时绝不会展露的温暖。
towards poor people that he would not show towards more affluent people. But the biggest difference and Robert Carroll was like, this is the turning point for them, is that Robert Moses, the guy who stands up to power and everything, if his mother said something, he'd be like, yes, mom. Whereas Paul Moses would not. So if they're disagreeing with Bella Moses, eventually Bob would be like, yeah, okay, I guess you're right, mom, and just pretend. And Paul Moses would be like, no, you're wrong, mom. Which means that the person who is the real secret weapon for Robert Moses, in that she is bankrolling him for much of his adult life before he can amass that power, is on his side because he will follow her lead. Whereas Paul Moses, the slightly older brother,
但最大的不同——罗伯特·卡罗指出，这是他们人生的分水岭——在于：罗伯特·摩西这个敢于对抗权贵、天不怕地不怕的家伙，只要他母亲发话了，他就会乖乖听命：“是的，妈妈。”而保罗·摩西则绝不。所以，如果他们与贝拉·摩西产生意见分歧，最终鲍勃会说：“好吧，好吧，我想你是对的，妈妈，”然后假装顺从。而保罗·摩西则会说：“不，妈妈，你错了。”这意味着，那个作为罗伯特·摩西背后真正秘密武器的人——在他在聚敛起权力之前的整个成年早期一直为他提供资金支持的母亲——之所以站在他这一边，是因为他会听从她的领导。而作为稍长一些的哥哥的保罗·摩西，
he will not follow her lead. And we talk about Paul Moses' youth here, and there's these kind of blank spots. He seems to have had some kind of falling out with their mom. It was either over politics, he was a Democrat and she was Republican, or if it was over a girl that he was in love with. But either way, the upshot is that he drops out of Princeton,
他才不肯听从母亲的领导。接着我们谈到了保罗·摩西的青年时期，这里面存在着一些空白期。他和母亲之间似乎闹过某种矛盾。原因要么是政治立场（他是民主党人，而母亲是共和党人），要么是因为他爱上了一个女孩。但无论如何，结果就是他从普林斯顿大学退学了，
and for four years, he's just gone, and nobody knows where he is. Nobody knows what he's doing. And then he returns to college and instead of majoring in Classics, now he's majoring in electrical engineering. And this is one of those dark spots in his life that Carol wanted to know about and is never going to know about. In 1913, both Bob and Paul want to go into public service. Bella, we know, arranges for Bob to go to the Bureau of Municipal Research. This is the first big step in his eventually becoming the power broker.
销声匿迹了整整四年，没有人知道他在哪里。没有人知道他在做什么。后来他重返大学，不过主修专业不再是古典文学，而是改成了电气工程。这是他人生中卡罗想要探究却永远无法得知的黑暗角落之一。1913年，鲍勃和保罗都想投身公共服务。我们知道，贝拉安排鲍勃去了市政研究局。这是他最终成为政治大佬迈出的第一步。
Paul is told, we've arranged a job for you at an investment bank. And Paul is like, I don't want to do that. That sucks. And he leaves, nobody knows where he goes. Some other family members, they tell Carol, yeah, I think he might've been in South America for a little bit.
保罗则被告知：“我们已经为你安排了一份投资银行的工作。”保罗的反应是：“我才不想干那个。这工作太烂了。”然后他便一走了之，没有人知道他去了哪里。其他一些家庭成员告诉卡罗：“是的，我觉得他可能在南美洲待过一段时间。”
Nobody knows what he does. And the trail doesn't pick up again until Paul is serving in the Navy during World War I. And Carol mentions during World War I, Robert Moses is staying out of the military. He doesn't want to do it. Whereas Paul enlists and serves. And while Bob is kind of starting to compromise his anti-machine politics so he can learn from Bill Moskowitz at this point, if you remember back that far in the series, while he's doing that, Paul Moses is working at Con Ed and is wrecking a very promising career by arguing politics with his bosses.
没有人知道他在做什么。直到第一次世界大战期间保罗在海军服役，这条线索才重新接上。卡罗提到，在一战期间，罗伯特·摩西选择置身军队之外。他不想去参军。而保罗则应征入伍并服了兵役。正当鲍勃开始妥协自己反政治机器的立场，以便在这个时候向比尔·莫斯科维茨学习——如果你还记得剧集里那么久远的剧情的话——正当他在这么做的时候，保罗·摩西正在爱迪生联合公司工作，并且因为和老板争论政治问题而毁掉了一个大有前途的职业生涯。
Like he will not compromise. He is, in some ways Paul Moses is the Bob Moses that Bob Moses is promised to be. Like he cares about people who blow him on the social scale. He is uncompromising and it just keeps causing him trouble. And finally he gets the chance to enter public service. He's offered a job at the Department of Public Works. At the last minute, Al Smith, who was governor at the time, vetoes the appointment. And Paul Most, I guess, tells Robert Caro that he
他就是不肯妥协。在某种程度上，保罗·摩西才是那个本该成为的“鲍勃·摩西”。他关心社会阶层中处于底层的人。他绝不妥协，而这也不断给他惹来麻烦。最终，他得到了一个进入公共服务领域的机会。有人向他提供了一份在公共工程部的工作。但在最后一刻，时任州长的艾尔·史密斯否决了这项任命。保罗·莫斯，我想他是这么告诉罗伯特·卡罗的：他当时并没有怀疑
didn't suspect at the time that his brother might have been behind that. Because at the time it wouldn't have occurred to him that his brother would be getting in the way of him ascending into that world. This is so sinister. This is also really upsetting. And then one of the other things that they have in common, curiously, is this love of swimming, like this obsession with swimming.
自己的兄弟可能在背后搞鬼。因为在当时，他根本不会想到自己的兄弟会阻碍他跻身那个世界。这太阴险了。这也让人感到非常沮丧。奇怪的是，他们两兄弟的另一个共同点是对游泳的热爱，简直到了对游泳痴迷的程度。
And so while Bob Moses is building Jones Beach, Paul is building this enormous swimming club in Pennsylvania, which is, again, what an obsession. I don't understand it. I could understand it if this was like the Luganus family, you know, like, you know, they had a history of a family swimming, but, or diving, you know, I just, but yeah, they just love swimming.
所以，当罗伯特·摩西在建造琼斯海滩时，保罗正在宾夕法尼亚州建造一个巨大的游泳俱乐部。这又是一个执念。我简直无法理解。如果这是像卢加纳斯家族那样，你知道的，有家族游泳或者跳水的历史，我还能理解，但，或者说，他们就是单纯地热爱游泳。
I don't know. And the difference here, Paul Moses, he's like an alternate reality version of Robert Moses in so many different ways, where Robert Moses can build Jones Beach and he can go way over cost because he has the power of the governor behind him. He can spend an entire bath houses budget on the foundation for the bath house and then say the legislature, give me more money. I got to finish
我不知道。而这里的区别在于，保罗·摩西在许多方面就像是罗伯特·摩西的平行宇宙版本：罗伯特·摩西可以建造琼斯海滩，并且因为有州长作为后盾而大大超支。他可以把整个浴室的预算全花在浴室的地基上，然后对立法机构说：“给我更多的钱。我得把
this bath house. But Paul, when he overspends on this swimming club, he has nowhere to turn. He won't ask his mother for financial help. Robert Moses, remember he asked his mom to float him like $22,000 to finish a project once and she did. And Paul Moses, he won't do it. So he's sinking further and further into debt. And by 1929, things are looking up. It's a great year for everybody, 1929. And Paul and his mom are starting to reconcile.
这个浴室建完。”但保罗在那个游泳俱乐部上过度消费时，却已经走投无路。他拉不下脸向母亲寻求经济上的援助。你还记得罗伯特·摩西曾向母亲要过大约22,000美元来完成一个项目，他妈妈确实给了他。而保罗·摩西则不肯这么做。于是他越陷越深，负债累累。到了1929年，情况似乎有了起色。对每个人来说1929年都是个好年份，保罗和母亲也开始冰释前嫌。
He gets a consulting job with Common Edison. The pool is starting to bring in money. And he has an argument with his brother. And Paul Moses tells Robert Caro that he didn't see it as any other different argument than before Robert Moses was a government guy. But suddenly in 1930, the next year, Paul and his mom, they have another falling out. And when he tries to make up with her, she refuses to see him. And suddenly other relatives are cutting him out. They won't talk to him. And this is the big mystery that I'm always drawn to in this chapter, is they all seem to think he has done something horrible. He's committed some kind of crime, and he is too proud to ask what they think he did. And he will never know. And later in the chapter,
他在通用爱迪生公司找到了一份咨询工作。那个游泳池也开始有收入了。结果他跟自己的兄弟吵了一架。保罗·摩西告诉罗伯特·卡罗，他当时觉得这不过是跟罗伯特·摩西以前还没当官时一样的普通争吵而已。然而突然之间，到了1930年，也就是第二年，保罗和母亲又闹翻了。当他试图跟母亲重修旧好时，母亲却拒绝见他。紧接着，其他亲戚也开始跟他疏远，不理睬他。这是这一章中最吸引我的巨大谜团：他们所有人似乎都觉得保罗做了什么可怕的事。他犯了某种罪行，而他又傲慢得不屑去问别人觉得自己到底做了什么。他将永远无从得知。在这一章的后面，
Robert Caro talks to relatives and they're like, yeah, I don't really remember. He did something bad. I don't remember what it was. Maybe Bob said he did something bad, but nobody can seem to remember what the sin is that Paul committed that basically got him ex-communicated from the family. No one knows. And when Bella Moses dies, she divides her estate up between Robert Moses and their sister Edna, who we've barely heard anything about. And she leaves a trust for Paul. It's a hundred thousand dollars. It's $100,000. He's only allowed to receive the interest, which is not very much money, never the principal.
罗伯特·卡罗去采访了亲戚们，他们的反应是：“哦，我记不太清了。他做过一件坏事。我不记得具体是什么了。也许是鲍勃说他做过坏事吧。”但似乎没有人能记清保罗究竟犯下了什么罪孽，导致他基本上被逐出了家族。没有人知道。而在贝拉·摩西去世时，她将自己的房产遗产分给了罗伯特·摩西和他们的妹妹埃德娜——我们对这个妹妹几乎一无所知。她为保罗设立了一笔信托基金。金额是100,000美元。价值10万美元。他只被允许领取利息，金额其实并不多，永远拿不到本金。
It says in the will that if he contests the will, it all goes to his siblings and he loses it automatically, which is a very Bob Moses move, I feel like. And worst of all, Robert Moses is named the trustee of the fund or one of the trustees. And so now that his mother is gone, Paul Moses has lost any financial security he ever felt like he had before. And even into his old age, he's wondering, why did my mom cut me out
遗嘱中写明，如果他敢对遗嘱提出异议，遗产将全部归他的兄弟姐妹所有，他的份额会被自动取消——我觉得这绝对是非常“鲍勃·摩西”式的作风。最糟糕的是，罗伯特·摩西被指定为该基金的受托人之一。于是，随着母亲的离世，保罗·摩西失去了他以往感受到的任何经济安全感。甚至到了晚年，他还在纳闷：为什么我妈要在遗嘱里把我应得的完整份额给剥夺了？他将，他永远也不会知道了。就像艾尔·史密斯对罗斯福满腹怨恨一样，保罗·摩西在某种程度上也开始相信罗伯特·摩西——他不说罗伯特·摩西，他管他叫鲍勃——保罗·摩西开始相信，我在笔记里从头到尾都写的是鲍勃，心想：我真不习惯叫他鲍勃。这太让人精神错乱了。保罗·摩西开始相信，他的兄弟鲍勃在其余家人面前说谎中伤他，以此败坏了他们的关系。保罗·摩西告诉罗伯特·卡罗，曾经有过一份早期的遗嘱，
of a full share of her will? Like he'll, he'll never know. And much like Al Smith, curdling with, with resentment towards Roosevelt in some ways, Paul Moses comes to believe Robert Moses, and he doesn't say Robert Moses, he would say Bob, that Paul Moses comes, in my notes I say Bob all throughout and I'm like, I'm not used to calling him Bob. This is very disorienting. Paul Moses comes to believe that his brother Bob lied about him to the rest of the family to poison his relationship. And Paul Moses tells Robert Carroll, there was an earlier will
把遗产平分成了三等份。后来当母亲住院时，鲍勃来找她，让她签署了一份新遗嘱，因为他想要我那份钱。并且他指控说，从那以后，他的兄弟还处处设法阻挠他寻找工作。而卡罗呢，他
that divided the estate into three equal parts. And then when my mom was in the hospital, Bob came and got her to sign a new will because he wanted my share of the money. And he alleges that then his brother made it harder from defined work. And Caro, he investigates Paul's charges
尽其所能对保罗的指控进行了调查。他发现保罗在签署新遗嘱的时间上记错了细节。确实曾有过一份旧遗嘱和一份新遗嘱，但那是在她住院之前重新签署的。保罗的亲戚们并不记得当时是怎么回事。他们只确信他确实做过坏事。
as best as he could. He finds Paul has some details wrong about when the new will was signed. There was an old will and a new one, but it was before she was in the hospital, it was re-signed. Paul's relatives, they don't remember what the deal was. They're sure he did something bad.
保罗·摩西对罗伯特·卡罗说：“请结合罗伯特在1930年的财务状况来看待这件事。”他当时已经不再担任州务卿了。他失业了。他41岁。除了母亲给的那点接济外，他没有任何收入。他有两个女儿要送去读私立学校。他有两处房产要维持。
And Paul Moses says to Robert Carroll, look at this in light of Robert's 1930 financial situation. He's not secretary of state anymore. He doesn't have a job. He's 41 years old. He has no income, except what he's getting from his mom. He had two girls to send to private school. He's got two homes to keep up.
这是你第一次发现他其实很需要钱，因为他向政府提交了一张账单，索取他为他们做工的报酬。虽然这张账单的付款被拒绝了，但他为了讨薪而大动干戈，甚至不惜提交账单，这本身就说明他确实缺钱。而他却拒绝离开公共服务岗位
And for the first time, you can see he needs money because he submits a bill to the government for some work he's done for them. And the bill is denied payment, but he made such a big deal about, I don't get paid for my work, that just to send a bill means he needs money. And he refuses to leave public service
去从事私营企业的工作。他的一贯人设就是那个对金钱毫不在意的人。他花钱大手大脚，所有的摩西家人都这样，但他总是宣称自己不在乎钱。而且与此同时，贝拉·摩西在晚年花钱的速度远远超过了她资金补充的速度。而罗伯特·摩西则在想：
for a private industry job. His whole deal is that he's the guy who doesn't care about money. He spends lavishly, all the Moses do, but he doesn't care about money. And spends lavishly, all the Moses do, but he doesn't care about money. And meanwhile, Bella Moses is spending her money faster than it can be replenished in her old age. And Bob Moses is like,
如果我拿不到这份遗产的合理份额，我就养不起我的家庭了。卡罗说，这当然是保罗的分析。罗伯特拒绝讨论此事，而且当时也没有其他人能够开口了。他稍后又说，不过，要去证实保罗·摩西的另一项指控是否属实是完全可能的。去查明罗伯特·摩西是否真的在幕后秘密运用他在市政府的影响力，
if I'm going to get a fair share of this inheritance, I'm not going to be able to support my family. And Carol says, this of course is Paul's analysis. Robert will not discuss it and there is living no one else who is able to. And he says a little later, but it is possible to ascertain the truth of Paul Moses' other charge. It is possible to determine whether or not it is true that Robert Moses secretly employed his behind the scenes influence
来阻止他的兄弟获得他应得的工作，这件事是完全可以定论的。段落缩进：这是真的。当时的感觉就像是：什么？既然罗伯特·卡罗都这么说了，那就说明有人把实情告诉了他。他说：“我知道这是真的，因为和我谈过的人都向我证实了这一点。而且我找不到任何人告诉我这不是真的。”阅读这段的时候，感觉就像是：好吧，我身边的确也有这样的家庭成员，他们彼此争吵，把很久以前发生的事情归咎于对方。
in city government to keep his brother from getting jobs he deserved. Paragraph indent, it is true. And it's like, what? And if Robert Caro is saying it, it's because people told him. And he says, I know this is true because people I've talked to told me it was true. And I can't find anyone to tell me that is not true. And this is what it's like, you're reading it and you're like, yeah, okay, I certainly have family members who argue with each other and blame each other for things that happened a long time ago.
在市政府里阻止他哥哥获得应得的工作。段落缩进，这是真的。这就像是，什么？如果罗伯特·卡罗这么说，那是因为有人告诉了他。他说，我知道这是真的，因为我交谈过的人告诉我这是真的。而且我找不到任何人来告诉我这不是真的。这感觉就像你在阅读时会想，好吧，我确实有家人们互相争吵，并为很久以前发生的事情互相指责。
And like, they don't talk to each other now because of wills and things like that. It's always like, all right, all right. So this story with Paul Moses, I'm like, all right, maybe, I don't know. And then as soon as it gets to, oh yeah, he totally stopped his brother from getting work. You're like, oh, I'm like, all right, maybe, I don't know. And then as soon as it gets to, oh yeah, he totally stopped his brother from getting work. You're like, oh, well maybe the will stuff was true.
他们现在因为遗嘱之类的东西甚至都不说话了。感觉总是，好吧，好吧。所以对于保罗·摩西这个故事，我觉得，好吧，也许吧，我不知道。但一看到，哦对了，他完全阻挠了他兄弟的工作，你就会觉得，哦，我想，好吧，也许吧，我不知道。但一看到，哦对了，他完全阻挠了他兄弟的工作，你就会觉得，哦，那遗嘱的事可能也是真的。
I don't know. And this is when it gets kind of strange, the lengths that Robert Moses is going to to keep his brother from supporting himself, from working in the same field that he's in. Yeah, and this is just hard to figure out. It's funny, the cutting them out of the will is the motivations or what Robert Moses' role in that is harder to determine, but the motivation for such an action is very clear.
我不知道。而这就是开始变得诡异的地方，罗伯特·摩西竟然费尽心机阻止他兄弟自食其力，阻止他在他所在的同一领域工作。是的，这简直让人难以理解。说来也奇怪，把他从遗嘱中除名的动机，或者罗伯特·摩西在其中扮演了什么角色，还很难确定，但这种行为背后的动机却非常明确。
Here, the trail of evidence is very clear, but the motivation sort of alludes me, you know, of why you would make it so that he could not find consulting jobs in the city. I mean, it's very, there's only two thoughts I have about that, Roman, do you have any brothers? I do not. Okay, so I have a brother,
在这里，证据链非常清晰，但动机让我有点费解，你知道的，为什么要让他无法在城里找到咨询工作。我的意思是，这非常……我对此只有两个想法，罗曼，你有兄弟吗？我没有。好吧，那我有一个兄弟，
and sometimes I get kind of annoyed with him, and so, you know, he rubs me the wrong way. But that's a minor point.'s there's something about Bob Moses He needs to be the superior one. He needs to be the authority He needs to be the bully and I wonder if just having someone there who not only Doesn't see him as an authority sees him as an equal or maybe even as slightly lesser because he's his younger brother Like to have someone who is like, oh yeah, well, I'm not as afraid of you
有时我会被他烦到，所以，你知道，他总是惹我生气。但这只是小事。鲍勃·摩西身上有一种特质，他需要成为那个高高在上的人。他需要成为权威，他需要成为霸凌者，我在想，如果身边有这样一个人，他不仅不把摩西当成权威，反而把他当成平等的人，甚至因为他是弟弟而觉得他略逊一筹，比如身边有这么一个人，表现得像“哦，对了，其实我没那么怕你”，
because like, I literally remember when you were pooping in your pants as you were a little kid. Like that's something I imagine Bob Moses cannot have around, even beyond the will stuff. So he goes about making sure that his brother cannot be hired in the city, and then both for the government,
因为就像，“我 literalmente 记得你小时候拉裤子的样子。”就像我能想象鲍勃·摩西绝对无法容忍身边有这样的人，甚至抛开遗嘱的事不谈。于是他千方百计确保他的兄弟无法在城市里受雇，接着无论是在政府部门，
and then later in private industry. And there's a point where LaGuardia, he needs someone like Paul Moses. He needs someone who understands electrical engineering and is liberal so that he can give him the information he needs to regulate and investigate the utility companies for ripping off New Yorkers. And he also needs someone who has that knowledge
还是后来在私营企业。有那么一段时间，拉瓜迪亚需要像保罗·摩西这样的人。他需要一个懂电气工程且思想开明的人，这样才能为他提供必要的信息，去监管和调查那些敲诈纽约人的公用事业公司。他还必须具备这种知识
and expertise, believes in the cause and does not care if he pisses off utility companies that might hire him later on. And there's basically one guy who fits that bill and it's Paul Moses. And multiple people recommend Paul to LaGuardia and LaGuardia says to them, I can't have him around as long as Bob is here.
和专业技能，信仰正义，根本不在乎是否会惹恼那些以后可能会雇佣他的公用事业公司。基本上符合这个条件的人只有一个，那就是保罗·摩西。多个人向拉瓜迪亚推荐了保罗，而拉瓜迪亚对他们说，只要鲍勃在这里，我就不能留他在身边。
And people in the city government, they can sometimes hire him for temporary consulting jobs. They're impressed by him. He cannot seem to get hired on a permanent job. And what's interesting is, Paul Wendles seems to be trying to hire him all the time. But then when Caro talks to Paul Moses, Paul Moses is like, yeah, Paul Wendels didn't want me around. Like even he doesn't fully understand who was really stopping him from getting hired. And once Paul Wendels leaves the
市里的官员有时还可以聘请他做临时的咨询工作。他们对他的能力印象深刻。但他似乎就是无法获得一份正式的工作。有趣的是，保罗·温德尔似乎一直想雇佣他。但当卡罗与保罗·摩西交谈时，保罗·摩西却说，哦，保罗·温德尔并不想留我在身边。甚至连他自己也没有完全弄清楚究竟是谁在真正阻挠他获得工作。一旦保罗·温德尔离开
government, Paul can't get temporary jobs. Suddenly even private companies won't hire him, even though they used to offer him work. And the hand behind this is Robert Moses, who again controls all this stuff. He's the one person who both has the influence to stop his brother from getting work and also would care at all. Who else would give a shit, pardon my language.
政府，保罗就再也接不到临时工作了。突然之间，连私营公司也不肯雇佣他了，尽管他们过去常常给他提供工作。而这一切背后的黑手正是罗伯特·摩西，他再次掌控了这一切。他是唯一一个既有影响力阻止他兄弟找到工作、又对此会在意的人。除了他，谁还会在乎呢，请原谅我的粗口。
Who else would care if Paul Moses gets a job? And the amount that this sabotages his life is not just he's throwing up roadblocks to make things difficult that he doesn't gain a certain level of success and therefore is somehow a more formidable rival to Robert Moses. He brings him to poverty through these actions.
除了他，谁会在乎保罗·摩西能不能找到工作？这对他生活的破坏不仅仅是设立路障制造麻烦，让他无法达到某种成功的高度，从而不至于成为罗伯特·摩西更可怕的对手。他是通过这些行径将他逼入贫困。
He ruins him completely. Yeah, it's not like, and so Paul Moses didn't work in government and he ended up becoming a lawyer or he ran a shoe store or something. No, it's like like, and so Paul Moses didn't work in government and he ended up becoming, you know, a lawyer or he ran a shoe store or something. No, it's like he's wrecked as a person. Probably it's his own fault because Paul, the Moses's spend money lavishly. Paul Moses also a spendthrift. And by the end of 1938, when we, you know, the years we were talking about in the
他彻底毁了他。是的，并不是说……所以保罗·摩西没有在政府工作，最后成了一名律师，或者开了一家鞋店什么的。不，事情是这样的……所以保罗·摩西没有在政府工作，最后成了一名，你知道的，律师，或者他开了一家鞋店什么的。不，他整个人都被毁了。这可能也是他咎由自取，因为摩西家族花钱大手大脚。保罗·摩西也是个挥霍无度的人。到1938年底，也就是我们，你知道的，在
previous chapter, he's out of money. He's in deep debt. He used to be this kind of dapper man about town. Now he's staying at a salvation army. We're living in the office behind his, his pool complex. His suits are ragged. He's skipping meals. He simply cannot afford to eat regularly. And he's this bitter frustrated guy and he hates his brother and his, and it doesn't help that his brother has managed to invest Paul's trust money in
上一章中讨论的那些年份，他已经分文不剩。他负债累累。他曾经是一个衣着光鲜、风度翩翩的城中名流。现在他却住在救世军收容所里。或者住在他的泳池综合大楼后面的办公室里。他的西装破烂不堪。他经常不吃饭。他根本吃不起正餐。他成了一个痛苦而沮丧的人，痛恨他的兄弟，而且，他的兄弟还设法把保罗的信托基金投资在
a bad real estate deal that has made Paul lose even more money and put him into even deeper debt. Yeah. And he also like lobbies to as the trust, as the executor of the trust, he demands, Bob Moses demands a salary off of this money. Like it's just like insult to injury. It's so terrible.
了一个糟糕的房地产项目上，导致保罗损失了更多的钱，陷入了更深的债务泥潭，这也无济于事。是的。他还游说……作为信托的遗嘱执行人，他要求，鲍勃·摩西要求从这笔钱里拿薪水。这简直是雪上加霜。太可怕了。
Rob Romsky says, I want to be paid for this work. Also this investment, we actually overpaid into it. So you need to return some money to us. You need to return a few thousand dollars you don't have. And Paul Moses is like, my brother's gonna get paid more money from the trust I inherited than I'm ever gonna get. Like this is, and he sues the trustees
罗布·罗姆斯基说，我想要这笔工作的报酬。还有这笔投资，我们实际上支付过头了。所以你需要把一些钱退给我们。你需要退还几千美元，而你根本拿不出来。保罗·摩西觉得，我从继承的信托基金里得到的钱，我哥哥拿到的报酬比我这辈子能拿到的还要多。就像这样，于是他起诉了受托人，
and the case is moved from an impartial judge to a judge who's friends with Al Smith, who not only rules for the trustees and rules for Robert Moses, but then lectures Paul about being greedy. And like at this point, it's like the book of Job, you know, like it's just one thing after another happening to Paul Moses.
案件从一个公正的法官那里转给了一个与阿尔·史密斯交好的法官，这位法官不仅判受托人胜诉，判罗伯特·摩西胜诉，还训斥保罗贪婪。到了这个时候，感觉就像《约伯记》一样，你知道的，一件接一件的不幸降临在保罗·摩西身上。
And he becomes this guy who is fixated on his brother and it makes it easier for other people around him to believe, oh, he's unstable. He did something bad in the past. He must have, he can't trust him. And he just can't get work in New York City. And Robert Caro says to him, why don't you go to another city?
他变成了一个执着于他兄弟的人，这使得他周围的其他人更容易相信：哦，他精神不稳定。他过去做过坏事。他一定……根本不能信任他。而他在纽约市就是找不到工作。罗伯特·卡罗对他说：“你为什么不去别的城市呢？”
And Paul says to him, what, let him drive me away? And it's like, oh, that's like, that's not a healthy outcome. And it does remind you, it's like, oh, well, he probably could have gone to Chicago, Los Angeles, some other city, Cincinnati somewhere and gotten a job doing this kind of work. But now there's a personal rivalry to it.
保罗对他说：“什么，让他们把我赶走吗？”这就好比，哦，这可不是一个健康的结局。这确实提醒了你，那就是，哦，他其实完全可以去芝加哥、洛杉矶、其他某个城市，比如辛辛那提的某个地方，去做这种类型的工作。但现在这已经变成了一场个人的意气之争。
And also New York is the place that he knows by now he's becoming an older man. And people in the New York area, they're like, it's pretty weird that this brilliant electrical engineer whose brother controls the hiring of engineers for public projects, that he can't get a job. Very strange. It's like, Robert, you're having trouble finding engineers
而且纽约是他熟悉的地方，到现在他已经是一个年纪稍大的人了。纽约地区的人们会想，这个才华横溢的电气工程，他的兄弟却控制着公共工程工程师的招聘，而他竟然找不到工作，这真是太奇怪了。太奇怪了。就像，罗伯特，你在为圣劳伦斯河上建造的水坝寻找工程师时遇到了困难，
for this dam you're building on the St. Lawrence River. Didn't your brother already make up plans for a dam on the St. Lawrence River. Didn't your brother already make up plans for a dam on the St. Lawrence River, but you won't hire him. I don't know what's going on. And it gets to the point that you're saying he ends up in poverty. He is an old man. He lives in a one room walk-up apartment
难道你兄弟不是早就为圣劳伦斯河上的水坝做好了规划吗？难道你兄弟不是早就为圣劳伦斯河上的水坝做好了规划，但你就是不肯雇佣他。我不知道这到底是怎么回事。事情发展到你所说的地步，他最终陷入了贫困。他成了一个老人。他住在曼哈顿最南端的一间
at the very Southern tip of Manhattan. He lives with a woman named Millie, who, Carol says, nobody seems to know what her last name is. She's just this older woman who seems devoted to him. And Carol hints that this may be the woman Paul loved at Princeton when he was young. There's something about that that feels a little too romantic to me.
步梯公寓里。他和一位名叫米莉的女士住在一起，卡罗说，似乎没有人知道她的姓氏是什么。她只是一个似乎对他忠心耿耿的老年妇女。卡罗暗示，这可能是保罗年轻时在普林斯顿深爱的那个女人。这件事总让我觉得有点太浪漫了。
A little too like, so I don't know. And I wonder- I like it. I always remember that detail because it's so poignant. You know, even if it's, you know, just doesn't, you know, I don't know, doesn't quite hold water. To sound like a newspaper, say beautiful if true. You know, doesn't quite hold water. To sound like a newspaper, say beautiful if true. You know, but, and by the 1960s,
有点太……所以我不知道。不过我——我挺喜欢的。我总是能记住这个细节，因为它太感人了。你知道，哪怕它，你知道，只是不，你知道，我不知道，经不起推敲。套用报纸的话说，如果是真的那就太美了。你知道，经不起推敲。套用报纸的话说，如果是真的那就太美了。你知道，但是，到了20世纪60年代，
when Robert Moses is still a powerful person, Paul Moses is an elderly man. He can't get up the stairs of his building. His brother is building thousands of apartments in elevator buildings for people at Paul Moses income level. And Robert Moses giving out those apartments to people as favors, and it never occurs to him. Or or if it does he rejects the idea to give his brother one of those buildings which as Carol points out would have improved his brother's
当罗伯特·摩西仍然是个大权在握的人物时，保罗·摩西已经是一个垂暮老人了。他连自己公寓的楼梯都爬不动了。他的兄弟正在为保罗·摩西收入水平的人建造数千套带电梯的公寓。罗伯特·摩西把这些公寓作为人情送给别人，却从来没有想到过这一点。或者说，就算他想到了，他也拒绝了给他兄弟一套公寓的想法。正如卡罗所指出的，如果住在有电梯的公寓里，本可以无可估量地改善他兄弟的
life immeasurably to live in a building with an elevator this is how far their their lives have gone these two guys started in the same place they're very similar men Robert Moses is the shaper of worlds who is re almost by hand remolding New York and Manhattan Island and things like that and putting up more bricks than anyone ever has more cement and his brother meanwhile is struggling to get up the stairs of this to this tiny apartment he lives in and he haunts kind of city hall he's always hanging around there to the point that the people he used to know uh retire and now Paul Moses becomes just kind of like in the eyes of the people who work there, like a nut who just goes into offices and bothers people.
生活。这就是这两个人生活的差距。这两个起点相同的人，是如此相似的男人。罗伯特·摩西是世界的塑造者，他几乎亲手重塑了纽约和曼哈顿岛以及诸如此类的地方，铺设了比历史上任何人都要多的砖块和水泥；而与此同时，他的兄弟却在艰难地爬上楼梯，回到他居住的那间微型公寓里，他在市政厅周围徘徊，总是在那里转悠，以至于他过去认识的人都退休了，如今在那些在那里工作的人眼中，保罗·摩西变得就像个怪胎一样，只会闯进办公室去烦扰别人。
And finally in 1962, Paul collapses and his brother finally goes to visit him at the hospital. And he brings him like a brochure about the Triborough Authority or something like that. Like he brings him like souvenirs that are about how great Bob Moses' work is. And Paul Moses at this point, he's so nervous that Millie is going to be left with nothing when he dies with no money that he swallows his pride after decades and he writes Robert Moses and he asks him for a job. And Moses arranges for him to become what Caro describes essentially an errand boy at an engineering firm for $96.16 a week. Like the least he can do is what he does,
终于在1962年，保罗晕倒了，他的兄弟终于去医院探望了他。他给他带了一本关于三镇管理局（Triborough Authority）或者类似机构的小册子。他带给他的纪念品全都是关于鲍勃·摩西的成就有多伟大。而此时的保罗·摩西，担心自己死后身无分文，米莉会一无所有，他终于在几十年后压下自尊，写信给罗伯特·摩西，向他求职。摩西安排他去一家工程公司当了一名卡罗所描述的基本上是差遣杂役的员工，周薪96.16美元。他能做的最起码的事情也就是这样了，
which is like, oh, my elderly brother, yeah, I'll get you this kind of low man on the pole job where you should be probably running this firm at this point. It's such a, there's other members of the family that we'll get into in just a moment, but the story of Paul Moses, it really feels like you're seeing
那就是，哦，我年迈的兄弟，好吧，我会给你安排这种处于底层的工作，而以你目前的资历，本来应该由你来管理这家公司。这真的是……家族里还有其他成员，我们稍后再谈，但保罗·摩西的故事，真的让人觉得你仿佛看到的是
in some ways the same person, it's a real sliding door thing, the same person on alternate tracks. And I wonder if part of it is like, Bob Moses seeing competition from his brother and wanting to cut that off, or Robert Moses being like, I could have turned out like my brother.
在某种意义上是同一个人，这是一个现实版的“滑动门”效应，同一个人在不同的人生轨道上。我在想，其中一部分原因是不是，鲍勃·摩西看到了来自他兄弟的竞争，想要将其扼杀在摇篮里，或者罗伯特·摩西觉得，我本来也可能变成我兄弟那样的人。
I don't wanna be reminded of that. Like, I just don't want anything to do with him. You know, that's the more sympathetic way to look at it in a way, you know. Or it doesn't want anybody to see someone so similar to him, so down on his luck, so low. And so therefore you can imagine Robert Moses as this man, as this man knocking around City Hall,
我不想被勾起这种回忆。所以，我只是不想和他有任何瓜葛。你知道，从某种角度来看，这是一种比较容易引起同情的方式，你知道的。或者他不想让任何人看到一个如此像他的人，运气这么背，处境这么低。因此，你可以想象罗伯特·摩西作为这样一个人，在这个男人在市政厅里到处游荡、
talking about engineering. I think this idea of Robert Moses self-mythologizing, you know, he has to come from somewhere. So obviously, you know, Bella Moses, you know, is part of his story, but there's this way, you know, he doesn't talk about having a brother in any public forum. His biography, when stuff like that is mentioned, part of his personal life is mentioned, he stops cooperating with his biographer. He never talks about his sister either. And I think that there's a bit of him that just like,
谈论工程学的时候……我觉得罗伯特·摩西这种自我神话化的想法，你知道，总得有个出处。所以很显然，你知道的，贝拉·摩西，你知道，是他故事的一部分，但有一种方式是，你知道的，他在任何公开场合都不谈论自己有个兄弟。在他的传记中，当提及类似事情、提到他的个人生活时，他便停止与传记作者合作。他从来不提他的妹妹。我觉得他身上有一部分就是，
he doesn't want any personal history that allows for some kind of weakness, like some kind of like different part of the story instead of what he makes of himself. Like he is the city builder and he was just like born, you know, fully armored out of Zeus's head as the city builder and him, you know, like having a period of time where this like weak man,
他绝不希望任何个人历史暴露出某种弱点，暴露出某种与他自己塑造的形象截然不同的故事。就像他是城市的建设者，他是直接带着全副盔甲从宙斯的脑袋里蹦出来成为城市建设者的，而如果让他经历这样一段时期——这段时期里，这个软弱的男人、
this failure of a man probably dominated him was maybe smarter than him. He can't have a period of his life, have any type of narrative in which he is below or less than or whatever it is. I mean, it's just, it's really, I mean, this chapter is really heartbreaking. And it's also, you know, like of all the different things and interpretations of whether or not Robert Moses is doing, you know, the right thing for the most amount of people, the person who can get things done when most
这个失败的男人曾经压倒过他，甚至可能比他更聪明——他绝不能让自己的生命中有任何一段叙事，在其中他是居于人下、不如别人或者诸如此类的。我的意思是，这真的……我的意思是，这一章真的非常令人心碎。而且这也是，你知道的，在所有关于罗伯特·摩西是否在为最多的人做正确的事情、是否是在大多数人
people can't. And you can argue these little bits and points about like, you know, him being just part of the entire culture of cars that's happening in cities around the nation and his poor decisions were really the fashion of the time. This type of thing, where this is a man who could literally give him an apartment and gives apartments to people all the time, could just alleviate the suffering of his brother and doesn't do it, is just, it's like so cold. It's so painful.
做不到时能把事情办成的人的各种不同看法和诠释中，这个能够 literalmente 给他一套公寓、却总是把公寓送给别人、本可以减轻他兄弟的痛苦却偏偏不这么做的人，真的是冷酷到了极点。太痛苦了。
There's no national ideological trend of ruining your brother in America at the time. Like there's a car culture, but there's not a torturing your siblings culture, into adulthood. Kids torture their siblings all the time. And he could do, it's so little. It's so nothing for him to make Paul's life better. And it just blows my mind.
当时美国并没有摧毁自己兄弟的全国性意识形态潮流。就像存在汽车文化，但并没有成年后折磨自己兄弟姐妹的文化。小孩子整天折磨兄弟姐妹。而他能做到的，这只是举手之劳。对他来说，让保罗的生活变得更好简直是微不足道的事情。这真的让我大跌眼镜。
Yeah, it's astounding. And it's almost like the, he know, he's the master builder. He's gonna reshape the world the way he wants it, no matter who has to leave, has to get relocated or hurt in the process. And he's gonna reshape his history the way he wants it, no matter who he has to relocate or get rid of in the process.
是的，太令人震惊了。这简直就像是，他知道，他是造物主。他要按照自己想要的方式重塑世界，无论过程中必须让谁离开、必须让谁迁走或受到伤害。他也要按照自己想要的方式重塑自己的历史，无论过程中他必须迁走或除掉谁。
And I mean, the story only gets a little sadder from here. So buckle up folks. I mean, first, Carol briefly talks about their sister, Edna, who really gets short shrift in the book, maybe because she didn't talk to Robert, I don't know. Or maybe because her life is not particularly eventful, which is fine. But she kind of does whatever Robert Moses tells her to do
我的意思是，这个故事从这里开始只会越来越令人悲伤。所以各位系好安全带吧。我的意思是，首先，卡罗简要地谈到了他们的妹妹埃德娜（Edna），她在书中着墨极少，也许是因为她没有跟罗伯特说话，我不知道。或者也许是因为她的生活并没有什么特别的波澜，这倒也无所谓。但她基本上是罗伯特·摩西让她做什么，她就做什么，
in terms of family stuff, until she and her husband moved to Florida. And then she finds that her brother effectively forgets she exists and just ignores her, doesn't take her calls. There's one point where he's coming to Florida and she's like, oh, can I see you? And he's like, yeah, well, if you come to the airport,
在家庭事务方面，直到她和丈夫搬到佛罗里达。然后她发现她的兄弟基本上忘记了她的存在，对她置之不理，不接她的电话。有一次他要来佛罗里达，她说，哦，我能见见你吗？而他说，好吧，如果你来机场，
you can see me for a couple minutes before I leave for this other place. And she goes, okay, I get the idea. I'm just not going. Like, that's it. I don't need to do that. And it fits into that rubric for him of like, if I can use this person, they're a part of my life. If I can't use this person, I don't need them to be a part of my life. But then Carrow ends the chapter talking about the relationship between Robert Moses and his wife, Mary Moses.
在我去别的地方之前，你可以见我几分钟。然后她说，好吧，我明白了。我干脆不去了。就这样。我没必要这么做。这符合他那种为人处世的准则：如果我能利用这个人，他们就是我生活的一部分；如果我不能利用这个人，我不需要他们成为我生活的一部分。但随后卡罗在章节末尾谈到了罗伯特·摩西和他的妻子玛丽·摩西（Mary Moses）之间的关系。
And we remember Mary was the secretary at the bureau that he fell in love with. He would talk his ideas out with her. And she was the woman who, when he was working two long hours, you know, on the Long Island Park Commission, she'd come to the office and pull him by the ear and get him home. And she is the person who is effectively making his career possible by running their home while he is away. And that split is pretty classic for the time that the man works at the side of the home, the woman is inside the home. But even further than normal, she's buying all his clothes, she's paying the bills, she's arranging
我们还记得玛丽是他坠入爱河的那个局里的秘书。他会跟她讨论自己的想法。当他在长岛公园委员会（Long Island Park Commission）长时间工作时，她是那个会去办公室揪着他的耳朵把他拉回家的人。她基本上是通过在他外出时操持家务，才让他的职业生涯成为可能的。这种分工对于那个时代来说非常经典，男人在外面工作，女人在家里操持。但她做的比通常人还要多得多：她给他买所有的衣服，她付账单，她帮他安排
for his haircuts. She makes sure in the morning that he has car fare in his pockets in case he has to take a car or train somewhere. And if he's schmoozing with city politicians, she helps him remember who people are. She helps him to get them on his side. She helps take care of the staff. If he's in a bad mood, when he leaves to work, she'll call ahead and say, he's in a bad mood today when he leaves to work, she'll call ahead and say, he's in a bad mood today, like, just be careful. If someone on staff loses a family member,
理发。她会在早晨确保他口袋里有零钱，以防他需要坐车或坐火车去什么地方。如果他要在市里的政客面前应酬，她会帮他记住这些人的名字。她帮他把这些人争取到自己这边。她帮忙照顾员工。如果他心情不好，出门去上班时，她会提前打电话说：“他今天出门上班时心情不好，你们小心点。”如果员工家里有人去世，
she's the one who remembers to reach out to them and give their condolences. Like, she is very much a partner in a lot of what he's doing, and is also constantly defending him to other people, constantly advising him. And he said, and Moses quoted in the chapter that when he makes a mistake and something doesn't work out,
她是那个记得去慰问并致以哀悼的人。可以说，她在他所做的很多事情中扮演了名副其实的合作伙伴角色，而且还经常在其他人面前为他辩护，不断向他建言献策。正如他在本章节中所引用的那样，当他犯了错、事情没有办成时，
he goes, oh, that's one of the times I didn't listen to Mary. I didn't talk to Mary about that one. Yeah, anytime he makes a boner, it's because he didn't listen to Mary. Yeah. It's an old fashioned way of saying it. Yeah, yeah. And, but over the years, Caro depicts this process
他说过：“哦，那正是我没有听玛丽的话的时候之一。那件事我没有跟玛丽商量。”是的，他每次犯蠢，都是因为没有听玛丽的话。是的。这是个比较老派的说法。对，对。而且，多年来，卡罗描绘了这个过程，
and it's not as detailed as the Paul stuff. I think because he wasn't talking directly to Mary Moses. And also I think there's a, I get the feeling here that I think because he wasn't talking directly to Mary Moses. And also I think there's a, I get the feeling here that he's kind of covering his sources a little bit more than he does in other sections. I have to look in the notes in the back to see. Every now and then in the notes, you'll find a part where it's like, this person only spoke if I kept them anonymous, or there's the mention in one part really in the book of one of Moses
其详细程度不如保罗的部分。我想这是因为他并没有直接采访玛丽·摩西。而且我也觉得，在这里给我的感觉是……我想这是因为他没有直接采访玛丽·摩西。而且我也觉得，在这里给我的感觉是，他在隐瞒消息来源方面比在其他章节中做得更多一些。我得去翻翻后面的注释看看。注释里偶尔会发现这样一部分内容：这个人只有在我保证匿名的情况下才肯开口，或者书中确实有那么一处提到了摩西的一位
staff members who commit suicide because he's being driven so hard. And he says in the notes, I am not mentioning this man's name out of respect for his mother who's still alive. And like, so there's a little bit of that, I wonder going on here, but he talks about how as the years go on and Robert Moses gets more powerful and louder, Mary Moses is getting kind of weaker and quieter. And by 1930, she is seen by people no longer as like the vivacious equal partner of Bob Moses,
员工因为工作压力太大而自杀。他在注释中写道：为了尊重这位母亲依然在世的母亲，我没有提这个人的名字。所以，这里面多少有点这种成分，我在想是不是这么回事，但接着他谈到，随着岁月流逝，罗伯特·摩西变得越来越有权势、声音越来越大，玛丽·摩西却变得越来越虚弱、越来越安静。到了1930年，人们不再把她看作是鲍勃·摩西充满活力、平起平坐的伴侣，
but as this kind of shy, withdrawn woman. She still clearly idolizes her husband, and she boosts him a lot while minimizing herself. When he's running for governor, she's interviewed and she's like, well, I don't know why you talk to me. You should talk to the candidate. He's a more interesting person than me. I don't know what I've done. And she seems to be aging dramatically, perhaps from the strain of running their household and Bob's life and her own life,
而是把她看作是一个害羞、退缩的女人。她显然依然崇拜她的丈夫，在极力抬高他的同时不断贬低自己。当他竞选州长时，她接受采访时说：“好吧，我不知道你们为什么要采访我。你们应该去采访候选人。他比我更有趣。我不知道自己做过什么。”她似乎在急剧衰老，也许是因为操持家务、操心鲍勃的生活以及她自己的生活所承受的巨大压力，
or perhaps just from being ignored so much, who knows? So much of Robert Moses' life is spent with the things he's doing. And as Carol has made it clear earlier, there's almost no time in the day for any of this stuff. It's funny because Carol will be like, Robert Moses was always there for Clambakes with the kids, but it seems like that.
又或者仅仅是因为长期遭受冷落，谁知道呢？罗伯特·摩西的大部分时间都花在了他所做的事情上。正如卡罗之前已经明确指出的那样，一天之中几乎没有时间来处理这些事情。有趣的是，卡罗会写道：罗伯特·摩西总是抽出时间和孩子们一起参加滨海烧烤（Clambakes），但看起来好像……
I don't know how often that must have happened. It seems impossible. Yeah, exactly. It's not a weekly clambake. And Robert Moses is, you know, he at, at any time of day or night, he may suddenly leave and go swimming to stay kind of physically vigorous. And Carol starts jumping ahead and saying by the 1950s, Robert Moses is catching the eyes of younger women who see Mary as not
我不知道这种事到底能发生多少次。这听起来根本不可能。对，没错。这不是每周一次的滨海烧烤。罗伯特·摩西，你知道的，他在一天中的任何时间或黑夜，都可能突然离开去游泳，以保持身体的健壮。而卡罗开始把时间线往后推，说到了20世纪50年代，罗伯特·摩西开始吸引年轻女性的目光，在她们眼里，玛丽已经
being much to speak of. And as early as the 1930s, there are rumors that Moses is having affairs with kind of more glamorous women, richer women. And under the strain of all this, Mary begins to drink, people began to assume that she is an alcoholic, and there are times when she embarrasses herself in public because she's had too much to drink. And she's eventually hospitalized several times and it seems unclear whether that's because of alcohol abuse
算不上什么了不得的人物。早在20世纪30年代，就有传言称摩西与一些更有魅力、更富有的女性有染。在这一切的重压之下，玛丽开始酗酒，人们开始认为她是个酒鬼，而且有时她会因为喝得酩酊大醉而在公众面前出丑。她最终曾数次住院，目前尚不清楚这是因为酗酒导致的，
or because of other kinds of breakdowns. But we're left with this portrait of this marriage that was between these two vigorous people, one of whom was clearly subordinating herself for the ambitions of the other. And now he's stayed powerful. He's gotten only more powerful and she has withdrawn more and more. And I think it's too far to say that Caro is saying this, but the impression I get is almost of Moses like a vampire, kind of like draining the vitality from
还是由于其他类型的精神崩溃。但留给我们的却是这样一幅婚姻肖像：这段婚姻曾经属于两个充满活力的人，其中一人显然为了另一个人的野心而甘愿处于从属地位。而现在，他依然大权在握，甚至权力更胜从前，而她却日渐退缩。我觉得如果说卡罗是在这样表达，或许有些过分，但给我的印象几乎是摩西就像一个吸血鬼，从他的妻子身上
his wife in order to stay on top of his own life. And then when she is no longer able to keep up in the same way because she's gotten older, kind of like tucking her away, you know, and not necessarily openly mistreating her, but sidelining her from his life. And it's such a sad way for this chapter to end. You know, the last chapter ended with the sadness of Al Smith as this bitter old man, and this chapter has taken us through the ruin of Paul Moses and then the just diminishment of Mary Moses. And there's something, I'm of two thoughts about this chapter. And one of them is that this is much more gossipy
榨取生命力，以此来维持他自己高高在上的生活。而当她因为变老而无法再以同样的方式跟上节奏时，他就把她“束之高阁”，你知道的，虽然不一定是公开虐待她，但却把她从自己的生活中边缘化了。这一章以如此悲伤的方式结束。你知道，上一章以阿尔·史密斯作为一个痛苦老人的悲剧收场，而这一章则带我们经历了保罗·摩西的毁灭，然后是玛丽·摩西的日渐消沉。而且对于这一章，我有两种截然不同的想法。一方面，这比其他章节要八卦得多，
than other chapters in a way that Carol mostly stays away from. But also that to avoid showing this, to say only, oh, we're only gonna talk about his public life. We're only talking about the public things he did, is to not look at the person in full, all the ways that he used power, because there's another sort of power, and that's the power between two people. That's the power dynamic that's in a family.
卡罗通常会刻意避开这种风格。但另一方面，如果为了避免展现这一点，如果只说“我们只谈他的公共生活，我们只谈他所做的公开事情”，那就是没有全面地审视这个人，没有看到他运用权力的所有方式，因为还存在另一种权力，那就是人与人之间的权力。那是存在于家庭之中的权力动态。
And these are other aspects of power that are not democratic power, they're not urban infrastructure power, or electric power, you know, which it becomes up so much in the book, the power of motors and things like that. But every human interaction involves some sort of power dynamic. And I feel like the last, I don't know what 10, 15 years of American society has been about people having their eyes open to kinds of power dynamics they maybe didn't recognize before or were refused
这些是权力的其他方面，它们不是民主权力，不是城市基础设施权力，也不是电力（这在书中经常出现，比如发动机的动力等等）。但每一次人际互动都包含某种权力动态。我觉得过去的，我不知道，美国社会的最后10到15年，正是关于人们睁开眼睛去审视那些他们以前可能没有意识到、或者拒绝
to recognize before, were oblivious to. And these are other aspects of power and they show us some more of the cost of someone being the master planner who can get things done, you know, in this way. That the cost is not just in money, it's not just in marshland, but it's also in the people around this person. And whether that's a fair cost, whether that's an equation worth balancing, Caro's not gonna give us that answer. That's not his job to give us that answer. His job is only to lay it all out there and then allow us to make the choice,
意识到的、对此一直懵懂无知的权力动态。这些是权力的其他维度，它们向我们展示了某人成为能够把事情办成的规划大师所付出的更多代价。这种代价不仅体现在金钱上，不仅体现在湿地上，还体现在这个人周围的人身上。这是否是一个公平的代价，是否是一个值得权衡的等式，卡罗不会给我们答案。给出答案不是他的职责。他的职责只是把这一切摆在桌面上，然后让我们自己做出选择，
I think, of how we feel about it. And it's a thing that, I don't know, I like it when my books tell me what to think. You know, I don't like it when my books just ask questions. It's pretty interesting to me how, you know, segregated this portion is. It both like extends and collapses time in an interesting way.
我认为，去决定我们对此有何感受。这是一件，我不知道，我挺喜欢我的书直接告诉我该怎么想的。你知道的，我不喜欢我的书只是不断抛出问题。对我来说挺有趣的是，这一部分是如此的“独立隔离”。它以一种有趣的方式既延伸又压缩了时间。
It works on a different time scale than other parts that we're talking about. I mean, we sort of reach the end of Mary Moses's life here somewhat and definitely the end of Paul Moses's life. But it's very sequestered to do this thing, which is to give a well-rounded view of Robert Moses as a man as opposed to his sort of just activities as the master builder. It strikes me that like, you know, the Lyndon Johnson books that Carol wrote, the personal and political are more integrated into the story of LBJ, and they're more documented too.
它以不同于我们讨论的其他部分的时间尺度在运作。我的意思是，在这里我们某种程度上走到了玛丽·摩西生命的终点，而保罗·摩西的生命则毫无疑问地走到了尽头。但为了完成这样一件事，它的安排是相当孤立的——也就是为了给罗伯特·摩西提供一个全方位的立体视角，让他作为一个活生生的人呈现在我们面前，而不仅仅是他作为规划大师的种种活动。让我印象深刻的是，你知道的，卡罗写的林登·约翰逊的那些书，其中的个人生活和政治生涯与LBJ的故事融合得更加紧密，而且也有着更丰富的文献记录。
So it seems like he's figuring out how to place this. He sort of has a way of just integrating it better when he's talking about Lyndon Johnson in the later volumes of the work that he did. This just stands out, this is one like strange chapter that tells a totally different story that gives you a different view of this man that you've at this point grown to somewhat loathe and now you really do
所以看起来他当时正在摸索如何摆放这些内容。当他在作品的后期卷册中谈到林登·约翰逊时，他有一种方式能把这些内容融合得更好。而这一段则显得格外突出，这是一个奇怪的章节，讲述了一个完全不同的故事，让你对这个你此时已经开始有些厌恶、而现在更是深恶痛绝的男人有了另一种看法，
because these are like, it's not that his actions are relatable at all, they're just more normal. Like more people have experienced like rifts within families that cause this type of strife and can place themselves more in these situations. And you can totally see how a person could read this and see themselves in Paul Moses or Mary Moses in a way that they maybe can't, like a person who just has their favorite park bulldozed or you know or something like that.
因为这些，这不是说他的行为有什么共鸣可言，而是它们更像普通人。就像更多的人曾经经历过导致这种冲突的家庭内部裂痕，并能更能感同身受地将自己代入这些情境中。你完全可以想象一个人在读到这里时，会在保罗·摩西或玛丽·摩西身上看到自己的影子，这种代入感可能是在看到某人最喜欢的公园被推土机推平、或者诸如此类的事情时所没有的。
There's a, Caro is so good I feel like, I think you're right that in the Lyndon Johnson books they're more integrated. I wonder if part of that is because yeah Lyndon Johnson was already a famous personality but also he had three, he knew he would have at least three books to work on that with so he kind of get into it more. But I also, I wonder if like, Caro is still kind of working in some ways in a reporter mode and the reporter mode is like, you're telling a big story. You got to find the human element of it. Like we talked with Brandy last episode about like people are interested in people. Every story that's interesting has people in it, you know?
卡罗真的是太棒了，我觉得，你说的对，在林登·约翰逊的书中，它们融合得更加紧密。我在想，部分原因是不是因为，是的，林登·约翰逊本身就是一个名人，而且他也知道自己至少有三本书的篇幅来处理这些，所以他可以更深入地挖掘。但我也在想，卡罗是不是在某种程度上仍然以记者模式在运作，而记者模式的特点就是：你在讲述一个宏大的故事。你必须找到其中的人性元素。就像我们在上一集和布兰迪聊的那样，人们对人感兴趣。每一个有趣的故事里面都有人，你知道吗？
And so he's very good, I think, at picking out who is the individual that he's going gonna boil a story down to a lot of the time. When it's, you know, when he gives a couple examples earlier on in the first chapter, but like when it's time for him to talk about Moses as a bully, he focuses for a few moments on Pearl Bernstein and the way that Moses treated Pearl Bernstein. And it's so much more powerful than if he said, you know,
所以他非常擅长，我认为，挑选出那个他要将故事浓缩到其身上的个人。当他，你知道的，在第一章的早期给出几个例子时，但当轮到他讲述摩西是一个恶霸时，他花了片刻时间聚焦于珀尔·伯恩斯坦（Pearl Bernstein）以及摩西对待珀尔·伯恩斯坦的方式。这比他说，你知道的，
400 people quit from Moses's staff or something like that. And here it's like, it's like the reporter part of him that's like, you gotta, 400 people quit for Moses's staff or something like that. And here it's like, it's like the reporter part of him that's like, you got to find the human angle. Let's, we'll do it here. This is the, and we'll do it about Paul Moses. And yeah, it's a, it is a strange chapter. It's strange the way it's balanced. It's called two brothers, but it ends talking about his wife, about Mary Moses. And I'm not quite sure how I feel about how little space Mary Moses gets, whether I think more space would be allowing to tell her story more fully. And because right now she's almost treated like a side person in this whole story. Or if more space would feel like it was holding her up to, um,
有400名员工从摩西手下辞职之类的说法要有力得多。而在这里，这就好像是……就像他身为记者的一面在说：你必须找到切入人性的角度。我们就在这里做这件事。这就是，我们会围绕保罗·摩西展开。而且是的，这是一个奇怪的章节。它的结构平衡方式很奇怪。它被称为《两兄弟》，但结尾却在谈论他的妻子，谈论玛丽·摩西。我不大确定自己对玛丽·摩西得到的篇幅如此之少作何感想，我不知道更多的篇幅是否能允许更充分地讲述她的故事。因为现在她在整个故事中几乎被当成了一个边缘人物。或者说，如果给予更多的篇幅，会不会让人觉得是在把她置于
in indignity, you know, um, whether it's protecting her or not, what the gentility of it and the old-fashionedness of protecting someone or revealing the truth. And there's a lot going on under the surface in this chapter. And I wonder if that's also why, like, or if it's aided by the fact that Kara was so open at the beginning of like,
一种有失尊严的境地，你知道的，这究竟算是在保护她，还是别的什么？这里面既有对某种体面和老派风格的考量——即是该保护一个人还是该揭露真相。在这一章的表象之下，潜藏着很多东西。我在想，这是否也是为什么，或者说，是否得益于卡罗在开头时表现得如此坦诚，比如：
this is when I talked to Paul Moses. This is what it looked like where I saw Paul Moses. Like he's much more in this chapter than he is in other chapters. Yeah, it's just so different and fascinating. And I think it's like, you know, when people look back and have read this with us over the year,
“这就是我与保罗·摩西交谈时的情景。这就是我见到保罗·摩西时的样子。”在这章中，他的个人印记比其他章节要浓厚得多。是的，真的是如此与众不同且引人入胜。我想，当人们回首过去，在这一年中与我们一同读完这本书时，
I think it's super likely that this will be the chapter they remember the most, the most detail of, and has the most visceral impact on them. It's just, it's really something else. It's sort of like, it just stands out in this interesting way that I like. But I'm just kind of fascinated by it. I think about it all the time. Yeah, it's a powerful thing that it sticks out that much.
我觉得这极有可能是他们记忆最深刻、细节记最牢、且对他们产生最直观冲击的一章。真的是别具一格。它就像是……它以一种有趣的方式脱颖而出，我很喜欢。但我只是对它深深着迷。我无时无刻不在思考它。是的，它有着强大的力量，才会让人印象如此深刻。
The book is so huge, and there's so much stuff going on. And true, I feel the same way that this chapter always stuck out to me and the details of it, that opening that you're in a room full of people applauding Robert Moses and way in the back is Paul Moses and he is not applauding. Like that visual and that moment stuck with me so long and it's so cinematic. And this feels to me like when a TV show does their one episode, that's kind of like the weird episode, you know, where it's like a musical, or it's like all set in one room, or it's told backwards. And it's so unlike what the rest of the series is,
这本书太宏大了，里面发生的事情太多了。真的，我也有同感，这一章总是让我印象深刻，其中的细节，那个开场——你身处一个满是人的房间里，大家都在为罗伯特·摩西鼓掌，而在队伍的最后方是保罗·摩西，他没有鼓掌。那样的视觉画面和那个瞬间在我脑海里挥之不去，画面感太强了。这让我觉得，这就好像是一部电视剧拍了他们那集“画风突变”的怪异单集，你知道的，比如那一集是音乐剧，或者所有的场景都发生在一个房间里，或者是倒叙。这与该剧的其他部分大相径庭，
but that's the episode people remember, partly for that reason, you know, that it sticks out in their mind. So I guess this is Robert Caro's bottle episode where he didn't have the budget, so he had to have everything take place in one car or something. Walk up apartment.
但偏偏这就是人们记住的那一集，部分原因也正是因为这一点——它深深印在他们的脑海里。所以我想这就是罗伯特·卡罗的“瓶中剧”（bottle episode），因为经费不足，所以他不得不把所有的场景都安排在一辆车里或者别的什么地方。步梯公寓。
Well, anyway, so it's just a fascinating chapter, a fascinating discussion. And when we move on from here, next month we'll be covering pages 607 to 702. That's chapters 27 through 32, which will finish out the part five, the love of power, and continues on to part six, the lust for power. It just gets worse and worse. Oh, you thought the love of power was bad. the lust for power just gets worse and worse. You thought the love of power was bad. Lusting for power is even worse than at least loving. There's an emotional aspect to it.
好吧，不管怎样，这真的是一个迷人的章节，一场精彩的讨论。当我们从这里继续前行时，下个月我们将涵盖第607页到第702页。那是第27到第32章，这将为第五部分《对权力的爱》画上句号，并继续进入第六部分《对权力的贪婪》。情况只会变得越来越糟。哦，你以为对权力的爱已经够糟糕了吧？对权力的贪婪只会变得越来越糟、越来越糟。你以为对权力的爱很糟糕？贪恋权力甚至比单纯的热爱还要糟糕。这里面包含着一种情感层面。
Lusting. It's just animal passion for power. Yeah, that's next month. But after this break, we're going to talk to Mike Schur, who created Parks and Rec and The Good Place. And we're going to talk to him a little bit about what this book means to him and how he, you know, after Robert Caro presented the Parks Department as this secret source of power, Mike Schur came along decades later to remind us that Parks and Rec is actually a little tiny department that does nothing. That's after the break. as inspiration in developing Parks and Rec, we just had to have him on. The idea for having Mike on the show
贪婪。那纯粹是对权力的动物性激情。是的，那是接下来的内容。但在休息之后，我们将与迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）进行交流，他是《公园与游憩》（Parks and Rec）和《善地》（The Good Place）的创作者。我们将与他聊聊这本书对意味着什么，以及当罗伯特·卡罗将公园部门描述为这个秘密权力之源后，迈克·舒尔如何在几十年后来到我们身边，提醒我们《公园与游憩》实际上只是一个无所作为的小部门。广告之后见。作为开发《公园与游憩》的灵感来源，我们必须要邀请他来。邀请迈克来节目的想法
actually came from our Discord server, so thank you to user Ben for the suggestion. First of all, let's talk about your experience with Power Broker. How did you come to it, and what happened to you once you read it? Well, I don't wanna kick this off with a brag, but I've read it three times.
实际上来自于我们的Discord服务器，所以感谢用户本（Ben）提出的建议。首先，让我们谈谈你阅读《权力掮客》（Power Broker）的经历。你是如何接触到它的？读完之后你有什么感受？好吧，我不想一开头就在这里显摆，但我已经读了三遍了。
We call that the minimum around here. off with a brag, but I've read it three times. We call that the minimum around here. We call that the beginning step, but yeah, okay. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, I have achieved amateur status by reading it three times. So I moved to New York after college in 1997, and I love New York. I grew up in Connecticut and New York was always like big and scary and exciting.
我们把那叫做这里的最低标准。我有点像在自吹自擂，但我已经读了三遍了。我们把那叫做这里的最低标准。我们把那叫做起步阶段，不过，好吧。是的，没错。是的，我已经通过读了三遍达到了业余爱好者的水平。所以我在1997年大学毕业后搬到了纽约，我非常喜欢纽约。我是在康涅狄格州长大的，对纽约的印象总是那种宏大、吓人又令人兴奋的城市。
And then I moved there and just completely fell in love with the city. And I was at a party maybe a year after I moved and I was ranting about New York because I was saying, this is the best city in the world. And it is so beautiful and so, it makes so much sense, you know, the, the layout of the streets and the neighborhoods and central park right in And it is so beautiful and so, it makes so much sense. You know, the layout of the streets and the neighborhoods
然后我搬到了那里，就彻底爱上了这座城市。大概在我搬去一年后的一次派对上，我在那儿大发牢骚地夸赞纽约，因为我说，这是世界上最棒的城市。它太美丽了，而且，它太合乎情理了，你知道的，街道的布局、街区以及中央公园就在——而且它太美丽了，而且，它太合乎情理了。你知道，街道和街区的布局
and Central Park right in the middle, taking up a thousand acres of the greatest, most valuable real estate in the, certainly in North America. And it's just, everything about it is great, except for one thing, which is why is it so messed up in terms of its transportation? And you know, coming from Connecticut, which is just north and a little east of
而中央公园就在正中间，占据了最好、最有价值的房地产中足足一千英亩土地，至少在北美是这样的。而且它简直，方方面面都很好，除了有一件事，那就是为什么它的交通会搞得这么一团糟？你知道的，从康涅狄格州过来，那儿就在纽约市的北面偏东一点，
the city, every time I drove home, I would have this same feeling, which is like, what is this insane tangle of road that you encounter? Why is it so crazy? The Van Wick Expressway and the Major Deegan and then the Sawmill and the BQE and the Cross Bronx, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. You know, you can't, you can barely take the subway to the airport, it takes four hours and it's just, I don't get it and someone, I don't know who,
每次我开车回家，我都会有同一种感觉，那就是：你遇到的这究竟是什么疯狂交织的道路？为什么它会这么疯狂？范威克高速公路、迈杰迪根高速公路、锯木厂高速公路、布鲁克林-皇后区高速公路以及跨布朗克斯高速公路，等等等等。你知道的，你根本不能，你几乎没法坐地铁去机场，要花四个小时，这简直太让人费解了，而且有人，我不知道是谁，
lost to history, basically said like, read this book and you'll understand. And it was, and I've heard you two talk about this on this very podcast. It was like, I was being inducted into the Masons or something. It was like a secret society where it was like, just here, like, so like they opened a trench coat
早已湮没在历史中，基本上说过这样的话：读这本书，你就会明白了。而且那是，我听你们俩在这个播客里谈论过这件事。那种感觉就像，我被吸收加入共济会或者别的什么组织一样。就像是一个秘密社团，就好像，过来，就像他们打开了风衣的衣襟，
and there were some knockoff watches and a copy of the Power Broker and they gave me the copy of the Power Broker. And I, me the copy of the Power Broker. And I started reading it and I just tore through it. I read it in like two weeks and I thought when I was done, I thought that's the greatest novel I've ever read is how I thought about it. It's certainly the greatest book I've ever read, but I thought of it as a novel. It's like you couldn't have, no imagination
里面有些山寨手表和一本《权力掮客》的副本，然后他们就把《权力掮客》的副本交给了我。然后我，把《权力掮客》的副本交给了我。我开始阅读它，然后简直是一气呵成地读完了。我大概两周就读完了，当读完的时候我想，我当时心想，这是我读过的最伟大的小说。它绝对是我读过的最伟大的书，但我当时把它当成了一部小说来读。就像你不可能，没有任何想象力
could have come up with a better story than this story. And I started, uh, I started talking about it so much that my, my then girlfriend and now wife actually banned me from talking about it at cocktail parties or other gatherings. It's one of three times in her life she's been like, you gotta stop talking about this.
能想出一个比这个故事更好的故事了。我开始，呃，我开始不停地谈论它，以至于我当时的男友、现在的丈夫实际上禁止我在鸡尾酒会或其他聚会上谈论它。这是她一生中仅有的三次对我说“你得别再谈这个了”的时候之一。
Not like, not for her sake, for my sake. She was like, you're gonna drive all of your friends away if you keep talking about this book. And she was by the way, totally right. So I, instead of talking about it, I just thought about it. I thought about it endlessly for years. I moved to LA in 2004 and a couple of years
不是为了她好，是为了我好。她说，如果你继续谈论这本书，你会把所有的朋友都吓跑的。顺便说一句，她说得完全对。所以，我不再谈论它，而是开始思考它。多年来我一直在无休止地思考它。我在2004年搬到了洛杉矶，几年
after that, I started working on the TV show Parks and Recreation, which was about a woman who worked in local government. And the idea for Leslie Knope, Amy Poehler's character was she was going to be a person who was a pure idealist, but had no kind of understanding of the structures, the power structures and the calcified system of government and how to actually get things done.
之后，我开始制作电视剧《公园与休憩》，该剧讲述了一个在地方政府工作的女性的故事。而莱斯利·诺普（也就是艾米·波勒饰演的角色）这个构思是，她将是一个纯粹的理想主义者，但对种种结构、权力结构、僵化的政府系统以及如何真正把事情办成却毫无概念。
And I thought, I gotta read The Power Broker again. Like that's the book that helps you understand these things. So I read it for the second time, sort of in preparation to run that show. And it was very sort of meaningful in this new context, which was not about living in New York, but about what happens when you are an idealist, and you, but you also need to get things done.
当时我想，我得再读一遍《权力掮客》。因为那是能帮你理解这些事情的书。所以我为了筹备那部剧，读了第二遍。在这样一个全新的背景下，它显得意味深长，不再是关于住在纽约，而是关于当你是一个理想主义者，并且你既有理想，但又需要把事情办成时会发生什么。
Because obviously that book is the greatest story ever of a person who, who starts off with the best of intentions and is slowly corrupted by power and, and sort of like the understanding of how levers are pulled. And the goal I remember saying early on to Amy, the goal of this is to do, is to have Leslie be Robert Moses, but remain true to herself. Like, yeah, but Robert Moses, but good.
因为很显然，那本书是有史以来关于一个人最伟大的故事：这个人最初抱着最好的意图，却慢慢被权力所腐蚀，并且，某种程度上理解了权力的杠杆是如何被操纵的。我记得早期曾对艾米说过，我们的目标是让莱斯利成为罗伯特·摩西，但同时要忠于自我。就像是，没错，但是要做个好版罗伯特·摩西。
It's a pretty good, it's a good explanation of the character. And then, so that was a sort of guiding principle. We actually worked it into an episode. She gave, she mentioned it in one episode and I think gave it to a friend of hers as a, as a present or something. And then the third time I read it was over COVID when, when we were all locked in our houses,
这解释这个角色还算挺贴切的，这是一个很好的角色解释。然后，这就成为了某种指导原则。我们甚至把它写进了一集里。她在其中一集中提到了这本书，我想是把它当成礼物送给了她的朋友什么的。然后我第三次读它是在新冠疫情期间，当时我们都被锁在家里，
I sort of had this thought of like, well, I can't leave my house and what should I do to spend my time? And I was like, I haven't read that book in a decade. I'll read it again. So I read it for the third time. And the wonderful and funny thing was that when I read it over COVID, it was the same copy, it was the same paperback copy I'd read the first two times. And it completely disintegrated in my hands.
我脑子里突然冒出这样一个想法：嗯，我不能出门，我该怎么打发时间呢？然后我想，我已经有十年没读过那本书了。我再读一遍吧。所以我读了第三遍。美妙而又搞笑的事情是，当我在疫情期间阅读它时，竟然是同一本书，是我前两次读的那本平装书。它在我的手里彻底解体了。
Like it just, the binding broke and like huge chunks of the book had fallen out. And I was like, by the time I was done reading it, it was the cover of the 1100 page book, but with only like 300 pages still actually adhering to the spine. So that's my history with it. It started with how do I understand New York City? It changed to how can I understand this character who is obviously not anything close to Robert Moses, but has the same set of goals as he did
就像它那样，书脊断裂了，书的大块大块内容掉了下来。我想，当我读完的时候，它只剩下了这本1100页的书的封面，而实际上依然粘在书脊上的只有大约300页。这就是我和这本书的历史。它始于“我该如何理解纽约市？”，后来变成了“我该如何理解这个角色，她显然和罗伯特·摩西没有任何相似之处，但却有着和他在当初作为一个满眼憧憬的改革者时相同的目标”。第三次阅读纯粹是因为我喜欢它，我想再读一遍。
when he started out as a sort of wide-eyed reformer. And then the third time was just because I love it and I wanted to read it again. I love that your story with it is kind of like the story of a prophet who has received the word from on high, tries to share it with everybody. It falls on deaf ears. They're not listening.
我喜欢你与它之间的故事，这有点像一个先知的故事：他从高处接受了神谕，试图与所有人分享。但这犹如对牛弹琴，没有人听。
They tell you stop, don't tell us this anymore. Then you find the person or the form that you can actually communicate it in, and you reach, I guess, Amy Poehler, you reach the one person who is open to that message. And then when you try to return to the original source, the original word, it's like God has shut off that valve and is like, you don't need this anymore. You're, you know, my time with you is done. You're no longer a tool I need in the universe. And the book disintegrates like something in a fantasy novel, you know? Exactly.
他们叫你停下，别再跟我们讲这个了。然后你找到了能够真正传达它的那个人或那种形式，你接触到了，我猜就是艾米·波勒，你触及了那个对这一信息持开放态度的唯一的人。然后，当你试图回归最初的源头、最初的神谕时，就好像上帝关闭了那个阀门，说道：你不再需要这个了。你知道的，我对你的时间已经结束了。你不再是我在宇宙中需要的工具了。这本书就像奇幻小说里的东西一样解体了，你知道吗？完全是这样。
Yeah. So like the words floated off the pages and disappeared into the ether. The lost golden disks of Moroni. Yep. Yep. Exactly. Yeah.
对。所以那些字飘离了书页，消失在太空中。莫罗尼失落的金页片。没错。没错。完全是这样。对。
Am I saying I'm a prophet of some kind? I don't know, that's not for me to decide. That's up to your listeners. That's right. That's outstanding. I mean, one of the reasons why I was so intrigued to talk to you is this Parks and Rec connection of like Robert Caro creating this masterpiece
我是说我是某种先知吗？我不知道，这不由我决定。这取决于你的听众。没错。太出色了。我的意思是，我如此渴望与你交谈的原因之一，就是《公园与休憩》和罗伯特·卡罗创作这部杰作之间的这种联系，
of like Robert Caro, you know, creating this masterpiece to talk to us about how the Parks Department is this, you know, strange source of hidden undemocratic power. And then you, you know, like whatever, 40 years later, talk about being like as sort of silly as you might expect, you know, Parks and Rec Department to be, but also having all these might expect, you know, Parks and Rec department to be, but also having all these sort of, you know, intricacies of bureaucracy
就像罗伯特·卡罗（你知道的）创作了这部杰作，来向我们讲述公园部门是如何成为一个奇怪的、隐藏的、反民主的权力来源的。然后你，（你知道的）不管怎样，40年后，谈到自己就像你所能预料的那样有点傻乎乎的，你知道的，《公园与休憩》部门的样子，但同时也拥有所有这些你可能会预料到的，你知道的，官僚主义的错综复杂
and good people doing, you know, bad things, bad things. You know, mostly it's good people doing good things on Parks and Rec. Yeah. So, but it's so funny to me that there's this connection there when you were already connected to this material in some way. Yeah.
还有好人做，你知道的，坏事，坏事。你知道，在《公园与休憩》里，大多是好人做的好事。对。所以，当你本来就以某种方式与这个题材产生联系时，发现其中存在这种联系，让我觉得太有趣了。对。
I mean, the, the research that Greg Daniels and I did early on in order to write the show was, was very eyeopening and also very on, at a small scale level, obviously very reminiscent of the early chunk of the power broker, because what we learned was like, you're, you start off when you trying to do public works projects, you start off with a, an idea and the idea can be very pure. And then because this is America, the public gets to weigh in and the public
我的意思是，格雷格·丹尼尔斯和我为了写这部剧在早期所做的研究，非常具有启发性，而且在小范围内，显然非常让人联想起《权力掮客》的前半部分，因为我们了解到的是：当你试图开展公共工程项目时，你最初会有一个想法，这个想法可以是非常纯粹的。然后，因为这是美国，公众得以介入并发表意见，而且公众
has a lot of opinions and some of them are good and some of them are bad, but they all have to be heard. And we talked to this one guy who he had, he was trying to design, redesign a small park. And he had this, in New York City, and he had this idea for to sort of restore the park to the way that it had looked in the like 1890s, you know. And that involved like, you know, light stanchions that had a certain kind of like at the time, I think it was like a Doric column kind of feel because it was the Gilded Age, you know. And so he was gonna do these like old timey 19th century sconces and all this sort of stuff.
有很多意见，其中有些是好的，有些是坏的，但他们的声音都必须被听到。我们采访过一个家伙，他当时正试图设计、重新设计一个小公园。他在纽约市，他有这样一个想法，试图把公园恢复到它在1890年代左右那时的样子，你知道的。这涉及到，你知道的，某种特定样式的路灯灯柱，在当时，我想它有点多立克柱的感觉，因为那是镀金时代，你知道的。所以他打算做这些19世纪的老式壁灯以及所有诸如此类的东西。
And it was a very beautiful idea. And then meeting after meeting after meeting after meeting, people say, those lights are too tall, they're gonna shine in my apartment and I'm not gonna be able to sleep. And so he makes alterations and then someone else says, this is where we walk our dogs. And if the paths aren't, if there isn't enough green space,
这是一个非常美好的想法。然后，开会、开会、开会、开会，人们说，那些灯太高了，会照进我的公寓，让我无法入眠。于是他做出修改，接着另一个人说，这是我们遛狗的地方。如果小路不是，如果没有足够的绿地，
then the dogs won't have places to walk or whatever. And they just kind of like chip away and chip away and chip away. And by the time the design was actually approved by the public commission, it was like he had one, like the columns were just now like steel poles and you know, everything was like flattened. And there is this one little tiny, like little flourish,
那么狗狗们就没有地方散步了，诸如此类。他们就这样一点一点地削减、一点一点地削减、一点一点地削减。等到这个设计方案真正被公共委员会批准时，就好像他只剩下一个——柱子现在只变成了钢柱，你知道的，一切都被扁平化了。而且只有一个小小的地方，有一个小小的装饰，
like at the top of the light stanchions, there was like a tiny bit of like, you know, intricate stone relief that he had managed to keep and salvage from his original design. And we said like, that must have been so devastating. And he kind of shrugged and he was like, look, I got this like small win. Like I had this idea to do this big elaborate thing.
就像在灯柱的顶端，有一点点，你知道的，复杂的石雕浮雕，是他设法从最初的设计中保留并挽救下来的。我们说，那一定让人太崩溃了吧。他耸了耸肩，然后说道：听着，我赢得了这么一个小小的胜利。我本来有个想法要做一个宏大复杂的东西，
And like, at the end of the day, yeah, it's not what I wanted, but like, that's not the job of the, that's not my job. My job is to serve the public. And so if I can manage to salvage like one little tiny thing that I'm proud of, then great. And then the public, to the extent that the public can ever be truly satisfied with something, the public will be satisfied with the project. And it was both sort of heartbreaking and also kind of lovely because his attitude was like, I managed to do something that I'm proud of and also the public was served in the way that they asked to be served. And we sort of had that, it's not like a, I don't know what you would call it, it's not quite a North star for the show, but it had this vibe of like,
结果到头来，是的，这不是我想要的，但，那不是这份工作的内容，那不是我的工作。我的工作是服务公众。所以，如果我能设法挽救哪怕一小点我引以为傲的东西，那就很棒了。然后，公众——在公众能够真正对某事感到满意的范围内——会对这个项目感到满意。这既让人心碎，又有点可爱，因为他的态度是：我设法做了一件让我感到骄傲的事，同时公众也得到了他们所要求的服务。我们当时有这样一种，这不是，我不知道你该怎么称呼它，它不太像是这部剧的北极星，但它有这样一种氛围，即：
this is what Robert Moses lacked, especially as he gained power, was he forgot about the second part, right? He forgot about the part where his job was to serve the public, and all he wanted was for it to be the way that he wanted it to be. And I thought like, well, there's the difference, right? If you're trying to create a character who is the good version of Robert Moses,
这就是罗伯特·摩西所缺乏的，尤其是当他获得权力之后，他忘记了第二部分，对吧？他忘记了那部分：他的工作是服务公众，而他唯一的愿望就是一切都按照他想要的方式进行。我想，这就是区别所在，对吧？如果你试图塑造一个好版本的罗伯特·摩西，
then the, the part of Robert Moses, the idealist and the reformer should be 99% of the, of the character and the, and the part of Robert Moses that just wanted to run rough shot over everybody and do things only the way that he saw fit should be 1% or less than the way that this person goes about their business. And you know, there were a lot of moments like that where we would hear a story or a, a sort of tale of woe from a public servant.
那么罗伯特·摩西身上作为理想主义者和改革者的那部分应该占到这个角色特质的99%，而罗伯特·摩西身上那种只想对所有人横行霸道、完全按自己认为合适的方式行事的成分，应该只占到这个人做事方式的1%甚至更少。而且你知道，有很多这样的时刻，我们会听到一个公务员的故事或苦难经历，
And the first thing I would think of is Robert Moses. I would think about the book and the difference, the fundamental difference between the way that folks who are responsible public servants behave versus how Moses ended up behaving for the great majority of his life. Yeah. And like in your research, I bet you found,
而我首先想到的就是罗伯特·摩西。我会想到那本书，以及那些尽职尽责的公务员的行为方式与摩西度过其绝大部分人生时的行为方式之间，那种根本上的区别。是的。而且就像在你们的研究中，我敢打赌你发现，
I think I have found sort of like in my life, is the public servants that are, they're more like Leslie Knope than they are like Robert Moses out there in the world. Yeah, I think that's probably true. I mean, really many of them are not like either. Yeah, yeah. Well, I mean.
我想我在生活中也发现了，现实世界中的公务员们，其实更像莱斯利·诺普，而不是罗伯特·摩西。对，我想这大概是真的。我的意思是，实际上他们当中很多人两样都不像。对，对。嗯，我是说。
They're neither angels nor demons, I don't know. Yeah, like. But there's a sense of serving the public in a way, I mean, they know what's right and wrong, and sometimes you put yourself in a position of leadership because you feel you know what is right, you know, and therefore you reluctantly take the advice of other people, but I've found that, you know,
他们既不是天使，也不是恶魔，我不知道。是的，就像。但某种程度上有一种服务公众的意识，我是说，他们知道什么是对，什么是错，有时你把自己放在领导岗位上，是因为你觉得自己知道什么是对的，你知道的，因此你不情愿地接受别人的建议，但我发现，你知道的，
most people are trying to do good in this world. I think that's true. Yes. I think that that there's, let's put it this way. There are very few people who are trying to be Robert Moses in part, because it'll never happen again that part, part of what makes the book so compelling is it's the exact person and personality type and sort of like, and family
大多数人都在试图在这个世界上做好事。我认为那是真的。是的。我认为，让我们这样说吧。很少有人试图成为罗伯特·摩西，部分原因在于这种情况将永远不会再次发生。部分原因在于，这本书之所以如此引人入胜，正是因为它描绘了一个极其特殊的人、极其特殊的性格类型、以及某种背景和家族
lineage and city at a time of possibility. You know, everything in most things in American cities are pretty well formed at this point. You know, they're, we're not making a lot of new big cities that even have the opportunity for someone to do what Moses did in New York. And then also the kind of weird confluence of events of Moses coming of age in a time when like Tammany Hall was running New York and him getting that first firsthand look at how, you know,
血统，恰好出现在一个充满可能性的时代。你知道的，现在美国城市的绝大多数事物在这一点上都已经相当成型了。你知道，我们并没有建造很多新的大城市，甚至都不具备让某人能像摩西在纽约那样行事的契机。再加上一系列奇妙的事件交汇：摩西在坦慕尼协会统治纽约的时期长大成人，并且他第一手观察到了，你知道的，
idealism is fine, but power is what gets things done and him learning that lesson, getting crushed by that power and then shifting gears from idealist to power gatherer. And at a time when the entire west side of Manhattan was, you know, garbage and landfill, and there were no highways and cars were just kind of coming into vogue as individual modes
理想主义是好的，但权力才是办成事情的关键，他吸取了这个教训，被那种权力碾压，随后从理想主义者转变为权力的搜集者。当时曼哈顿的整个西区，你知道的，都是垃圾和填埋场，还没有高速公路，汽车作为个人出行方式刚刚开始流行，
of transportation and there were beaches all around and no one could get to them. And so he was able by building those roads to get people to beaches, which then gave him the power in the public sphere to that he could wield as, as the great, you know, man of the people, like all of those things had to swirl around and join forces at exactly the right moment. So if you're a public servant now, you know, you don't even have the opportunity to become Robert Moses because it's too late.
周围到处都是海滩，但没有人能去得了。因此，他通过修建那些道路，让人能够去到海滩，这随后赋予了他在公共领域的力量，使他能够以伟大的“平民英雄”的身份挥洒这种力量——所有这些事情必须在完全正确的时刻盘旋交织并合力爆发。所以如果你现在是一个公务员，你知道的，你甚至没有机会成为罗伯特·摩西，因为为时已晚。
So I think most people go into public service, especially in urban design or in, you know, working for a Parks and Rec Department or something with the goal of like doing something good for the public. They don't go in, no one in their right mind would say like, I want to be the most powerful man in the world. I'm going to join the parks and rec department of this, of this city. Like it's, it's hard to imagine what kind of psychopath would think that was even possible.
所以我认为大多数人投身公职，特别是在城市设计领域，或者在公园与休憩部门工作之类的人，他们的目标都是为公众做点好事。他们不会去想——任何神智正常的人都不会说：“我想成为世界上最有权势的人，我要加入这个城市的公园与休憩部门。”这，很难想象究竟是怎样的精神病患者才会觉得这甚至是有可能的。
Um, so I think you're right. I think that if, if there's a, if there's a default setting for the folks who have these jobs now, it is on the side of good. It is like, I want to, I just want to like make the soccer field look nicer for the girls, you know, youth league to play on and not I'm going to, I'm going to dominate the urban landscape for 50 years. You make, you make a good point that the, the time when that's possible is, is
嗯，所以我觉得你是对的。我认为，如果现在从事这些工作的人有一个默认基调的话，那就是站在善良这一边的。就像是，我只想让女子青少年联赛踢球的足球场看起来更好看一些，而不是我要在未来50年里统治整个城市景观。你提出了一个很好的观点，那就是那种可能性存在的时代，
fairly over. I feel like within my lifetime, the only person I can think of in New York, at least, that wanted to do that same sort of thing was maybe Michael Bloomberg when he was mayor. Where he was like, I'm a billionaire, I can do whatever I want, I'm gonna make it so I can run for a third term. And everyone's gonna let me do what I want.
基本上已经结束了。我觉得在我有生之年，在纽约我能想到的唯一一个想要做类似事情的人，大概就是迈克尔·布隆伯格当市长的时候了。当时他的态度是：我是亿万富翁，我想干什么就干什么，我要设法让我能竞选第三任期。每个人都会让我随心所欲。
And he had these big visions, but he's still coloring in the lines that Robert Moses set down. You know, there just isn't the blank canvas. I mean, Robert Moses' canvas was not that blank since, you know, as happens throughout the book, he displaces thousands of people. But this sense of like, oh, this city is clay
他有着宏大的远景，但他依然是在罗伯特·摩西划定的线条内涂抹。你知道的，这里根本没有一张白纸。我是说，罗伯特·摩西的画布其实也不是那么空白，因为，正如书中所展现的那样，他驱逐了成千上万的人。但这种感觉，噢，这座城市是一块我可以随心塑造的粘土。
that I can mold. With Bloomberg, even with his vision was still limited by the fact that the city was now, instead of clay, it was like plastic. So it was like, well, I can break this piece off, but I can't mold it. I can melt this, warp this kind of plastic structure, but I can't totally. When I was leaving New York, so I left New York in 04, and just as I was leaving, and I might have the timeline wrong, it's been 20 years, obviously,
到了布隆伯格时期，即使他的远景也依然受到这样一个事实的限制：这座城市现在不再是粘土，而是像塑料一样。所以这就好比，嗯，我可以把这块掰下来，但我没法塑造它。我可以融化、扭曲这种塑料结构，但无法彻底……当我离开纽约时——我在04年离开纽约，就在我离开的时候，也许我的时间线记错了，毕竟已经20年了，显然，
they unveiled, Bloomberg unveiled a giant plan for West Side redevelopment, and it involved massive new stadia for, I think, the Yankees, and maybe the Mets, and maybe the New York Giants and Jets, and like... As many teams as he could push to the West Side of Manhattan, and he wanted the Olympics to be in New York so badly. So it's like, we have to build all these facilities to make New York a world-class city for the Olympics. And I remember that I felt as a New Yorker at the time,
他们公布了，布隆伯格公布了一个关于西区重建的宏大计划，其中包含针对扬基队（我想是的）、也许还有大都会队、也许还有纽约巨人队和喷气机队的庞大新体育场，以及……尽可能多的球队，只要他能把他们推到曼哈顿西区去，而且他太渴望奥运会在纽约举办了。所以这就像是，我们必须建造所有这些设施，把纽约变成一个举办奥运会的国际大都市。我记得作为一个那时的纽约人，我当时的感受是：
I was like, we're already the greatest city in the world. Like I don't, the Olympics would be lucky to have us, but you'd be right, he had this huge plan for all this stadium development. Yeah, and it was not just a stadium. It was like the whole West Side was in this plan that he laid out. The whole West Side. It was exactly the kind of project that Moses would have not only proposed,
我觉得我们已经是世界上最伟大的城市了。我并不觉得，奥运会能拥有我们那是他们的幸运，但你说得对，他为所有这些体育场的开发做出了这样一个庞大的计划。是的，这不仅仅是一个体育场。根据他规划的蓝图，整个西区都在这个计划之中。整个西区。这恰恰是那种摩西不仅会提出，
but actually just ram-rodded through, right? And I remember thinking like, well, this is insane. This guy's lost his mind. There's no, this is a. This guy's lost his mind. There's, you can't, there's no, this would, this is a hundred trillion dollars worth of development. But I remember reading a quote from him and the quote was fascinating. And I think both scary and also true.
而且还会直接强行推进的项目，对吧？我记得当时想，嗯，这太疯狂了。这家伙疯了。根本没有——这家伙疯了。根本没有，这行不通，这根本是个——这是一个价值数百万亿美元的开发项目。但我记得读到过他的一句名言，那句话非常迷人。而且我认为既吓人又真实。
And what he said was New York is a city that builds things. And if New York ever stops building things, New York will die. And that's a paraphrase, but that's what he said. And I remember thinking of course, immediately of the power broker, but also that he's right. That one of the things about New York that has
他的原话是：纽约是一座靠建造事物而存在的城市。如果纽约有一天停止了建造事物，纽约就会消亡。这是我意译的，但大致就是这个意思。我当时立刻就想到了《权力掮客》，同时也觉得他是对的。关于纽约的一个特质是，
defined the city is that even though you can walk down blocks on the upper west side or the upper east side, and you can see these brownstones that have been there for 150 years. And there are enormous cathedrals and there are structures that date back 200 years, which for American cities is pretty old. The defining characteristic of the city is that every time you go back, it's different.
它定义了这座城市：尽管你可以沿着上西区或上东区的街区走过，看到那些已经矗立了150年的褐石建筑；也有巨大的大教堂，以及可以追溯到200年前的建筑（对于美国城市来说这已经相当古老了）。但这座城市的决定性特征在于，每次你故地重游，它都是不同的。
There are, there are stores of, and restaurants have disappeared and new ones are there and buildings have been torn down and new sky strapers have been built. And for better or worse, the city just moves forward and it moves forward in through construction and Bloomberg was the last mayor, I think, who, who was trying to sort of not only acknowledge that fact, but also like get like
有商店和餐馆消失了，新的餐馆取而代之，旧建筑被拆除，新的摩天大楼拔地而起。不管好坏，这座城市总是在向前迈进，它是通过建设向前迈进的。布隆伯格是最后一位市长，我认为，他不仅试图承认这个事实，而且还试图顺应这股潮流，
downwind of it and like sail on that aspect of the city and say like, the stuff that Moses did, yes, it might have been racist and awful and displaced thousands of people and destroyed neighborhoods, but that's just what this city does. It's what the city has always done. And we can't racist and awful and displaced thousands of people and destroyed neighborhoods. But that's just what this city does. It's what the city has always done. And we can't stop doing that. We maybe can do it more responsibly and less racistically, but we can't stop building.
乘着这座城市的这一面向前航行，并说道：摩西所做的事情，是的，它可能是种族主义的、可怕的、驱逐了成千上万的人并摧毁了社区，但这就是这座城市一直在做的事。这就是这座城市一直以来的所作所为。我们不能停止这样做。我们或许可以做得更有责任感、更少一些种族主义色彩，但我们不能停止建设。
And I do think that part of, again, part of what made Moses a singular person was he was doing it in that city. If Robert Moses does what he did in Cleveland, Ohio or even Chicago or Dallas or Phoenix or even Los Angeles, I don't think it's the same thing because New York is so, is so concentrated, it's so packed in. so, is so concentrated. It's so packed in and it, and in order for it to
而且我确实认为，再次强调，使摩西成为一个独一无二之人的部分原因在于，他是在那座城市里做这件事的。如果罗伯特·摩西在克利夫兰、俄亥俄州，或者甚至在芝加哥、达拉斯、菲尼克斯，甚至在洛杉矶做他所做的事，我认为都不是一回事，因为纽约是如此的集中，如此的拥挤。如此的集中。它是如此的拥挤，而且为了让它
have this kind of like this, you know, the ages of, of emperors were traditionally very long. And the ages of emperors in New York are very short, you know, these, these time periods that we think about in the city, they're measured in years or maybe decades, but not centuries, not millennia. Everything is knocked down and built back up very quickly. And so he was just, Moses was the guy who did it the most,
拥有这种类型的——你知道的，帝王们的统治时代通常非常漫长。而纽约帝王们的统治时代却非常短暂，你知道的，我们在城市中想到的这些时间段，是以年或者可能是十年为单位来衡量的，而不是以世纪、更不是以千年。一切都被迅速推倒并重建。所以他只是，摩西是那个把这件事做到极致的人，
but other folks who have come after him have recognized that and have tried in some cases like Bloomberg to actually replicate it by saying like, Hey, if we stop moving, this doesn't, this isn't New York anymore. And it's, it's one of the things that is so wonderful and also kind of heartbreaking about loving that city is just how often it is erased
但继他之后的人也意识到了这一点，并且在某些情况下，就像布隆伯格一样，试图通过这样的话来复制它：嘿，如果我们停止前进，这就再也不是纽约了。这是热爱这座城市如此美妙、却又如此让人心碎的事情之一，那就是它被抹去的频率是多么之高，
like an Etch A Sketch and then rebuilt. Uh, and I, I don't know, I don't know what that means about the future, whether that will continue, whether the time of New York is come and gone, but it is a, it's part of the reason the book is so fascinating is because that true fact about New York met the greatest builder who's ever lived.
就像是一块“神奇画板”（Etch A Sketch），随画随擦然后重建。呃，我不知道，我不知道这对于未来意味着什么，这是否会继续下去，纽约的时代是否已经过去，但这正是这本书如此迷人的原因之一，因为关于纽约的这个真实事实，恰好遇到了有史以来最伟大的建设者。
And they, in the, in the course of whatever it was, call it 30 years, basically built a new city within the city that already existed. Wow. It's true that you're, I mean, that's very well said. I think it's well said, yeah, totally. But it's funny, because you kind of get the idea that comes after the book is written.
他们在——无论多长时间，姑且称之为30年吧——的过程中，基本上在已经存在的城市内部，又建造了一座新城市。哇。确实如此，我的意思是，这话讲得太好了。我觉得讲得很好，完全如此。但这就很有趣，因为你会有那种在书写完之后才诞生的想法。
Because it's interesting to me to read the book now, know, 50 years after it was written. And there are certain things in it where Moses is saying, the things I'm building are going to last for centuries. This is not going to be for centuries. For centuries, people will be going to the New York Coliseum. That's going to last as long as the Roman Coliseum, and it's gone. You know, for centuries, people are going to go to Shea Stadium. That's not there anymore. That even Moses, he's building the biggest sandcastles. But maybe that's the nature of New York, is that it's a wave that eventually wears down anything.
因为现在读这本书很有意思，你知道的，是在它写成50年后。书中有些地方摩西在说，我建造的东西将历经数百年。这不是为了几百年后的事。几百年后，人们依然会去纽约体育馆（New York Coliseum）。那将会像罗马斗兽场一样长存，但它已经消失了。你知道的，几百年后，人们依然会去谢伊体育场（Shea Stadium）。那也不复存在了。甚至连摩西，他建造的也是最大的沙堡。但也许这就是纽约的本质，它是一股最终会磨损一切的海浪。
You know, so maybe there's hope to get that waterfront back, I don't know. Well, that's part, again, another fascinating aspect of this, right, is that he was right in some cases and very wrong in other cases, especially toward the end when he kind of lost his fastball, is like he didn't understand. He built Shea Stadium. Shea Stadium was always a piece of crap, always.
你知道的，所以也许还有希望把那个滨水区夺回来，我不知道。嗯，这也是另一个迷人的方面，对吧？那就是他在某些情况下是对的，但在其他情况下大错特错，尤其是到了晚年，当他有点“失去投球威力”（lost his fastball）时，就像他并不理解的那样。他建造了谢伊体育场。谢伊体育场一直是个垃圾，一直都是。
It was never a good stadium, ever. And he had, right next to it, he had Yankee Stadium that was also now gone, but was like a testament to history and to something that had longevity compared to other similar stadiums across the country. But he was so short-sighted to think that Shea Stadium, this kind of like random collection of slabs of concrete and a terrible blue and orange color scheme and all of the other stuff that made Shea Stadium terrible, that like,
它从来都不是一个好体育场，从来都不是。就在它旁边，他有扬基体育场，虽然现在也消失了，但它曾经是历史的见证，相比全国其他同类体育场，它具有某种长寿性。但他却如此目光短浅，认为谢伊体育场——这个由混凝土板随机拼凑、有着糟糕的蓝橙配色方案以及所有让谢伊体育场变得糟糕的其他东西的建筑——
this is his Roman Coliseum? Like, this is what's gonna stand the test of time? Like, that thing was doomed from the beginning. I went to Shea Stadium for the first time in 1987, and I remember thinking like, what a piece of crap. Like, I mean, just awful. And it's very funny to have the attitude that he had, which was, I am the one guy who will build things in this city that will never be torn down. And then to build Shea Stadium. It's a very funny, it's a very funny PS.
会是他的罗马斗兽场？就像，这就是经得起时间考验的东西？那玩意儿从一开始就注定要毁灭。我是在1987年第一次去谢伊体育场，我记得当时的感想是：真是个垃圾。我的意思是，简直太糟糕了。而且带着他那种态度——我是唯一一个在这座城市建造永远不会被拆除的东西的人——然后却建了谢伊体育场，这真的非常搞笑。这真是个非常滑稽的附言。
But his like, his like, his slow growth, and you might say like delusion of, like I've won this race. I have conquered this city. I will be the person who's never forgotten. The irony is that if it weren't for Robert Caro, he would absolutely have been forgotten by now because it's not that people wouldn't know who he was.
但像他那种——他缓慢的膨胀，你也可以说是妄想——觉得自己赢得了这场比赛。我征服了这座城市。我将成为那个永远不会被遗忘的人。具有讽刺意味的是，要不是因为罗伯特·卡罗，他现在绝对已经被遗忘得干干净净了，倒不是说人们不会知道他是谁。
He still has his name on a thousand state parks all over the state and people would go like, oh, who was that guy? Yeah, he built the Van Wick or whatever. But the like all truly kind of narcissistic delusional lunatics, by the time he was done, he felt like he was gonna be, you know, Caesar or Nero or whoever. He was gonna be a, he was a piece of history
他的名字依然刻在全州成千上万个州立公园上，人们可能会问：哦，那家伙是谁呀？是的，他修建了范威克高速公路什么的。但就像所有真正自恋、有妄想症的狂人一样，当他完工时，他觉得自己将成为——你知道的，凯撒、尼禄或是别的什么人。他将成为一段历史，
that would never be displaced, which is why the last line of the book, spoiler alert, is so beautiful, which is when Carol- Pause this interview right now, listeners. Yeah, sorry. Then listen to the rest of the series, then come back and finish this interview.
永远不会被取代。这就是为什么这本书的最后一句话（剧透警告）是如此的美丽，当卡罗——现在就暂停这个访谈吧，听众们。是的，抱歉。然后听完系列的其余部分，再回来听完这个访谈。
Something I wanted to ask you about, so in this episode we talked about, one of the chapters we talked about is Two Brothers, the story of Paul Moses and Robert Moses. And you are, you know, you're a very versatile writer, but you are, majority of your writing on television is sitcoms. I'm curious, how would you develop a sitcom about the rivalry between the two Moses brothers?
我有一件事想问你，在这集中我们谈到了，我们讨论的其中一个章节是《两兄弟》，也就是保罗·摩西（Paul Moses）和罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）的故事。而你，你知道的，你是一位非常全能的编剧，但你在电视领域的绝大部分作品都是情景喜剧。我很想知道，你会如何开发一部关于这两位摩西兄弟之间竞争的情景喜剧？
Is that basically just Frasier or is there a way to do that? Well, you know what it really is at some level is the, Succession kind of already did it. Like, when I was watching Succession, But what it really is at some level is the succession kind of already did it. When I was watching Succession, the James Cromwell character is, it's got a similar vibe I think to the James Cromwell, Brian Cox relationship. It's slightly different because James Cromwell is also like a billionaire, you know, but he broke a different way and he has this,
那基本上就是《欢乐一家亲》（Frasier）吗？还是有别的办法来拍这个？嗯，你知道它在某种程度上真正像的是什么吗？《继承之战》（Succession）其实已经拍过类似的了。看《继承之战》的时候，但它在某种程度上真正像的是什么呢，《继承之战》其实已经拍过类似的了。我在看《继承之战》时，詹姆斯·克伦威尔（James Cromwell）饰演的角色，我觉得和詹姆斯·克伦威尔与布莱恩·考克斯（Brian Cox）的关系有着相似的氛围。它略有不同，因为詹姆斯·克伦威尔也是个亿万富翁，你知道的，但他走了一条不同的路，他有这样一种，
and in that version, Cromwell was, his character was 100% convinced that his brother was just a terrible, evil demon, right? Like it was, it's not, the relationship of the book is very different. The relationship of the book is more heartbreaking because Moses just essentially ignores his brother. His brother's living in poverty.
而且在那个版本中，克伦威尔的——他的角色100%确信他的兄弟是个可怕的、邪恶的恶魔，对吧？就像是，书中两人的关系非常不同。书中的关系更让人心碎，因为摩西基本上就是无视他的兄弟。他的兄弟生活在贫困之中。
And Moses could, Carol makes it clear, at any moment, give him any number of hundreds of thousands of different jobs that he controlled to lift him out of poverty and just didn't because of his vindictiveness and his acid and everything else. So it's not, you know, Cromwell in succession was also because he was a part of the family, this titanic family was like a billionaire. But the way in which those two brothers just a rift formed that was unhealable and the differences in the way that they approached the world
而卡罗写得很清楚，摩西随时都可以给他成百上千个由他掌控的各种职位，从而将他从贫困中解救出来，但他就是不给，出于他的记仇、他的刻薄以及其他一切原因。所以它不是——你知道的，《继承之战》里的克伦威尔，也因为他是这个家族的一部分，这个庞大的家族就像个亿万富翁一样。但那两兄弟之间撕裂出一条无法愈合的鸿沟的方式，以及他们对待世界的方式的不同，
had a like, reminded me of the book a lot, like at different times and they didn't pull their punches, you know, in succession. Again, spoiler alert if you haven't watched Succession. But when it gets all the way to Brian Cox's character's funeral and Cromwell just is like, I'm going to speak at this funeral. And what you expect, because we're so trained for this, is that there would be like a little bit of a like, there are moments where I, you know, regret the way that we grew up or we treated each other. And you get like one tiny fleck of that
在不同的时候让我想起了这本书，而且他们在《继承之战》里也是毫不留情，你知道的。再次发出剧透警告，如果你还没看过《继承之战》。但当剧情一直推进到布莱恩·考克斯饰演的角色的葬礼，而克伦威尔直接说：我要在这个葬礼上发言。而由于我们被训练成习惯于此，你所期待的是，会有一种类似这样的时刻：有时候我会，你知道的，后悔我们长大的方式，或者我们对待彼此的方式。你会在悼词里听到一丝那样的痕迹，
in the eulogy that I remember. But mostly it's Cromwell going like, my brother was an asshole. He was a terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, one tiny fleck of that in the eulogy that I remember. But mostly it's Cromwell going like, my brother was an asshole. He was a terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible, terrible person. And it's so shocking, but it's like, yeah, that's the truth of these relationships sometimes
我记得的悼词里有那么一点点。但大多数时候，是克伦威尔在说：我兄弟是个混蛋。他是个可怕的、可怕的、可怕的、可怕的、可怕的、可怕的人——悼词里有那么一点点。但大多数时候，是克伦威尔在说：我兄弟是个混蛋。他是个可怕的、可怕的、可怕的、可怕的、可怕的、可怕的人。这太令人震惊了，但就像是，是的，这有时才是这些关系的真相：
is like, just because you're brothers, it doesn't mean that when one of you dies, it's all, everything, wounds are healed. Like Moses was so awful to his brother in so many ways that I can't imagine if Paul spoke at his funeral that he would have been like, you know, he wasn't a bad guy. He was all right.
仅仅因为你们是兄弟，并不意味着当你们其中一人死去时，一切都会过去，伤口都会愈合。摩西在很多方面对他的兄弟都太糟糕了，以至于我无法想象如果保罗在摩西的葬礼上发言，他会说：你知道的，他其实不是个坏人。他挺好的。
We had our differences, but look at those bridges, you know? I've thought of, of course, as I work in TV, I've thought so many times about like, can you ever film this, right? Like it's the greatest story ever told about America. Could you ever film it? The conclusion I've come to is no, you could not, because you would need 50 hours.
我们虽然有分歧，但看看那些桥梁，你知道吗？我当然思考过，由于我在电视行业工作，我曾多次思考过：你究竟能不能把它拍成影视剧，对吧？就像它是关于美国最伟大的故事。你能不能把它拍出来？我得出的结论是：不能，你做不到。因为你需要50个小时。
You would need 50 hours of drama and you would need an actor who could play both an 18-year- old and a 79 year old somehow or you'd have to do that thing where you cast different actors who kind of look like each other to play these different eras or whatever. I mean, like the Crown did it, maybe it's possible, but it's, it's one of those, um, if like, if you
你需要50个小时的剧长，而且你需要一个既能演18岁又能演79岁老人的演员，或者你得采用那种选定长相相似的不同演员来饰演不同时代等类似的做法。我的意思是，《王冠》（The Crown）就是这么做的，也许这是有可能的，但这是那种——如果你
could snap your fingers and have the version of a crown-like show about Robert Moses, it would be the greatest filmed story ever told. There's no more compelling portrait of an American than that book. I mean, we've been talking about the book as this great novel, as this Dickensian, Shakespearean, all that sort of stuff, but it's also this great ethical case study.
能够打个响指，就能拥有一部像《王冠》那样关于罗伯特·摩西的剧集，那将是有史以来最伟大的影视故事。再没有比那本书更引人入胜的美国人物肖像了。我的意思是，我们一直把这本书当作伟大的小说、狄更斯式、莎士比亚式等等诸如此类的作品来谈论，但它同时也是一个伟大的道德案例研究。
And you wrote a book on moral philosophy. And I wonder about that. What Caro is setting up is Robert Moses' values that inform his sort of utilitarian calculation for a greater good are being questioned by Caro because he has extremely different values, you know, about what the greater good is. And, you know, when you, how do you look at the book as, you know, someone who's thought about,
而你写过一本关于道德哲学的书。我对此很好奇。卡罗所设定的罗伯特·摩西的价值观——正是这些价值观支撑了他为了追求“更大利益”而进行的功利主义计算——却遭到了卡罗的质疑，因为卡罗对于什么是“更大利益”有着截然不同的价值观。而且，你知道的，当你——作为一个思考过、
wrote about, did a show about moral philosophy? It's an incredible case study for a number of different issues, I would say, that pop up in moral philosophy. The first and most obvious to me is what I would sort of broadly call the danger of the shifting Overton window, right?
写过、制作过关于道德哲学的节目的人——如何看待这本书？我想说，对于道德哲学中浮现的许多不同议题来说，这是一个不可思议的案例研究。对我而言，最直接也最显而易见的第一点，就是我愿意广义上称之为“正在发生位移的奥弗顿窗口（Overton Window）的危险”，对吧？
Like what, what you find, I wrote about this in the book I wrote, there's a danger in violating any moral principle that you hold in even the slightest way. And the danger to me is that once you do that, your Overton window for what you personally find permissible, ethically speaking, shifts a tiny bit, right? So you normally don't park in a handicap parking spot,
比如，你在书中写过，你发现了什么，违反自己所持有的任何道德原则，哪怕只有一点点，也是有危险的。在我看来，危险在于一旦你这么做了，你个人对伦理上什么是可以接受的“奥弗顿窗口”就会发生微小的偏移，对吧？所以你通常不会把车停在残疾人车位上，
but today you do because you're in a rush and nothing bad happens. And so the next time that you're driving around, you see like there's a fire lane that you could park in. And you're again in a rush. And so you're like, well, the last time I parked in the handicap spot and nothing bad happened. So this is fine, I'll just do this.
但今天你停了，因为你赶时间，而且也没有发生什么坏事。所以下次你开车到处转的时候，你发现有个消防通道你可以把车停进去。而且你又赶时间了。于是你会想，嗯，上次我停在残疾人车位上也没出什么事。所以这没关系，我就这么停吧。
And then nothing bad happens. Then you're like, you ding someone's mirror when you're pulling into your next parking space, and it's like a tiny little chip of paint, and you're like, well, this isn't that much worse than parking in a handicap spot or a fire lane. And so I'm just going to drive away. Whatever, cars get banged up. It's fine. And like, you know, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, the Overton window just shifts a little bit more and a little bit more,
结果也没发生什么坏事。然后你会想，当你把车开进下一个停车位时，你擦到了别人的后视镜，那就像是一小块掉落的油漆，你会想，嗯，这其实不比把车停在残疾人车位或消防通道上糟糕多少。所以我还是直接开走吧。管他呢，车嘛总会有磕磕碰碰的。没关系。就像，你知道的，叮、叮、叮、叮、叮，奥弗顿窗口又进一步发生了偏移，再偏移，
and soon, you know, you're a serial killer. That's the, that's the, that's the end of the story. We've seen it so many times. Yeah, we have, right? But no, you're not a serial killer, but you're a person who has now deemed it permissible for you to do certain things and then certain things that crop up that are only slightly worse than the thing that you are okay with and it just snowballs right? And the problem obviously with thinking this way is that no one likes a rules nerd and I know that because I'm a rules nerd and no one likes me and so you don't want
很快，你知道的，你就成了一个连环杀手。这就是，这就是，这就是故事的结局。我们看过太多次了。是的，我们确实看过，对吧？但不对，你不是连环杀手，但你成了这样一个人：你现在认为自己可以做某些特定的事情，然后当一些只比你原本能接受的事情稍微糟糕一点的新事情出现时，事情就像滚雪球一样发展了，对吧？显然，这种想法的问题在于，没有人喜欢规则书呆子，我知道这一点，因为我就是一个规则书呆子，没有人喜欢我，所以你不会想
to be the kind of person who never does anything even never jaywalks or never, you know, it's like, that's not a way to live either. So the trick, and this is what I wrote about, the trick is in those moments where we have to do things, small things that aren't quite, you know, aren't quite right, or you know, are bending the rules a little bit, which we all do, the trick isn't never do them. The trick is when you do them, just note it in your brain. Just be like, you know, I should make a habit of this, right?
成为那种从不做任何事、甚至从不乱穿马路或从不，你知道的，就好像，那也不是一种生活方式。所以秘诀在于——这也是我写过的——秘诀在于，当我们不得不做一些事情的时候，那些不太对劲的小事，你知道的，或者说稍微有点破坏规则的小事（我们都会这么做），秘诀不是永远不做。秘诀是当你做了之后，在脑子里记下来。就好像，你知道的，我不应该把这变成习惯，对吧？
Like, this is not quite 100% in line with my personal ethical code and I'm not gonna make a habit of this and I'm not gonna justify more severe transgressions by saying, well, I did that other thing and that was okay, so I'll do this now. And Moses's trajectory was so granular, you know, it was so, and that's again why the book is 1100 pages long. It's like the piece by piece, bit by bit, he goes from a guy who is a pure idealist reformer into the most corrupt person
就像，这并不完全符合我个人的道德准则，我不会把这变成习惯，我也不会通过说“反正我做了另一件事，那件事没事，所以我现在也可以做这个”来为更严重的越轨行为辩解。而且摩西的人生轨迹非常具体，你知道的，非常……这也就是为什么这本书有1100页长。这就好比他通过一点一滴、一步一步的过程，从一个纯粹的理想主义改革家，变成了
who's ever been a part of any government, which is saying a lot in this country. And you can read the whole book as just a continual slide of his personal Overton window, from idealist reformer to completely corrupt lunatic. And those moments where he does something, he pulls a lever of power, it works out for him. He gets what he wants. And then the next time he pulls two levers of
任何政府中有史以来最腐败的人，在这个国家这可真算是个了不得的评价。你可以把整本书看作是他个人的奥弗顿窗口不断下滑的过程，从理想主义改革家沦为彻底腐败的疯子。在他做某些事情的那些时刻，他拉动了权力的杠杆，这对他很管用。他得到了他想要的。然后下一次，他拉动了两个权力的
power and gets what he wants even more, they're laid out so perfectly and so completely that you can just watch in real time. It's a slow motion train wreck of a guy moving from one kind of person to another kind of person. So that's, to me, that's a slow motion train wreck of a guy moving from one kind of person to another kind of person. So that's, to me, that's the biggest sort of philosophical or ethical story of the book.
杠杆，得到了更多他想要的东西，这一切布局如此完美、如此彻底，以至于你可以实时观看。这是一个家伙从一种人变成另一种人的慢动作列车失事过程。所以，对我来说，这就是一个家伙从一种人变成另一种人的慢动作列车失事过程。所以，对我来说，这就是这本书最大的哲学或伦理学故事。
The other one is, is that again, no one likes Kant because Kant is too rigid to actually be helpful in the world. You know, like, like you can't lie ever, you can't ever, you can't, he would say you can't ever jaywalk because jaywalking, you know, like, you can't lie ever. You can't ever, you can't, he would say you can't ever jaywalk because jaywalking, you know, jaywalking isn't allowable. And if everybody jaywalked, then the world would be chaos.
另一个是，再次说明，没有人喜欢康德，因为康德太死板了，在现实世界中根本没用。你知道的，比如，你绝对不能撒谎，你绝对不能，你绝对不能……他会说你绝对不能乱穿马路，因为乱穿马路，你知道的，比如，你绝对不能撒谎。你绝对不能，你绝对不能……他会说你绝对不能乱穿马路，因为乱穿马路，你知道的，乱穿马路是不被允许的。如果每个人都乱穿马路，那世界就会陷入混乱。
So he'll never let you jaywalk. And if it's like 120 degrees and you need to go to CVS and the light is taking a long time and there's no cars coming, you can jaywalk. It's fine, just jaywalk. It's okay, you know? But what Kant would say is that he was following essentially a pretty strict moral code in terms of
所以他绝对不会让你乱穿马路。但如果气温高达120华氏度，你需要去CVS药店，而红绿灯要等很久，又没有车过来，你完全可以乱穿马路。没关系，乱穿马路就行了。这没问题，你知道的？但康德会说，他在如何处理事情方面，
how he was trying to go about his business. And then he gets to a point where, you know, he's crushed by the levers of power and the gears grind him up and spit him out. And he basically, in that moment just flips. He flips from a pure Kantian to a pure utilitarian. And says like, if this, if I can justify what I'm doing for the greater good, if, if what I'm doing, even though it's seems like it's a little iffy, if it
基本上遵循了相当严格的道德准则。然后他到了一个地步，你知道的，他被权力的杠杆碾碎，被齿轮嚼碎并吐了出来。基本上，就在那一刻，他彻底转变了。他从一个纯粹的康德主义者变成了一个纯粹的功利主义者。并且说，如果这个……如果为了更大的利益，我能为自己的行为辩解，如果……如果我做的事，尽管看起来有点可疑，但如果它
gets people to Jones beach and they can swim, then it's worth it. And it doesn't matter what I did. That's irrelevant. What matters is the result. people to Jones beach and they can swim, then it's worth it. And it doesn't matter what I did. That's irrelevant. What matters is the result. And when you combine that shifting personal overton window with a flip from Kantian ethics to utilitarian
能让人去琼斯海滩游泳，那这就值得了。我做了什么并不重要。那无关紧要。重要的是结果。……能让人去琼斯海滩游泳，那这就值得了。我做了什么并不重要。那无关紧要。重要的是结果。当你把这种不断变动的个人奥弗顿窗口与从康德伦理学到功利主义
ethics and utilitarian ethics are the most easily justified ethics in the world, because it doesn't matter, you can murder a busload of nuns, but if it helps, you know, if it helps like 50 more people than there were nuns have a certain amount of happiness that, you know, that overtakes the amount of sadness you caused to the nuns and their families, then you're fine.
伦理学的转变结合起来时——功利主义伦理学是世界上最容易为自己辩解的伦理学，因为这无所谓，你可以谋杀一车厢的修女，但如果它有助益，你知道的，如果它能让比修女多50倍的人获得一定程度的幸福，而这种幸福超过了你给修女及其家属带来的悲伤，那你这就没问题。
And so he just found a haven in this really corrupted view of utilitarian ends justify the means, you know, power. And it's the greatest cautionary tale maybe ever of why a corrupt version of utilitarianism is a bad idea because he justified everything he did essentially by saying it's good for the people, it's good for the people, it's good for the people. Long after the things he was doing stopped being good
所以他只是在这种对功利主义“目的为手段辩解”的严重腐败观点中找到一个避难所，你知道的，也就是权力。这或许是有史以来最伟大的警世故事，告诉你为什么功利主义的腐败版本是个坏主意，因为他基本上通过声称“这对人民有好处，这对人民有好处，这对人民有好处”来为他所做的一切辩解。而这时候，他做的事情早就已经不再对
for the people that he was supposed to be helping. Yeah, yeah. I think it's so amazing that Robert Carroll identifies the moment that the Overton window shifts in taking the sort of deal with AutoCon. And he knows that's the moment. And he knows that Robert Moses is sensitive to that moment because maybe even Robert Moses knows that that's the moment
他本该帮助的人民有好处了。对，对。我觉得罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）指出奥弗顿窗口在与奥托·卡恩（Otto Kahn）做交易时发生偏移的那个时刻，真是太精彩了。他知道那就是那个时刻。而且他知道罗伯特·摩西对那个时刻很敏感，因为也许连罗伯特·摩西自己也知道那就是
that he began to shift his Overton window. Well, I heard you talk about this in an earlier podcast, um, but the primary attitude, I think that Caro adopts is that power doesn't corrupt, it reveals. And I think that what is so great about that moment is what he has set up for you is a guy who was waiting, kind of waiting all his life for that moment to be presented to him. Right. It's like, he was a guy who was waiting, kind of waiting all his life for that moment to be presented to him.
他开始转移奥弗顿窗口的时刻。嗯，我听你在之前的播客里谈过这个，嗯，但我认为卡罗采取的核心态度是：权力不会腐蚀人，它只会显露人的本性。我认为那个时刻之所以如此伟大，是因为他为你塑造了一个一直在等待、某种程度上可以说一生都在等待那个时刻降临到自己身上的家伙。没错。这就好比，他是一个一直等待、某种程度上可以说一生都在等待那个时刻展现给自己的家伙。
Right? It's like, he was a guy who was like, he had these goals. He had this idea in his head of how to, to achieve them. He was wrong. Someone else was like, this is how you achieve them. And he was like, great, then I'll do that. And, you know, you're, you're talking about a guy who, you know, lest we think that he was actually a good person who was corrupted by power. You're talking about a guy who didn't only believe that all cities should be planned and all city planning should be executed by only
对吧？这就好比，他是一个这样的人：他有这些目标。他的脑海里有关于如何实现这些目标的想法。他错了。另一个人则说：“这才是你实现目标的方法。”而他当时想：“太好了，那我就这么做。”而且，你知道的，你正在谈论的这个人，为了防止我们以为他其实是个被权力腐蚀的好人——你谈论的这个人，他不仅认为所有的城市都应该规划，而且所有的城市规划都应该只由
Ivy league graduates. He thought they should only be planned and executed by people from Harvard, Yale or Princeton, like, like screw you Columbia. Like not, not good enough to build our cities. Sorry, Brown. Nice try. Good riddance Cornell grads.
常春藤盟校毕业生来执行。他认为它们应该只由哈佛、耶鲁或普林斯顿的人来规划和执行，比如，去你的哥伦比亚大学。比如，不够资格来建设我们的城市。对不起，布朗大学。算了吧。滚开吧，康奈尔的毕业生。
Like he was so, he was such an inveterate snob and so elitist that the, the, the actual disconnect when you read the book, to me, is his combination of extreme elitism and his initial stance on sort of idealistic populism. That's the part of the character that doesn't make sense to me. The part of it that gets corrupted by the deal with Otto Kahn
就像他是个如此根深蒂固的势利眼和精英主义者，以至于当你读这本书时，真正的脱节感，在我看来，是他极端精英主义的组合与他最初那种带有理想主义民粹主义立场的结合。那是这个角色中让我觉得说不通的部分。那部分因与奥托·卡恩的交易而遭到腐蚀，
and then executes his miserable plan of running roughsh shot over rules and regulations and the public for 40 years. That makes sense. That's the part that seems like, yes, this lines up with the guy that we learned about at Yale and the guy who had this absurd view of how it was that cities should be run. And so when that deal happens, what it actually feels like is the gears were not meshing properly until then for him. And then once the deal happens, it's like, yeah, click, click, click. Now everything is working the way it was supposed to for him. Yeah.
然后执行了他那持续40年对规则、规章制度以及公众横行霸道的可悲计划。这倒是说得通。这部分看起来确实是：是的，这与我们在耶鲁了解到的那个家伙，以及那个对城市应该如何管理有着荒谬看法的家伙是一致的。所以当那笔交易发生时，实际的感觉是，在此之前齿轮一直没有为他妥善咬合。而一旦交易达成，就好像，是的，咔哒、咔哒、咔哒。现在一切都按原计划为他顺利运转了。对。
Well, I think that what I could use to explain Robert Moses' delusion in his younger years is that, you know, he thought that these sort of masters of the universe should be anointed masters of the universe out of merit. And then he ran into reality and he realized that there was no merit. And so he just had to use the old systems
嗯，我认为可以用这个来解释罗伯特·摩西年轻时的妄想：你知道的，他认为这些所谓的宇宙大师应该凭实力被膏立为宇宙大师。然后他撞上了现实，他意识到根本没有什么实力。所以他只能利用旧系统
to get things done. Totally. A hundred percent. And that's why Al Smith is again, this confluence of events. Al Smith, essentially an illiterate man who did not, by the way, go to Harvard, Yale, or Princeton, right?
来把事情办成。完全正确，百分之百。这就是为什么阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）——这又是一次事件的交汇。阿尔·史密斯，一个基本上目不识丁的人，顺便说一句，他可没有上过哈佛、耶鲁或普林斯顿，对吧？
Like, I think Moses met him and was like, wait, this son of a bitch is the guy who has all the power in the city? Like, how is that possible? I'm six, four and devilishly handsome and Ivy league educated. And I wrote a thesis on civic planning and like, how is Al Smith running rings around me?
就像，我猜摩西见到他时一定会想：等等，这个王八蛋就是拥有城里所有权力的人？这怎么可能？我身高六尺四，英俊得邪门，还是常春藤盟校毕业的。我还写过一篇关于城市规划的论文，怎么阿尔·史密斯能把我耍得团团转？
And so it shattered his worldview that like, because you are born into the right kind of family, look a certain way or educated in a certain place that you shall be granted from on high, the ability to just do whatever you want to do. He learned that lesson from a slovenly, functionally illiterate guy who was just very
所以这粉碎了他的世界观：他认为因为你出生在正确的家庭，长着一副特定面孔，或者在某个特定的地方接受教育，你就理所当然地应该从天而降获得随心所欲做任何你想做的事的能力。他从一个邋遢的、基本功能性文盲的家伙身上吸取了这一教训，那个家伙只是非常
charming and had figured out how to consolidate power. And that was, it was incredibly revealing for him, obviously. It was like this, if this, if this jackass who, who didn't even go to college can be just knocking me off my game so easily, then there, then I haven't actually learned how to achieve
迷人，并且已经搞清楚了如何巩固权力。显然，这对他来说极具启发性。就好像如果这个连大学都没上过的笨蛋都能如此轻易地把我打乱阵脚，那么，
what I need to achieve. Yeah, that's right. That's right. That's totally right. And he also learns that this idea of like the tools to use that is, is how to learn laws and how to write laws. And he learns the skill through Al Smith.
我实际上根本还没学会如何实现我需要实现的目标。对，没错。完全正确。这绝对没错。而且他还了解到，这种使用的工具——也就是如何了解法律以及如何编写法律——正是他通过阿尔·史密斯学到的技能。
And I find that to be stunning. I just love that. Oh, the details of him burying and footnotes, all of those little like, you know, we're going to use the definition of this thing as laid out in the 1812 law that says this thing, which allows this commission to be set up. I mean, it's very damning because I don't think, this is one way in which the world,
我觉得这太惊人了。我太喜欢这个了。哦，关于他在脚注里埋藏细节的那些事，所有这些微小的细节，你知道的，“我们要利用1812年法律中对这个事物的定义来阐述，该法律规定了这一事项，从而允许成立这个委员会”。我的意思是，这非常具有定罪性，因为我不认为……这是世界在某种程度上
I think, is very similar, right? You learn all the time about these omnibus spending bills that are passed in Congress, and they're given to people to read with like 48 hours before the vote. There's handwritten notes just thrown into the margins and things crossed out or whatever and you see the politicians in the minority parties say like we're having a vote on this tomorrow and it's 6,000 pages long and no one's read it and then it just passes and you're like all right whatever is in that bill is now the law of the land. And money is being thrown around and wasted and given
非常相似的地方，对吧？你经常听说国会通过的这些综合支出法案，它们在投票前大约48小时才发给人们阅读。手写的笔记直接写在空白处，有些东西被划掉什么的，然后你会看到少数党派的政客说：我们明天就要对这个进行投票，它有6000页长，根本没人读过，然后它就通过了。接着你会想：好吧，那法案里不管是什么现在都成了国家的法律。金钱被到处抛洒、浪费，随意发给
out to people left and right that we have no, there's no accountability for. And when you read how Albany functioned back in that time, and you realize that the, all of the people in the Tammany hall world are just, they're just out getting drunk. They don't read the bills are just, they're just out getting drunk. They don't read the bills and him realizing they don't read the bills. And if I learn how to do this, I can do anything I want because it becomes the
人们，而我们对此没有任何问责制。当你阅读奥尔巴尼当时是如何运作的，你就会意识到，坦慕尼协会（Tammany Hall）世界里的所有人，他们当时都在外面喝得酩酊大醉。他们根本不读法案，他们只是在外面喝得酩酊大醉。他们不读法案。而他意识到他们不读法案。如果我学会了怎么做这个，我想做什么就能做什么，因为它会变成
law. It's just such an amazing, like a, it's such an amazing lesson to learn and be right about, and it's probably still right today. It's such, it's such classic, classic, I keep bringing it back to stories, I apologize. It's such classic kind of like fantasy or martial arts storytelling where it's like, oh, okay, I want to learn how to be the greatest fighter in the world. Well, you're going to have to carry this bucket to that well and back again, a hundred times a day, every day.
法律。这真是一个惊人的……这真是让人学到惊人的一课，而且事实证明他是对的，而且直到今天可能依然是对的。这真是，这真是太经典、太经典的……我总是把它扯回故事上来，非常抱歉。这就像是那种非常经典的神话或武侠故事，剧情是这样的：“哦，好的，我想成为世界上最伟大的武术家。”“好吧，你每天都得把这桶水提到那个井边再提回来，一天一百次。”
I can't believe I'm doing it. Wait a minute. These are the motions I need. So it's almost like he walks in and he's like, of course I'm gonna run the world, but it turns out he's gonna have to read every bill so we can learn this arcane, you know, magic language of the law. And then suddenly he's, yeah, suddenly he's Neo
“我真不敢相信我在做这个。等等。这就是我需要的动作吗？”所以这几乎就像他走进去时想的：“我当然要统治世界”，但结果证明他必须阅读每一项法案，这样他才能学会这种晦涩的、你知道的，法律的魔法语言。然后突然之间，他……是的，突然之间他成了《黑客帝国》里的尼奥，
in the matrix and he can see the code and no one else can see it. And he's dodging bullets. It's the really slow and boring version of getting that, Neo getting that thing plugged into the back of his head and then saying, I know Kung Fu. It's that, but it takes like four years and it involves reading a billion really boring bills from legislators.
他能看到代码，而其他人看不到。他还能躲避子弹。这就是尼奥脑子里被插进那个东西然后说“我会功夫”的那个情节的超级缓慢、无聊的版本。就是那个，只不过花了大约四年时间，并且需要阅读来自立法者的十亿份极其无聊的法案。
It's the real life version of it. The way that like, you know, if you want to be a, if you want to be a holy man, you have to go sit on a mountain and just think for nonstop for years. And it's like, that's a lot of work. I guess, maybe I don't want to be holy that badly, but Moses wants to be in control that badly. He's like, I'll do it. And Al Smith too.
这是现实生活中的版本。就像，你知道的，如果你想成为一个圣人，你必须去山上一边坐着一边不停地思考好几年。这就好像，这活儿可真多。我想，也许我没那么渴望成圣吧。但摩西对控制欲的渴望有那么强烈。他会说：“我来做。”阿尔·史密斯也是。
I'll do it. I'm going to put the work in. And it's such a, if this was a different kind of book, if Carol was more on Moses' side, this could be a book about how kids, if you put the work in, if you strive and you work harder than everybody else, you get to the top of the heap. And that's kind of buried in there. But unfortunately, usually in those stories, the person does the work and then they're a good person. And that's not exactly the case in real life or in the book.
“我来做。我要付出努力。”而且这真是……如果这是一本不同类型的书，如果卡罗更多地站在摩西这边，这可能会是一本关于“孩子们，如果你付出努力，如果你奋斗，如果你比其他所有人都更努力地工作，你就能爬到金字塔尖”的书。这其中其实包含着这个主题。但不幸的是，通常在那些故事里，主人公付出了努力，然后他成为了一个好人。而在现实生活中或书中，情况并非完全如此。
I want to read that version of the book now where it's like, Hey kids, you want to, you want to become powerful and, and do good things. Like follow, like that's Robert Moses' self appointed biographer. Like that's his spin on it is like, it's the story of a noble man who did the work and reap the rewards. Like that's an amazing version of the power broker.
我现在就想读那种版本的书，书里写着：“嘿，孩子们，你们想变得强大并做好事吗？那就效仿……”这就好像是罗伯特·摩西自封的传记作家一样。这就是他对这件事的粉饰：这是一个高尚的人，他付出了努力并收获了回报。这简直是《权力的经纪人》的一个绝妙版本。
I'd love to read that. I mean, the funny thing is, is that story was written for decades in the newspaper. Right? Yes, that's true. And he began to believe that in his own way and when somebody interrogates it even slightly and they go, what about that brother Paul? He's like, I don't know, I never had a brother Paul. You know?
我很想读那一版。我的趣点在于，这个故事在报纸上连载了几十年。没错，确实如此。他开始以自己的方式相信这一点，而当有人哪怕稍微对这一点提出质疑并说：“那个叫保罗的兄弟是怎么回事？”他会说：“我不知道，我从来没有什么叫保罗的兄弟。”你知道吗？
Like. There has to be, in that over tin window moral choice mindset, there has to be a in that over tin window, moral choice mindset, there has to be a moment where you say, if I'm telling the world my brother doesn't exist, maybe I'm doing the wrong thing here. Maybe if I'm denying the existence of my closest sibling,
就像……在那个奥弗顿窗口式的道德选择心态中，必然会有……在那个奥弗顿窗口式的道德选择心态中，必然会有一个时刻，你会对自己说：“如果我正在向世界宣告我的兄弟并不存在，也许我在这里做错了事。也许如果我在否认我最亲近的兄弟的存在，
maybe I'm not the good guy at the moment. Or maybe I am, I don't know. The unknowable thing, right, that is never to be known, is to what degree, if any, those thoughts pass through Moses' brain, right? Did he ever, did he ever, did he have a single pang of regret or sadness or did he feel like, ah, I don't know,
也许我此刻并不是个好人。”或者也许我是个好人，我不知道。那件不可知的事，对吧，永远无从得知的是，这些想法在多大程度上（如果有的话）曾在摩西的脑海中闪过，对吧？他可曾有过哪怕一丁点的后悔、悲伤，或者他是否曾感觉：啊，我不知道，
maybe this isn't so great? Like all of the times that he wanted to build something. And a group of people came to him and said, if you just do this three blocks to the South, that you will destroy a bunch of abandoned buildings and you won't destroy this neighborhood and you won't displace these people and he ignored them. And then all the people were displaced. And he said, and he would say to the press, they're all being given housing and none of them were being given housing and none of them were being given housing and they were driven from their
也许这其实并没有那么好？就像所有那些他想要建造某样东西的时候。有一群人来到他面前对他说：“如果你只是把这个往南挪三个街区，你就会摧毁一堆废弃的建筑，而不会摧毁这个街区，也不会让这些人流离失所。”而他却无视了他们。然后所有这些人都流离失所了。接着他对媒体说，他们全都得到了住房——而实际上根本没有人得到住房，根本没有人得到住房，他们被赶出了自己的
house, like home, families ruin, neighborhoods ruin. In all of those moments, was there ever a moment where he thought to himself like, oh, this isn't great. And it sure doesn't seem like it wasn't. It doesn't seem like it at all. No, it doesn't. And I just can't imagine what you're thinking about when you're swimming all those laps, except for that.
房子，就像家园被毁，家庭破碎，街区被毁。在所有这些时刻，可曾有过哪怕一个瞬间，他心里想过：哦，这可真不妙。而且看起来他真的从没这么想过。一点也没有。不，确实没有。我简直无法想象当你在游进那么多圈时，脑子里除了这个还能想些什么。
Like that's what's always on my mind at all times. And him, it's just building bridges. And to me is, did I accidentally upset that person in junior high? You know? Yeah. I imagine when Moses is in the shower, he's not thinking about what are all the mistakes
就像，这永远是我脑子里时刻在想的事情。而对于他来说，脑子里只有建桥。对我而言则是：我是不是不小心惹初中的那个人生气了？你知道吗？是的。我猜摩西在冲澡的时候，绝对不会去想他在年轻时犯下的所有错误
that I made when I was young. And instead it's, how do I get this thing done? How do I get that? And I wonder if there's an aspect of it, of his psychology that is like Mayor Bloomberg's vision of New York, that I have to keep moving, I have to keep building or I stop. And if I stop, I think, and I can't think. I've got to keep thinking about the next project because I can't think about my life or what I've done. And I doubt he was conscious enough of those things or cared enough, but it does feel like when he's swimming, you know, I certainly, I don't like swimming partly for the reason that my mind wanders to embarrassments in the past or things like that.
是什么，相反，他想的是：我怎么才能把这事办成？我怎么才能搞定那个？我在想，他的心理中是不是有一种类似于布隆伯格市长（Mayor Bloomberg）对纽约的愿景，那就是：我必须不断前进，我必须不断建设，否则我就会停下来。如果我停下来，我就会思考，而我却不能思考。我必须一直想着下一个项目，因为我不能思考我的人生或我做过的事。我怀疑他是否有足够的意识去察觉这些事情，或者是否在乎这些，但确实感觉当他在游泳时，你知道的，我个人其实不太喜欢游泳，部分原因就是我的思绪会飘回到过去的尴尬经历或诸如此类的事情上。
But I'm sure he's just thinking about, okay, if I can put this bond across at that percentage rate, then I can get the money from the federal government to get the labor. And then I can build this bridge across. It seems like his mind is just always going at these problems. Yeah. Like I went in, I don't know, 1993, I was getting on a plane and the woman at the counter helped me change my seat and she gave me my ticket and she said, have a nice flight and I said, you too. And then I walked on the plane and I was like,
但我敢肯定他当时只是在想：好吧，如果我能以那个百分比发行这笔债券，我就可以从联邦政府那里拿到钱来雇佣劳动力。然后我就可以把这座桥建过去。感觉他的脑子里总是全神贯注于这些问题。对。就像我在，我不知道，1993年的时候，我正要登机，柜台的那位女士帮我换了座位，她把机票交给我并说：“祝您飞行愉快。”我说：“你也是。”然后我走上飞机心想：
she's not flying anywhere, why didn't I say you too? And that was 32 years ago and I haven't stopped thinking about it. I think about it once a month. You know, like, just like, that was so weird. Why did I do that? Why did I say you too to a woman who wasn't flying anywhere? And that it's like, there's,
她又不出差，我为什么跟她说“你也是”？那是32年前的事了，我至今还没停止思考这件事。我差不多每个月都会想一次。你知道的，就像：这太奇怪了。我为什么那么做？我为什么会对一个根本不出差的女人说“你也是”？而这就像是，
and it's something essentially human about reflecting on your own foibles and like mistakes and small goofs and gaffs and, and certainly more serious things. Times that you offended someone, hurt someone, broke up with someone in a crappy way and, and made their lives miserable or anything like you, that stuff haunts us and it should haunt us. It's probably evolutionarily beneficial that it haunts us
这是人类本质中不可或缺的一部分，那就是反思你自己的缺点、小失误、小洋相，当然还有更严重的事情。比如你曾经冒犯过某人、伤害过某人、以一种糟糕的方式和某人分手，让他们的生活苦不堪言，或者诸如此类的事——这些事情一直困扰着我们，它们也本该困扰着我们。从进化论的角度来看，它们困扰着我们或许是有益的，
because it helps us correct our behavior or maybe do better the next time we're in a similar situation. And he, Moses, had apparently such a hardened kind of lizard brain, just to like a fight or flight guided brain that you get the sense that none of that, not only did it not haunt him, I don't think he ever would have seen any of those
因为这有助于我们纠正自己的行为，或者下次遇到类似情况时做得更好。而摩西，显然有着一副如此冷酷的、类似爬行动物的头脑，仅仅是由一种“战斗或逃跑”本能引导的大脑，以至于你会觉得所有这些事情——不仅没有困扰过他，我不认为他会把其中任何
things as mistakes or foibles or, or failures of character or anything. I think he, I think he just somehow had a constitution that allowed him to focus only on the future and like you're saying, and what else he could accomplish in his limited time on earth and had a true belief that everything he did was right and good and proper. And that's just not a mindset that I think most of us can access, thank God. I don't think we'd wanna,
事情视为错误、缺点、性格上的失败或别的什么。我觉得他，我觉得他不知怎么地拥有一种体质，让他能够只专注于未来，就像你说的，专注于他在人世间有限的时间里还能成就什么，并且坚信他所做的一切都是正确、美好和恰当的。感谢上帝，这绝不是我们大多数人都能具备的心态。我想我们也不会想要这种心态，
I would not want to access that kind of mindset. What kind of person do you become if you never, if there's no self-reflection? I think we know the answer is Robert Moses or a couple other people we could probably name in national politics, right? It's like that's the kind of person who never apologized, never admit you were wrong, never admit defeat, never focus on anything except the next thing you're going to do and be 100%
如果你从不反思，你会变成什么样的人？我想我们都知道答案，那就是罗伯特·摩西，或者其他几个我们能在国家政治中点得出名字的人，对吧？这就好比，那是那种从不道歉、从不承认自己错了、从不承认失败、从不把注意力放在除了接下来要做的事之外的任何事情上的人，而且百分之百
sure that that thing is right and good and proper. It's a very brutal way to go through life. And it seems like, and the, the, alongside that, if he does think about the past, he does seem very conscious of how other people have wronged him or things that he's mad about. And it's, it's like Richard Nixon, where he seems powered by just wanting to be like,
确信那件事是正确、美好和恰当的。这是一种非常残酷的生活方式。而且感觉，与此同时，如果他真的去回想过去，他似乎对别人是如何冤枉他的或者他生气的那些事情有着高度的意识。这就很像理查德·尼克松（Richard Nixon），他似乎纯粹是被一种渴望证明自己的动力所驱动，
I'll show them, I'll show them all. Like there's this, there's this spite that, that is just fueling him that is very very in the right person is real powerful. You can accomplish a lot if you, if you can harness that spite, you know? Yeah, no, look, dictators can accomplish more than democratically elected officials. Like that's, that's the, that's always been true. Like the, the pyramids were not voted on by the Egyptian public, you know? It's like that, that is the, that's why certain folks
“我会让他们好看，我会让所有人好看。”就像有这样一种怨恨在支撑着他，这种怨恨在对的人身上确实非常强大。如果你能驾驭这种怨恨，你可以成就很多事，你知道吗？对，没错，听着，独裁者能比民主选举产生的官员成就更多的事。这，一直都是真的。比如，埃及公众可没有对金字塔进行过投票表决，你知道的？这就好比，那就是，这就是为什么某些人
who have this mindset have dictator fantasies. That's why Trump is constantly praising world leaders who have dictatorial powers. It's because to him and to folks with this mindset, that is the ideal kind of methodology for a world leader. It's like you have all of the power, no one can challenge you, you do whatever you want, and you're convinced that what you do is the right thing to do. It's just completely antithetical to the American system of government, and it's why Moses worming his way up to that amount of power through non-elected positions is such a cautionary tale and such a
拥有这种心态的人会产生独裁幻想。这就是为什么特朗普经常赞美拥有独裁权力的世界领导人。因为对他和持有这种心态的人来说，那是世界领导人的理想方法论。这就好比你拥有全部权力，没有人能挑战你，你想做什么就做什么，并且你坚信你所做的事就是正确的事。这与美国的政府体制完全对立，这也是为什么摩西通过非选举职位一步步钻营到那种权力高度，会成为如此一个警世故事，以及对这样一个人的迷人写照——他可不是去竞选总统或州长，虽然他其实并不在乎。他早就已经找到了实现自己想做之事的方法。那就是通过立法和委员会，你知道的，当他达到权力巅峰时，他拥有一个
fascinating portrait of a person, not who ran for president or who ran for governor and didn't really care. He had already figured out the way to do what it was that he wanted to do. And it was through legislation and commissions and, you know, by the time he hit the peak of his power, he had a, a theater
只有他能去的剧院，还有各个行政区里满员编制的餐厅，尽管根据定义，你每顿饭其实只能吃一家餐厅，因为你只有一个人，而他甚至不需要通过参加任何选举就获得了所有这些独裁权力，这简直不可思议。好吧，跟
that only he could go to and restaurants and every burrow that were fully staffed, even though by definition you can really only eat at one restaurant per meal, uh, cause you're only one person and he achieved all of that dictatorial power without ever being elected to anything, which is just incredible. Well, it's been so much fun
你聊《权力的经纪人》真的太有趣了。我非常喜欢它融入了你工作的方方面面，而且你还读了三遍。你能来这里对我们来说绝对是一种真正的荣幸。所以非常感谢你加入我们的读书俱乐部。非常感谢你加入我们。我们真的非常感激。
talking to you about Power Broker. I love the fact that it's infused all these parts of your work and that you read it three times. It's just been a real pleasure for us to have you here. So thank you so much for joining us on the book club. Thanks so much for joining us. We really appreciate it.
这是有史以来写得最棒的书。我很高兴你们在做这个播客。我会收听每一集的，能来到这里真的是一种真正的荣幸。所以谢谢你们邀请我。以上就是本月的“权力的经纪人”全部内容。下个月，我们将涵盖第27章到第32章。我们在这些章节里进展神速。这一集只有两章，下一集会有很多。我们将完成第五部分，并开始第六部分“对权力的渴望”。在我手头的书里，这是第607页到第702页。如果你只是想在
It's the greatest book ever written. I'm so glad you're doing this podcast. I will be listening to every episode and it's been a real pleasure to be here. So thank you for having me on. That's all for this month, Power Brokers. Next month, we're going to cover chapters 27 through 32. We're really burning through the chapters there. Only two this episode, so many next episode. We'll be finishing part five and starting part six, The Lust for Power. It's pages 607 through 702 in my copy of the book. If you just need to hear my mellifluous voice sometime between
现在到下个月之间的某个时候听到我甜美的声音，请收听《烂片播客》（The Flophouse Podcast）。这是我的烂片播客节目。我和丹·麦考伊（Dan McCoy）和斯图尔特·惠灵顿（Stuart Wellington）共同主持。它和这个严肃的文学和教育播客一样愚蠢且缺乏信息量。如果你有嘉宾点子，或者只是想和其他“权力的经纪人”粉丝继续交流，请前往我们的Discord加入讨论，链接在我们的网站上，你也可以访问 discord.gg/99pi。再次感谢本（Ben）建议邀请迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）作为嘉宾。
now and next month, then please listen to the Flophouse Podcast. It is my bad movie podcast. I co-host with Dan McCoy and Stuart Wellington It is as foolish and devoid of information as this podcast is serious literary and educational If you have a guest idea or just want to keep talking with fellow power broker fans Head to our discord to join in the link is on our website or you can go to discord.gg slash 99pi. Thanks again to Ben for suggesting Mike Schur as guest.
你可能已经注意到，迈克还没有说完关于是什么让这本书的最后一行如此优美的想法。好吧，如果你以前没读过这本书，我们只是……我们不想给你剧透。我们才进行到一半。我们现在不想泄露最后一行，但我们太喜欢迈克所说的话了。他对此有很多绝妙的想法和见解，我们将把这些留到本系列的最后一期节目中。所以敬请期待。你会在合适的时间听到这些。99%的“权力的经纪人”深度解析由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作，委员会剪辑，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，达拉·希尔施（Dara Hirsch）混音。99PI的执行制作人是凯西·图（Cathy Tu）。我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。柯克·科尔斯蒂德（Kirk Colestead）是数字总监。其余
And you might have noticed that Mike didn't finish his thought about what makes the last line of the book so beautiful. Well, in case you haven't read it before, we just we didn't want to spoil it for you. We're only halfway through. We don't want to give away the last line right now, but we love what Mike said so much. He had so many great ideas about it and thoughts that we are saving that for the end of the series. So stay tuned. You will hear it in the appropriate time. The 99% of visible breakdown of the power broker is produced by Isabel Angel edited by committee music by Swan Real mix by Dara Hirsch. 99 PIs executive producer is Cathy too. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kirk Colestead is the digital director. The rest
团队成员包括克里斯·巴鲁普（Chris Barrupe）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉特尼（Gabriella Glatney）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivienne Leigh）、拉什·马顿（Lash Madon）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、妮娜·波图克（Nina Potuck），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99PI的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。
of the team includes Chris Barrupe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Glatney, Martine Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne Leigh, Lash Madon, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor.
我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。
We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we have fun discussions about the power broker, about architecture, about movies, music, all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most of the time these days. You can find a link to the Discord server, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. If you have five more hours, I can keep talking. You know what?
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的住宅区上城。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站上找到我们，也可以在我们的Discord服务器上找到我们，在那里我们进行关于“权力的经纪人”、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种好东西的有趣讨论。这些天我大部分时间都在那里闲逛。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到 Discord 服务器的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。如果你还有五个小时，我可以继续聊下去。你知道吗？
I just gave us a wrap up point. Because we gave us an hour, but like, I have tons more questions. I actually probably need to go actually do my actual job. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我刚刚给自己设定了一个收尾点。因为我们给了自己一个小时，但我其实还有海量的问题。我其实可能得去真正做我真正的工作了。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。